Es ist ein stilnumerler Mittwoch irgendwo in Deutschland. Vier Computerfreaks unterhalten sich. Über dies und das und jenes. Herr Bader lag in seinem Bademantel im Bad und schaute auf die Uhr. Den Termin um acht konnte er in seinem Zustand nicht wahrnehmen, das wusste er ganz genau. Aber was bloß hatte ihn jetzt so aus der Bahn geworfen? Also die vier Gläser rum von gestern bestimmt nicht. Da war er noch zum Großteil Mathe drin gewesen. Ja gut, gestern hatte ich einen. Es gab wohl in der letzten Zeit das ein oder andere Android-Smartphone, was er in der Hand gehabt hat. Aber waren die Dinger mittlerweile wirklich so verseucht, dass es auf ihn hätte überschlagen können? Zweifellos wuchsen neben die Zweifel. Und dann fiel es irgendwie schuppend von den Augen. 133 Sendungen war er nun dabei. Er fand das zu viel. Er weigerte sich auch nur eine Sendung älter zu werden. Als Gegenmittel empfahl er sich selbst eine Verjüngungskur der Brauerei Loscher. Dazu füllte er das Bad ranvoll mit dem göttlichen gelb-goldenen Saft aus den praktischen 0,5 Liter Flaschen. Neben dem herrlich prickelnde Gefühl konnte er jede Sekunde fühlen, die er selbst jünger wurde. Die Stimme der Jugend.
Und die Klammern nie stimmen. Ja gut, ich meine, obwohl Jason auch nicht per Hand schreiben will. Du vergisst immer an der falschen Stelle ein Komma oder hast 1 zu 4 und aah.
Ich bin auch mittlerweile grad am Überlegen für ein einfaches Problem, doch eine Datenbank zu schreiben, die einfach nur ein paar Felder hat, wo ich dann wieder Sachen reinschreiben kann. Also Datenbank-Interface, statt irgendwas selber zu bauen an Jason.
Also Markdown halte ich einfach für ein gescheitertes Format. Das ist ganz okay, um irgendwie was bold und italic zu machen und eine 1, 2, 3, 4, 5-Liste zu machen und vielleicht drei verschiedene Level von Hierarchien zu machen. Aber allein schon die absolute Adressierung von Level geht halt gar nicht. Dann willst du halt einmal was einrücken über fünf Seiten. Was gehst du? Du gehst in zehn Stellen und änderst irgendwie Lattenzaun, Lattenzaun, Lattenzaun, Lattenzaun, Lattenzaun, Lattenzaun.
Wie was einrücken? Na du willst halt irgendwas, was derzeit auch... Ja, da bist du aber bei LaTeX auch falsch aufgehoben.
Ja, ich hab auch nicht gesagt, dass ich da richtig aufgehoben bin.
Du bist nirgendwo gut aufgehoben.
Das akzeptiere ich nicht.
Da ist da ein Problem.
Ich möchte gerne, dass das Internet mir eine Lösung liefert.
Lern programmieren.
Ich kann programmieren. Du wirst lachen, das war tatsächlich mal eins meiner ersten Projektsziele. Man überlegt manchmal, was könnte ich denn mal programmieren? Was reizt mich denn am meisten?
Was müsste am meisten mal gefixt werden? Dann kommen auch die besten Programme.
Es ist ja noch in der Zeit, wo es nichts gab. Da dachte ich so, was müsste man denn überhaupt mal schreiben?
Wolltest du eigentlich jemals einen Kalender fixen? Du hast ja mal dieses Kalenderthema gehabt.
Das habt ihr auch alle total missverstanden. Das war eine User-Interface-Kritik. Die ist auch teilweise gelöst worden nach zwei Jahren. So, ich wollte eine Textverarbeitung schreiben. Ich habe schon auf dem C64 damals mit großer Begeisterung Visa-Bereit verwendet. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand von euch noch im Ohr hat.
Ich habe das mal verwendet, aber...
Visa-Bereit war definitiv der beste Textprozessor auf dem C64. Das war also das erste Tool, was das mit den Absätzen hinbekommen hat, also was überhaupt so eine Vorstellung von einem Absatz hatte. Das war schon neu damals. Und ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr an zu viele Details, aber es war recht inspirierend, war nicht die Lösung aller Probleme, aber ich habe damit umfangreiche, mehrseitige Dokumente geschrieben. Viel und oft. Und so habe ich auch Deutsch gelernt. Also richtig. Und dann hatte ich irgendwie... Welcher Phase war denn das eigentlich? Muss so meine kurze DOS-Phase gewesen sein. Genau, es war meine kurze DOS-Phase. Ich hatte mal so für ein Jahr oder so, hatte ich glaube ich mal DOS, weil ich mir so ein PC gekauft habe, so aus Interesse, weil mir der Atari gestunken hat. Und dann war aber auch furchtbar. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mich dann mal einen Tag hingesetzt und habe mal so aufgeschrieben, was meiner Meinung nach eigentlich eine Textverarbeitung honorieren müsste. Also, welche Konzepte müssten in so einem Programm drin sein und wie müsste ein Programm das Prinzip Dokument, also Textdokument, verstehen? Und dann habe ich halt so verschiedene...
Für welche Texte?
Alle Texte. Textverarbeitung halt. Du schreibst etwas und wie...
Naja, aber es ist ja ein Unterschied, ob du jetzt einen Roman oder eine Gebrauchseinweisung schreibst.
Ja, Texte halt.
Er will die Universal-Lösung.
Wieso ist das ein Unterschied?
Weil du andere Dinge brauchst. Also ich meine, ein Roman ist im Wesentlichen eine Bleiwüste, wenn eine Gebrauchseinweisung halt hochstrukturiert ist mit Bildern und allem drum und dran. Und Achtung, Zeichen am Rand.
Ein Roman ist auch hochstrukturiert.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dafür gibt es ganz viele Software-Lösungen, dass du deine Chapter irgendwie hast und deine ganzen Charaktere mit Steckbrief und so weiter. Also das kannst du auch wissensunendliche treiben.
Ja, aber das ist trotzdem halt einfach was anderes.
Ich hab das alles mit berücksichtigt, keine Angst. So, und dann hab ich mir so einen Plan gemacht, dann hab ich mir vor allem irgendwie ein Konzept darüber gemacht, wie Formatierung und Text sozusagen zu trennen und zuzuordnen ist. So mit Absatzformatierung, Zeichenformatierung, Verabrung und so all diesen ganzen Sachen. Und dann dachte ich mir so geil, gutes Konzept. Und dann bin ich lustigerweise, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, auf Microsoft Word gestoßen, Version 3.0. Wohlgemerkt nicht für Windows, sondern das Original.
In schwarz-weiß, ne?
In schwarz-weiß.
Mit dem Menü unten.
Ja, genau mit dem Menü unten.
Daran denk ich mich noch dran.
Und Mark my Words, das war ein echt gutes Programm. Microsoft Word, also das Original Word war wirklich toll. Das war schnell und ich hab dann meine Ansprüche verglichen und dachte, okay, alles klar, gibt's schon. Und hab das dann nie so richtig weiterverfolgt.
Du kannst ja auf eBay schauen.
Du musst deinen, warte mal, ich fixe mal hier.
Kannst du auf eBay schauen, vielleicht gibt es noch einen alten Rechner und dann kannst du dir...
Nee, das ist mittlerweile auch komplett raus. Später wurde das ja von meinem anderen Traumprogramm von Framemaker ersetzt, beziehungsweise hab ich damit Word nicht viel gemacht, weil ich einfach mit DOS nicht viel gemacht hab. Ich hab irgendwie DOS schnell wieder sein lassen und mich anderen Dingen zugewendet. Das war ja auch nicht zu vertragen. Worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Das Textverarbeitung muss irgendwie elegant sein, muss schnell sein, muss ordentlich strukturiert sein und ich bin immer wieder entsetzt, wenn ich mir so anschaue, was heutzutage alles so falsch gemacht wird. Und als ich dann das erste Mal WinWird gesehen habe, oh man, oh das war so furchtbar. Das ist ja auch immer noch furchtbar. Gut, keine Lösung gefunden. Fangen wir das einfach an.
Ist wahrscheinlich auch, ab einer gewissen Komplexität gibt es ja nicht die perfekte Lösung. Da gibt es irgendwie viele Lösungen und eine ist besser und die andere ist schlechter.
Ja, aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass man solche Gedankendokumente umfangreicher Art von irgendwie 20 Seiten nicht irgendwie internetkompatibel erstellen und sharen kann.
Aber Tim, das ist den gleichen Vortrag, kannst du zu 15 verschiedenen anderen Software-Einheiten vortragen? Als Stimme der Hörer, das was ich dir schon immer mal sagen wollte, seit drei Jahren höre ich den Podcast, seit drei Jahren möchte ich dir das dann in dem Moment immer sagen, es gibt auch andere Nutzergruppen da draußen, die haben andere Bedürfnisse, die haben andere Prioritäten und deine Idealvorstellungen, die du immer formulierst, ist nicht das, was die Mehrheit der Nutzer braucht.
Das ist mir vollkommen egal.
Das weiß ich, das ist mir vollkommen klar.
Nur weil die Mehrheit sich mit weniger zufrieden gibt, muss ich ja noch lange nicht meine Ansprüche zurückfahren.
Lass dich auf deine Software maßschneidern, nur für dich, das ist ein bisschen teuer, aber dann mach ich alles, was du brauchst.
Es ist ja nicht nur, dass sie weniger wollen, sie sind mit der Komplexität überfordert. Das ist sozusagen das Kernproblem. Das, was du willst, ist an sich technisch überhaupt kein Problem. Es ist sozusagen der Trend, und das ist ja, wie du es auch bei Apple so insgesamt, dass sie sozusagen weggehen von dem Profitool hin zu dem, was sozusagen die 80-Prozent-Schnitt braucht. Und das ist sozusagen der Sweetspot, den die meisten Menschen, die Geld verdienen wollen, sozusagen anstreben. Weil sozusagen die 100-Prozent-Lösung hat zu viele Knöpfe, um es mal ganz blöd zu sagen, für die meisten Anwender. Und sozusagen es gibt dann für die Profi-Anwender, die ja, es ist...
Hallo, die Leute benutzen Word, und hast du mal gezählt, wie viele Knöpfe das hat? Das ist doch genau das Problem. Komplexität ist auch was vollkommen anderes als kompliziert. Also kompliziert gibt es da draußen viel. Man kann ein komplexes Problem auch elegant lösen. Ja, also ein User-Interface muss ja nicht zwangsläufig kompliziert sein, um ein komplexes Problem zu lösen, sondern es zeugt geradezu von einer guten Lösung eines komplexen Problems, wenn das User-Interface klar ist und wenn auch Formate klar sind. Du kannst ja auch so ein Word-Datei nicht parsen und nicht nixen.
Ich möchte mich ungern in die Position begeben, um jetzt Word zu verteidigen, aber ich möchte gerne sagen, dass du dieses Phänomen immer beobachtest, dass die Reduzierung eher gerade stattfindet bei den meisten User-Programmen und Software-Lösungen. Die schmeißen eher noch Funktionen raus, die eben nur von 0,1 Prozent der Nutzung genutzt werden, sozusagen Zwecksvereinfachung. Und du hast natürlich Recht, dass es eigentlich ginge, aber es ist natürlich ökonomisch gesehen für den Hersteller immer besser, sich auf das 80-Prozent-Modell zu verlassen, weil da muss er nicht in die Pflege von Funktionen investieren, die sozusagen nur für die Minderheit nutzern, relevant ist.
Das hängt ja ganz von deiner Zielgruppe ab. Ich meine, wenn deine Zielgruppe Leute sind, die technische Dokumentation schreiben, dann schreibst du ja nicht für Leute, die fünf Zeilen Brief in schlecht formatiert und auf den meisten Druckern kommt es sogar auf einer Seite raus schreiben.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich schreibe meine Briefe immer mit Text-Edit. Da gibt es diese Funktion Seitenränder einblenden und dann geht's los.
Ja, und schreibst immer wieder alles komplett neu.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, mit freundlichen Grüßen an bei erhalten sie.
Ja, das ist deine einzige Aufgabe, was ja nicht die Aufgabe von der ich gerade sprach. Ich rede ja von einem White Paper, was man schreibt und was halt sowohl in Form als auch in Funktion in Git gut darstellbar ist.
Na ja, wie gesagt, du hast ja zwei Möglichkeiten.
Naja, das sehe ich halt überhaupt nicht so. Ich habe mich in dem Zusammenhang, ich habe zum Beispiel mit diesen Transkripten, über die wir letztes Mal gesprochen haben, mich jetzt auch mit dem Problem auseinandergesetzt, wie kriege ich das Ganze im PDF ordentlich? Also wie kriege ich sozusagen aus so einer generischen Datenbank Informationen, die die Transkripte ja letzten Endes sind, auch ordentlich was im PDF auf den richtigen Weg? Und bin so halb zum Ziel gekommen, bis ich festgestellt habe, dass die Art und Weise, wie unsere Transkripte intern gespeichert werden, derzeit noch nicht optimal ist. Wenn sich das ändert, werde ich dann den zweiten Schritt gehen. Aber ich habe einen guten alten Bekannten wieder getroffen in dem Zusammenhang, der eigentlich ganz cool ist. Und zwar das gute alte XSL in seiner ursprünglichen Inkarnation FO. Was heißt das? Also der XSL-Standard, also XML Style Sheets, ist ja dazu gedacht, XML-Dokumente in andere XML-Dokumente zu überführen. Das ist dieser Transformationsteil, also das XSLT. Und das eigentliche Ziel von Anfang an, was aber erst Jahre später so richtig implementiert wurde, aber mittlerweile, wie es scheint, ganz ordentlich funktioniert, ist FO, nämlich ein bestimmter XML, ein bestimmter XML-Syntax, mit der ich halt Formatting-Objects definiere. Das heißt, ich kann halt sagen, hier sind Dinge auf Seiten, hier sind Header, hier sind Futter, hier sind Spalten, das läuft über mehrere Seiten etc. Man kann Bilder platzieren. Also man hat quasi so eine Art XML-basierten PDF-Generator. Und man kann dann quasi seinen Inhalt in XML, in diese FO-Objekte definieren. Und da ist dann halt XSL als Transformationssprache, also XSLT als Transformationssprache, sehr gut geeignet. Und am Ende, wenn man diese FO-Dateien hat, die also XML-Dateien sind, dann wirfst du das in einen sogenannten FO-Prozessor, da gibt es von Apache Open Source dieses Apache FOP. Und dann kommt da PDF-Buy raus. Und das ist schon mal eine ganz gute Basis, wenn man quasi vorne so eine Textlogik hat und am Ende geht es nur darum, jetzt soll das Ganze irgendwie auch schön aussehen, und kannst halt das nehmen, weil du kannst halt im Prinzip aus FO auch Hypertext machen und das irgendwie in andere Systeme überführt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier der optimale Weg wäre, daraus HTML zu machen. Wahrscheinlich eher besser, man macht vorher die Transformation gleich in HTML, aber im Prinzip ist das eine ganz gute Basis für alles, was so Seiten-orientiert funktioniert. Also auch wenn man so Präsentationsslides daraus machen will oder so, kann man das halt mit xsl.fo ganz ordentlich machen und dann hättest du als Tagelformat halt PDF. Also du formulierst das in FO, dann ist es immer noch XML und dann renderst du es und dann hast du halt PDF-Dateien, die dann halt auch Links haben und all diesen ganzen Kram, den man eben haben will, ohne irgendwas von Hand zu machen. Sofern du eben überhaupt erst mal eine generische Struktur hast, in was du dir die dann anlegst, ob das aus einer Datenbank kommt oder aus eigenen XML-Dateien, ist natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Sprich, das muss ich eben letztlich dafür sorgen, dass ich meine Transkripte in XML, in einem ordentlichen XML-Darstellung habe, weil er das durch so eine Transformation, und dann kann ich halt für meine Webseite automatisch PDFs erzeugen, wo eben dieses Transkript drauf ist. Wo dann halt so, wie man das so im Slack einen Dialog liest, quasi auf Papier ist. Das ist schon mal eine ganz interessante Sache, da bin ich jetzt gerade mal wieder so ein bisschen mehr am Forschen, wenn ich Zeit finde, zwischendurch.
Die Monolog-Alarm-Lampe ist angegangen.
Ich hab mich nicht getraut als Gast.
Ja, you lost me at X.
XML ist gut für dich.
Du erinnertest mich gerade so ein bisschen an diesen Comic von Toggl, How to Slay a Dragon. Wie heißt die eine Sprache? How to Slay a Dragon. Warte, ich such's gerade raus.
Hast dir was angerichtet, Letty.
Das ist so wie Kalender, das schreibt man einfach nicht auf. Auf gewisse Themen schreibt man einfach nicht auf.
Ich hätte nichts dafür, wenn ich überall was zu sagen habe.
Ich dachte, du bist ein müde Mann.
Ich hab doch gesagt, ich bin jetzt schon wieder auf Temperatur.
Genau, Kill Dragon Comic.
Wir können ja mal über Apple reden. Was haltet ihr denn davon, wir haben ganz viel Apple-Themen.
Der Haskell-Typ, an den hast du mich erinnert aus dem Comic. Warte, ich schmeiß das Comic mal eben.
Ihr werdet schon irgendwann feststellen, dass ich mal Recht gehabt habe.
Ich find das eigentlich total gut, wenn du dir Gedanken machst. Der Meinung ist, dass du Recht hast. Ich find das ja faszinierend, wie Tim Konzepte für sozusagen die konzeptualen Probleme von gewissen Online-Produkten definiert. Es ist nur, die Lösung, sich anzuhören, ist nicht immer bedrückend.
Die Lösung finde ich auch nicht beglückend, die da draußen sind.
Hier scrollen wir noch ein bisschen weiter. Da gibt es irgendwann, also da gibt es diesen Comic, How to kill a dragon in nine programming languages. Und dann gibt es weiter unten den You have Haskell in a monad. Und dann fängt er an und am Ende steht er vor der brennenden Mülltonne You need help.
Naja, CoffeeScript, Haskell, Dua, Kobold, C-Lattensounds, Scala, C-S-L-Z-T-M-L, Swift, Python, Alexi ist ja auch nicht dabei.
Der Swift-Typ ist auch nicht schlecht. Just as you are done, Apple releases a new dragon.
Lass mal über Apple reden. Wir haben verschiedene Apple-Sachen. Wo wir letztes Mal nicht drüber gesprochen haben, glaube ich, ist diese... Wer hat denn das hier überhaupt eingetragen? Hab ich das eingetragen?
Das war von der letzten Sendung.
Das war von der letzten Sendung, ja.
Das MacGo ist jetzt irgendwann nur noch 64-Bit-Applikation erlaubt und die 32-Bit, wenn es dann noch welche gibt, also ich habe glaube ich keine mehr, werden einfach nicht mehr gestartet dann.
Ja, kurz vor der WWDC wird Apple für den App Store Apps ablehnen, die noch 32-Bit enthalten.
Inzwischen kriegt man ja schon eine Warnung, wenn man sie startet, ne? Damit man schon mal Bescheid weiß.
Ich habe schon Horror-Vorstellungen, wenn die das durchziehen, die ganzen Drucker-Apps und Scanner-Apps und sonstigen Hilfe von...
Im App Store.
Ach, nur?
Es ist erstmal nur der App Store.
Es kommen keine neuen mehr.
Nur die Sachen im App Store ab. Du kannst also keine Updates mehr machen zu Apps oder neue Apps einreichen, die 32-Bit enthalten. Wann sie dann den 32-Bit-Support komplett rauswerfen, steht auf einem anderen Blatt. Nur, wenn man jetzt argumentiert, der ARM-Prozessor kommt, dann werden sie sicherlich einen ARM-Prozessor bauen für den Mac. Der ARM-Prozessor für den Mac. Dann werden sie einen bauen, der keinen 32-Bit-Support hat. Das ist meine Vermutung. Und um das vorzubereiten, versuchen sie jetzt alles, was 32-Bit ist, loszuwerden.
Weil 64-Bit ARM und 64-Bit Intel ja nichts miteinander zu tun hat. Also das besteht ja keinerlei Notwendigkeit in dieser Transition.
Moment, wenn du einen Source-Code hast, der unter 64-Bit nicht kompiliert, dann unter 64-Bit Intel, dann wird er auch unter 64-Bit ARM nicht kompilieren. Good point. Und deswegen glaube ich halt, also aus den letzten Transitionen, die ich so mitgemacht habe bei Apple, ist es halt so, dass zum Beispiel die Transition von PowerPC zu Intel war halt die Endiness das Problem, aber nicht, dass es ein anderer Zeichensatz ist. Und die Transition von Intel zu ARM, gut, das eine war Mac OS, das andere war iOS, aber da war das Problem überhaupt nicht der Prozessor, sondern dass du halt, dass der Set von APIs nicht so ganz hundertprozentig ist, wohingegen der Übergang von 32bit zu 64bit deutlich schmerzhafter war, als diese anderen beiden Transitionen.
Das ist ein guter Punkt, ja.
Ja oder läuft gar nicht, also wenn du Code hast, der irgendwie in Strukturen rumgräbt, die halt davon ausgehen, dass das 32bit ist und alles dann funktioniert nicht.
Aber wie ist denn das, ich hab das gar nicht jetzt noch mehr verfolgt, aber wie verhält sich denn so 64bit Intel Code zu 32bit Intel-Code-Performance-mäßig? Also auf ARM war das ja auch von der Performance her ein großer Sprung.
Ich glaube bei Intel war es schon auch ein Sprung, ja.
Also das gibt ja, also ich fände ja immer, dass es ein Urban Legend ist, aber vielleicht ist es auch nicht ganz so. Es ist schon so, dass durch die 64bit Pointer brauchst du halt mehr Speicher, wenn du halt viele Pointers, und die hat man ja nun mal in so einem Programm. Das heißt, das ist schon ein Nachteil, weil du musst dadurch auch mehr Memory durch die Gegend schieben und so weiter und so fort. Das ist eigentlich sozusagen, könnte man sagen, das ist langsamer. Aber da 64bit halt eben nicht nur 64bit ist, sondern die haben ja auch mehr Register und so weiter, weil x86 hat ja eigentlich mehr oder weniger keine. Und bei 64bit gibt es dann mal ordentlich welche, ist alles deutlich schneller durch, dass man halt mal Register ordentlich benutzen kann, so wie es sich gehört. Und das holt den Speed wieder raus. Und meiner Meinung nach ist das halt am Ende ein Win. Also das bisschen Memory da stört nicht so. Da sind viele Leute aber andere Meinung, weil die sagen mal, ja es braucht ja mehr Speicher. Aber Programme selbst, ja weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, dass ARM viel stärker relative Sprünge benutzt. Und dann hast du ja, du machst ja selten einen relativen Sprung über 64-Bit-Adressraum. Und dann hast du halt weniger Beize in deinem Code, wo du tatsächlich springen musst. Also ich das...
Also x86 kann ich relativ springen?
Also ich sag mal so, es gibt gute Gründe, Intel 32-Bit an sich auch zu verlassen. Einer davon mag ein Wechsel auf ARM 64-Bit sein. Einer, aber ist nicht der einzige. Sondern es ist generell auch, sagen wir mal, der Wunsch, sich zu erneuern auf der Plattform.
Ja, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Intel jetzt ein Chip rausbringt, wo sie den 32-Bit-Support wegschmeißen.
Aber ein OS, in dem keine 32-Bit-Libraries mehr sind. Wo sie quasi das ganze Betriebssystem und den ganzen 32-Bit-Code entschlacken können.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Aber macht das nicht auch Sinn, wenn sie auf ihrem Silicon den 32-Bit-Quatsch alles mal weglassen?
Ja, aber sie werden das bei Intel, glaube ich, nicht tun.
Nee, bei Intel nicht, aber...
Bei ARM werden sie es auf jeden Fall tun. Also die ARM-Prozessoren...
Deswegen war, das war ja meine Argumentation, dass es danach riecht, dass sie dann auf ARM gehen, weil ARM da nie 32-Bit haben wird. Und dann musst du halt darauf vorbereitet sein.
Hatten wir überhaupt eigentlich schon über diese 64-Bit-Rumors gesprochen? Überhaupt?
Was über die 64-Bit-Rumors? Nein, die 64-Bit-Transition, das hatte ich zur letzten Sendung eingetragen.
Es gab doch jetzt die Meldung, es gab doch diesen Bloomberg-Artikel, wo halt mal wieder gesagt wurde, ARM wird kommen.
2020, was haben die gesagt, ne?
Hatten wir das besprochen?
Ja, wir hatten das.
Nur, dass die das jetzt offiziell angekündigt hatten, dass sie kein 32-Bit mehr haben wollen, darüber haben wir nicht gesprochen.
Wie konkret haben sie sich denn hier geäußert? Dass sie... Okay, jetzt gibt es diesen Alert unter 10.3.
Also, du musst 64-Bit unterstützen. Genau, du musst 64-Bit unterstützen. Also, 32-Bit alleine geht nicht mehr. Wenn du im Mac App Store publishen willst, aber das ist natürlich so ein bisschen der Hebel, mit dem sie wahrscheinlich anfangen zu biegen.
Na ja, schon diese Warnungsmeldung hat jetzt extrem viel Bewegung ins Spiel gebracht. Also, ich hatte tatsächlich noch so einiges in 32-Bit rumliegen und auf einmal blumm die Blumen, kamen überall so ach ja, übrigens hier Update und 64-Bit und testen wir schon seit einem Jahr und jetzt können wir es ja auch mal releasen und so hust hust. So, hier unter anderem meine Buchhaltungssoftware und so weiter, war dann auf einmal auch so heute auf morgen dann doch mal 64-Bit. Und wie du schon sagst, diese ganze Scanner. Ja, genau, das ist die Chippo-Software. Ja, Chippo, ich weiß gar nicht, was das Problem da ist. Das sind einfach Leute, die sich nicht ausreichend kümmern. Oder Firmen, die nicht genug in diese Programmierer investieren, um da mal eine regelmäßige Produktpflege zu machen, sondern die quasi sagen, naja, wieso denn? Der Scanner ist ja vor drei Jahren erschienen. Da brauchen wir jetzt auch keine neue Software zu machen.
Schrieben, das Projekt.
Ja, bis dann alle schreien. Und das ist halt immer das Problem. Aber das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall eine Menge Welle bringen. Und allein schon in dieser Woche, seit einer Woche ist das draußen, hab ich also diverse Software-Updates bekommen auf verschiedenen Sachen. Und ich hab jetzt vor allem auch viel Zeug auch irgendwie weggeschmissen.
Was ist seit einer Woche draußen?
Das 10.3.10.4 oder zwei Wochen? Ich weiß grad nicht.
Ist doch egal, ist schon eine Weile draußen. Gestern kam ja schon das Update auf 10.13.4.1.
Ich bin mir auf jeden Fall immer sicherer, dass diese ARM-Transition stattfinden wird, dass wir irgendwie Macs sehen werden mit 64-Bit ARM-Prozessoren.
Ich auch.
Und ich glaube auch, dass die...
Ich hoffe, dass sie sich damit nicht in den Schub Fuß schießen, wie gesagt. Weil halt doch da sehr viele Backend-Entwickler da draußen sind, die halt auf Docker setzen. Und du kannst jetzt von Docker sagen, was du willst, aber das ist halt Intel.
Warum, was hat das mit Intel zu tun?
Na, weil in dem Docker-Container läuft halt ein Linux, ein Intel-Linux.
Ja, aber in dem Docker-Container kann doch genauso gut auch ein ARM-Linux laufen.
Ja, aber nur wenn du auch ARM-Server hast. Was aber niemand hat oder kaum jemand.
Ich verstehe jetzt gerade auch den Bogen nicht.
Also, wenn du lokal auf deiner Maschine Docker-Container entwickeln willst, dann müssen die natürlich auch dort lauffähig sein.
Ja.
Sprich, du lässt den Code laufen, der hinterher auch auf dem Server läuft. Aber Server gibt es auch immer mehr ARM. Ja, das mag ja sein. Nur, wenn du halt da draußen deine, ob es jetzt private oder public Cloud ist, die komplett aus Intel-Prozessoren besteht und du willst auf einem ARM-Rechner lokalen Docker-Container entwickeln, dann müsste der ja in einer virtuellen Maschine laufen, die wiederum halt Intel-Code interpretiert. Und dann wird es fürchterlich langsam. Also an diese Leute kannst du dann den ARM-Rechner nicht verkaufen, weil die brauchen den Intel-Prozessor.
Ich denke, dass gerade im Serverbereich ARM gerade riesige Fortschritte macht.
Das mag durchaus sein, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass halt Docker-Container auf Intel-Maschinen entwickelt werden und dann halt auch deployed werden.
Ich glaube, du guckst da auf so eine Gruppe von Leuten, die erstmal nicht für das erste Gerät interessant sind.
Die benutzt keiner Docker mit Raspberry Pi und irgendwie anderen ARM-Maschinen. Das kannst du mir noch nicht erzählen.
Rechenzentren.
Ja, aber auch in Rechenzentren.
Hochverfügbar und so weiter.
Ja, da sind jetzt ARM-Prozessoren der Hit, weil sie halt extrem viel weniger Strom hauen. Cloudfair hat gerade angekündigt, dass sie überhaupt keine Intel-Maschinen mehr kaufen.
Die kaufen dann so ARM-Cores mit 48 Kernen.
Cloudfair ist eh ganz interessant. Da gab es vor ein paar Monaten schon mal einen Blogpost von diesem Tech-Hat, also von dem VC-CTO, der schon seit längerer Zeit Benchmarks gemacht hat. Der hat dann mal Benchmarks veröffentlicht mit ARM-Prozessoren und mit Intel-Prozessoren. Und da war dann schon sehr deutlich sichtbar, dass...
Ist das mit den beiden Kilowatts?
Ich müsste den linken... Vielleicht kann der Chat uns da mal kurz helfen. Cloudflare, Blog, ARM, Server, Performance. So als Suchkeyword. Auf jeden Fall war die Essenz die, dass... Und für sie ist ja auch Performance relativ wichtig. Jetzt bei Cloudflare, weil...
Absolut wichtig.
Ist generell wichtig, aber ist bei denen sozusagen etwas, was er sich halt sehr genau angeschaut hat. Und es gibt da ganz interessante Vergleiche. Hier haben wir auch den Logician ARM Takes Wing. Rainer, Dankeschön. Und in der Essenz hat er festgestellt, dass die ARM-Prozessoren insbesondere im Multicore Benchmarks mehr als nur mithalten können, sondern teilweise auch schon schneller sind. Und es nur bei manchen Benchmarks, wo halt noch Intel-optimierter Code drin ist, es eben entsprechende Einbrüche gibt.
Aber mit was vergleichen Sie denn? Pro Schnelle, Pro Megaz? Schnelle, Pro Watt verbraucht? Oder was ist der Vergleich?
Ist das IAO-Bound oder ist das CPU-Bound?
Na ja, das sind hier so RSA-Krypto-Sachen. Das sind hier verschiedene Tests, die er gemacht hat.
Weil da die großen Player da draußen, die fahren halt sehr, sehr viel Java. Und Java braucht vor allen Dingen erstmal Speicher.
Das könnte voll knicken.
Nein, natürlich baut für Apple für solche Leute keine Rechner, aber die fahren halt solche Server. Klar, das kann natürlich passieren, dass Apple sagt, wir bauen jetzt nur noch ARM, und dann gibt es halt diverse Firmen, die sagen, ja ok, dann kaufen wir jetzt ThinkPad.
Nur noch werden sie wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht machen. Das wird wieder von...
Nicht nur noch, aber für die Leute, die halt entwickeln, die entwickeln dann halt nicht mehr auf Apple Artware.
Nein, die kaufen dann einfach einen anderen Apple erstmal.
Na welchen denn? Mcmini? Genau, was weiß ich? Ich weiß nämlich auch nicht, was man da gerade kaufen soll.
Das nächste MacBook Air kommt vielleicht mit einem ARM, und dann muss man ihre Docker woanders machen.
Zweiter Punkt, Cloudflare hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie nur noch ARM-Server kaufen werden, also offensichtlich sind sie mittlerweile, also dieser Blogpost ist jetzt vom November 2017, da mag sich schon ein bisschen was getan haben. Außerdem meinten sie halt, selbst wenn die Dinger noch langsamer sind oder teurer zu kaufen sind, das Geld sparen sie sich locker wieder rein beim Stromverbrauch. Die ARM-Server wären einfach so dermaßen viel mehr Speicher-Savvy, was einfach mal bei großen Data-Centers, was hab ich gesagt?
Speicher-Savvy.
Ja, genau. Strom-Savvy, dass sich das einfach bei solchen großen Installationen doppelt und dreifach lohnt. Allein schon von dem Gesamtstrombedarf, den du hast, nicht nur, dass er weniger kostet, sondern muss er genauer herkennen.
Der hat aber auch eine sehr spezielle Anwendung.
Die müssen halt auch auf den Strom gucken, genau.
Ja, die haben eine sehr spezielle Anwendung.
Alle haben spezielle Anwendungen.
Aber ist es nicht so, wie Dennis letztlich gesagt hat, dass der Transit insofern einfach gemacht werden kann, indem man zwei Modell-Serien läuft. Man läuft noch ein bisschen mit Intel. Und dann gibt es die neuen Fancy-Max mit ARM. Und man lässt jetzt mal noch beides für zwei, drei Jahre existieren. Man weiß aber, wo die Zukunft ist. Und diejenigen, die noch ein bisschen alte Software laufen lassen müssen, können sich dann noch... Aber ich meine, das ist nicht Apple Style.
Das ist überhaupt nicht Apple Style. Und es ist auch völlig unglaubwürdig, dass sie das machen. Also wenn sie umsteigen, dann stellen sie alles um.
Und darüber habe ich auch nachgedacht und habe dann eine steile These, weil es geht ja mit diesem Argument, oh ja, für diese paar Mac Pros jetzt nochmal High-End-Versionen von ihren Prozessoren zu bauen, wie soll sich denn das lohnen? Auch vollziehbares Argument. Und da habe ich mich erinnert, dass ja vor einer Weile schon mal die Nachricht kam, dass Apple für seine eigenen Data Center keine Manbords mehr in China kauft.
Nee, keine Manbords mehr von Supermicro.
Oder von Supermicro. Aber ich glaube, das lässt sich in eine generelle Skepsis gegenüber diesen Herstellern hin übersetzen. Und wenn ich mal so mein 1&1 zusammenzähle, denke ich mir so, ja, warum baut sich denn Apple nicht einfach seine eigenen Server? Sie brauchen da viele von, sie haben da spezielle Anwendungen.
Ja, aber viele ist ja nun auch ein bisschen relativ, oder?
Was meinst du, wie viele Maschinen sie haben?
Was meinst du, wie viele Maschinen Supermicro verkauft?
Das ist ja egal. Apple kann sich doch selber ihren eigenen Prozessoren...
Sie brauchen genug, dass es sich lohnt, sich mal selber zu machen.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall mehr Eigenbedarf an Servern in ihren iCloud-Datenzentren, als sie Mac Pros verkaufen. Aber sie haben vergleichbare Anforderungen an diese Prozessoren, abgesehen davon, dass es vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt immer im Reinen ist. Number-Crunching für alle Fälle, wo so ein Mac Pro glänzen muss. Aber du brauchst halt schnelle Krypto-Performance. Du brauchst einfach generell maximale Performance. Und warum sollten sie nicht ihre Prozessorschmiede damit beauftragen, zu sagen, ok, ihr baut jetzt mal hier eine schnelle Variante, die im Prinzip von Feststrom ausgeht?
Du meinst...
Also Steckdosenstrom und nicht Akkustrom darf mehr Strom ziehen, ist nicht auf Batterie hin, optimiert, wie jetzt die ganzen iPhone-Prozessoren oder Laptops, sondern halt mehr so iMac und Mac Pro Style und das selbe, oder nicht das selbe, aber ein sich in diesem Bereich bewegendes Anforderungsprofil hast du halt im Data Center auch. Du brauchst viele Cores, du willst over Performance haben, Stromverbrauch ist jetzt nicht so mega kritisch, es geht nicht so sehr um Stromsparen um jeden Preis, um irgendeine Akkulaufzeit lange rauszuzögern.
Na ja, bei Apple schon, weil die müssen ja ihren Solarstrom nutzen und kriegen sonst so einen Greenpeace aufs Dach.
Ja, aber du hast bei ARM-Prozessoren generell weniger Stromverbrauch als bei dir.
Du musst vor allen Dingen allen Strom, den du verbrauchst, hinterher durch die Klimaanlage wieder wegkühlen.
Genau, man braucht immer das Doppelte.
Ja, ich meine, ich gehe davon aus, dass sie mit diesen ARM-Prozessoren eh besser dran sind als mit den Inselteilen. Nur das Optimierungsziel dieser Prozessoren ist nicht, dass die maximale Batteriekapazität zu erhalten, sondern Performance zu haben. Wenn sie dann immer noch bei gleicher Performance weniger Strom verbrauchen als Intel, ist immer noch genug gewonnen. Nur es geht darum, so schnell wie möglich zu sein. Also von dieser Architektur her, so schnell vom Aufbau. Und genau dasselbe Prinzip können sie dann eben auch für Mac Pros oder iMac Pros verwenden. Und sie haben trotzdem einen Skalenfaktor. Der ist nicht derselbe Skalenfaktor, wie die ganze Welt kauft, diese Sachen. Aber sie haben immerhin noch einen Skalenfaktor, der ein Vielfaches von Mac Pro in iMac Pro Umsatz ist.
Supermicro ist übrigens eine kalifornische Bude.
Aber es hieß doch, dass sie da bestimmte Mainboards aus Taiwan oder China...
Na, die lassen sie bestimmt auch in China herstellen. Und die drei Gründe haben auch chinesische Namen, würde ich mal behaupten. Aber es ist San Jose irgendwie. Californien-based.
Ja, wahrscheinlich herstellen die alles in China her. Nur die Firma sitzt halt dort. Du hast natürlich nur noch Ausfallsicherheit. Uns und Server muss halt auch IO machen. Der muss vor allen Dingen IO machen. Also Rechenleistung ist gar nicht so entscheidend. Also für so einen normalen Wald- und Wiesen-Server. Weil der packt halt Bits von rechts nach links und vor und zurück und in die Datenbank und aus der Datenbank wieder raus und in den Kafka-Stream und aus dem Kafka-Stream wieder raus und ach, wie es das alles heißt.
Genau, so wie Mac Pro. Der macht auch viel IO.
Ich fände das mal ganz angemessen, wenn sie so einen Server bauen, dass sie ihn dann auch verkaufen würden. Ja, X-Surf! Es muss ja nicht unbedingt ein hübscher X-Surf sein, aber einfach mal ein Stück Cardware, was irgendwie was kann und was man sich bei uns unter den Schreibtisch stellen kann.
Aber das, was die dann da bauen, wenn sie das so machen, so Rechenzentren-mäßig, dann Google macht das ja auch. Ich glaube, die haben ja auch so Boards, die haben gar keine Gehäuse mehr, haben eine eigene Batterie drauf, damit sie gebuffert sind, damit sie keine USVs kaufen müssen. Da hat jedes Board seine eigene kleine Billigbatterie. Und sie haben keinen Wechselstrom mehr, sondern die kriegen irgendwie so 48 oder 24 oder 12 Volt direkt angeliefert. Schon weil das auch effektiver ist, als jedem dem extra nochmal so ein Netzteil zu geben.
Hatte nicht sogar Facebook angekündigt, dass sie auch eigene Prozessoren entwickeln wollen? Oder habe ich das mir...
Ja, die haben jetzt inzwischen auch so viel Hardware, dass es sich da auch langsam mal lohnt. Dann kommt halt irgendein so ein Typi an, rechnet das einmal durch, ob sich das lohnt oder nicht. Und dann wird halt entschieden, ja, wir können da 10 Prozent sparen, und dann macht man das.
Also solange du wirklich vom blanken Metall bis ganz oben an der Anwendung alles unter deinen Fittichen hast, dann lohnt sich das auch. Wenn du aber eigentlich solche Ressourcen woanders einkaufst, dann bist du sowieso ein bisschen davon abhängig, was das Datacenter dir bietet. Also ich meine...
Aber ich meine, Apple hat ja wirklich alles. Vom Datacenter über die CPUs, die können ja wirklich das alles designen.
Im Prinzip ja.
Haben sie auch schon.
Ich glaube, und ich halte das für sehr möglich.
Ich halte es auch für möglich, dass sie es machen. Ich bin mir nur nicht 100 Prozent sicher, ob es der richtige Schritt ist für alle Apple-User. Und dass sie, wenn sie von Intel weggehen, halt einen Teil verlieren, weil die sagen, wir brauchen umverlinkt Intel-Kompatibilität, damit wir in irgendwelchen virtuellen Boxen irgendwelche anderen Betriebssysteme laufen lassen können.
Ich möchte gerne einen ARM-Prozessor haben in meinem Mac alleine schon, um mich wieder über Intel-Chips lustig machen zu können, wie früher.
Das sehe ich ein. Aber wir haben ja gerade eben schon festgestellt, dass du nicht so bist, wie andere User.
Sei froh! Ich hab mal diesen Artikel rausgesucht, den ich gerade meinte. Aussage von dem CEO. ARM wäre für sie sogar billiger, wenn sie die ganzen x86-Prozessoren kostenlos bekommen würden. Das ist ein Preis, wo Intel nicht richtig mithalten kann. Weil sie sich so viel Strom sparen würden dadurch. Das ist schon eine Ansage. Genau, zumal es dann nicht nur die reine Performance ist. Weil dann kaufst du halt im Zweifelsfall einfach mehr. Wenn ihr dann weniger Strom braucht, kann es ja auch egal sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier noch genauere Zahlen geben. Das ist hier so ein Interview, das hier zusammengefasst wird.
By the way, lagert Apple seine iCloud derzeit auf eigenen Datenzentren? Ich meine, ich weiß, dass sie eins haben, ein größeres. Aber ich hatte vor kurzem gelesen, dass sie jetzt umgestiegen sind zu Google. Sogar, dass sie in die Hälfte der eigenen Daten der iCloud inzwischen auf Google-Servern liegt. Ich glaube, sie waren von Amazon zu Google gewechselt.
Sie haben von Anfang an das gemacht. Als iCloud gestartet ist, haben sie genaue Zahlen. Wie viel das ist, habe ich nie gesehen. Aber sie haben das auf verschiedenen anderen Architekturen gemacht, um ihre eigene Infrastruktur mal zu bootstrapen. Mittlerweile haben sie diverse Data-Center. Wie viel Prozent ihres Eigenbedarfs, die das da hinbekommen, weiß ich nicht.
Ich fand es erstaunlich, dass sie sich dennoch getrennt haben. Und jetzt noch mal zu Google umgezogen. Das finde ich eigentlich auch schon PR-technisch relativ ungünstig, wenn man sozusagen die Privacy-Company ist. Obwohl es natürlich völlig wurscht ist, weil es natürlich für Schlüssel der Lage ist. Hoffe ich doch!
Da kannst du mal von ausgehen.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz fand ich es erstaunlich, wenn man jetzt nochmal umzieht, dann ist man noch, glaube ich, nicht 100% selbst versorgt. Also vielleicht sind sie noch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Getränke, irgendjemand?
Ah, wenn das die letzte Brause war.
Ich werde jetzt nur noch die Pfütze noch rufen.
Also keiner will Getränke.
Ich nehme Fanta.
Na ja, wenn das die letzte war, nicht.
Ich hatte da letztens auch so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, weil eben alle so darauf abfahren, Cloud-Computing zu betreiben und einfach irgendwo was gefüllt zu mieten. Ob man nicht eben, wenn man ein bisschen größer ist, irgendwann an einen Punkt kommt, wo es halt wirklich günstiger ist. Also wo ist es günstiger zu sagen, ja, am Anfang kaufe ich sowas wie Amazon ein und habe halt vielleicht trotz alledem, wenn ich eine große Firma bin, so eine tägliche Amazon-Rechnung von Tausenden von Euro. Wo kommt dann der Punkt, wo man sagt, es lohnt sich dann doch selber, die Infrastruktur zu haben, wo man, wie Huckel irgendwie meinte, bis ins kleinste technische Detail irgendwie das Optimum aus dem Server zum Beispiel heraus zu holen.
Das kann man nicht so richtig sagen, weil du deinen Bedarf nicht so vielleicht abschätzen kannst oder weil der halt nicht immer gleich ist. Also jetzt gerade zum Beispiel Pokémon GO. Ja, muss ich jetzt mal erwähnen. Nee, ich glaube, die machen es tatsächlich selber. Die haben das nicht in der Cloud. Bin mir aber auch nicht so sicher. Früher haben die das ja auf jeden Fall selber gemacht in Paris. Egal, jedenfalls Pokémon GO hat am Anfang irgendwie 500 Millionen User und der Typ hat ja auch mal geschrieben, sie haben im Worst Case sind sie von 50 Millionen ausgegangen und haben aber eher so für 10 Millionen geplant oder weiß ja nicht wie viele und haben gesagt, naja vielleicht werden es 50 Millionen, aber dann brennt alles, aber es wurden dann halt 500 Millionen User. So damit du sowas abfangen kannst, gehst du halt in die Cloud. Und was die gemacht haben, die haben einfach irgendein so ein Button geklickt, haben gesagt, ja dann gibt uns halt eben dementsprechend mehr Clouds. Und dann war das Problem jetzt nicht gelöst. Sie mussten schon eine Menge machen, so auch traffic-mäßig und kostenmäßig. Sie haben irgendwie glaube ich so ein paar Features aus Pokemon Go entfernt, damit weniger Traffic stattfindet, also haben das ein bisschen durchoptimiert. Aber sie konnten einfach den Bedarf durch den Cloud-Kram einfach nach oben schrauben und als die User dann wieder weg sind, muss man auch nicht deine Haster verkaufen oder deinen Weiß schon die ganzen Verträge kündigen, sondern du sagst dir Amazon oder Google, ja wir brauchen jetzt ein bisschen weniger Cloud-Rechner und bumm fertig, das ist schon cool, wenn es sich so anpassen kann.
Ja vor allen Dingen, wenn du halt dieses User-Problem oder die Problematik der User und Skalierbarkeit hast.
Und ich meine, das ist ja so, ich weiß, ihr habt ja vielleicht auch selber eure eigene Hardware irgendwo zu stehen. Ich hab auch einen Rechner, der Mail macht und ein bisschen mambeln kann er und da läuft Bitcoin-Demon so nebenbei so ein bisschen. Also nicht als Mining, sondern nur als Note so. Aber ehrlich gesagt, der Rechner ist ja keine 10% ausgelastet. Und dann haben wir mal überlegt, das ist ja eigentlich total bekloppt, da die Festplatten rennen die ganze Zeit, alles rennt da die ganze Zeit, der Platz wird belegt, aber der Rechner wird eigentlich nur zu 10% benutzt. Und so ein Cloud-Ding, da sorgt Amazon halt dafür, dass die halt glühen, die Dinger, und dass die halt bis an den Rand irgendwie zu tun haben. Natürlich haben die so ein gewisses Limit und so weiter, also dass du halt immer ein bisschen kapazitätenfrei hast, aber die nutzen das eigentlich insgesamt viel besser aus, und das spart ja auch, ja, schont unsere Umwelt am Ende, wenn man das mal ganz unterm Strich betrachtet.
Die Data Center ja auch in zunehmendem Maße, also sich ja viel einfacher mit einem erneuerbaren Energiestrom versorgen lassen.
Von der Prozentzeit, Google.
Es gibt noch einen anderen Effekt, du willst ja, oder Aspekt, du willst ja, du willst ja eine Ausfallsicherheit haben. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich eine größere Firma bist, die davon abhängig ist, dass das System immer läuft, dann willst du einen Dual-Data-Center-Betrieb haben. Und wenn du das auf eigene Hardware machst, dann musst du auch zwei Data Center haben.
Und möglichst idealerweise schön weit voneinander wechseln, wenn Erdbeben kommt, nicht dein eigenes.
Erdbeben kommt, spielt eh keiner mehr Pokemon.
Genau, und dann kostet das halt nochmal richtig, wenn du halt zwei Data Center haben musst, mit zwei Anbindungen und, und, und, und, und.
Ja, ich hab mich das deswegen gefragt, so ein bisschen, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir über sowas überhaupt Gedanken gemacht habe. Das könnte gut sein, weil eben so dieses, ah, wann lohnt es sich wirklich, so Data Center gefüllt selber, oder Mini-Rechenzentrum selber zu haben. Und wenn du dann eben noch deine Software so optimieren kannst, genau, dass sie halt eben wirklich parallel auch, also so Parallel-Computing mit dem Ding betreiben kannst, dann wird es ja halt erst so richtig spannend. Aber ich glaube, meiner besten Freundin habe ich das erzählt und die meinte nur so, geh weg, das ist ein ekelhaftes Thema. Dafür ein bisschen Blaming bekommen. Aber das ist halt was, wo ich mir echt dachte so, wie muss ich das eigentlich aufbauen, damit ich so quasi den besten kosten-nutzen-Faktor habe.
Das ist ein total interessantes Thema. Nicht super einfach natürlich.
Weil ich nämlich auch gedacht habe, so bei einigen Sachen, also viele Software ist halt irgendwie, läuft halt nicht so verteilt oder wird nie so primär so entwickelt, dass es halt auch verteilt gut skaliert.
Ja, das ist auch total schwierig.
Ich hab ne total geile Vorlesung gehabt, auf die ich mich so gefreut habe, irgendwie hier Scalable Computing. Leider war mein Professor irgendwie ein bisschen krank und hat sehr langsam geredet zu C, Unscalable Computing. Das war eine harte Vorlesung.
Was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, dass ihr das alles gerade so positiv seht. Und das ist für mich gerade insofern neu, als dass es ja sonst immer hieß, so irgendwie, ja, cloud, gefährlich. Und irgendwie, es ist doch immer die Other People's Computer und so weiter.
Ja, so ist das ja auch.
Ja, natürlich ist es ja so. Aber was ich immer dachte dabei war, dass das natürlich immer von einem sehr hohen Ross ist. Wir sind wieder bei den 80 Prozent und 20 Prozent.
Ich hab ja mein eigener Rechner, muss ich ja eben nicht eine Business-Entscheidung treffen, dass ich da Geld spare, sondern ich mach das ja für mich und hab auch da Ansprüche und die kosten mich auch. Ich könnte wahrscheinlich viel billiger jetzt irgendwo mich in so ein Cloud-Server irgendwie einmieten, wo du bei Hetzer dann mit 100 Leuten auf einer Kiste steckst.
Ich wollte nochmal auf diesen Sicherheitsaspekt kommen, dass ja immer gesagt wird, ja, aber deine eigene Software ist doch viel sicherer und ich mir dann immer denke, also das sind halt... Hardware und Software, die du dann betreiben kannst. Und ich mir dann denke, ja, es gibt nicht sehr viele Leute da draußen, die wirklich einen sicheren Server laufen lassen können. Und dann, keine Ahnung, ja, aber du bist ja angreifbar, die NSA überwacht dich und ich so, die NSA überwacht auch deinen privaten Server, wenn sie wollen, plus dein Haus, in dem du deinen Server stehen hast, der wird halt auch gerade nicht dann überwacht, wenn du nicht zu Hause bist. Also die Annahme, dass die Cloud nicht sicherer ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das heutzutage noch stimmt oder ob es jemals gestimmt hat, also, Entschuldigung, dass es zu Hause sicherer ist als...
Das macht der NSA auf jeden Fall mehr Arbeit, wenn du deinen Song auf deinem eigenen Rechner hast, und nicht bei Amazon, wo sie direkt die Glasfaser dann aus dem...
So gefüllten Select-All darauf machen.
Also wenn du dein eigenes Data Center hast, dann kannst du schon auch andere Policies enforceen, da hast du natürlich alles...
Du brauchst unglaublich viel Wissen, unglaublich viel Update, die du die ganze Zeit drum kümmern musst.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist halt für den Durchschnittsnutzer, den ich ja hier vertrete.
Sehr gut, aber das macht es halt auch so teuer. Also wenn du den Kram selber betreiben willst, und deswegen gehen ja auch viele davon weg. Also selbst wenn du ein eigenes Data Center betreibst, betreibst du es ja im Prinzip wie eine Cloud. Nur, dass du halt deine eigene Cloud aufbaust, sprich du schiebst ja auch die ganzen Instanzen ständig zwischen den Servern hin und her und bootest die neu und Zeug, weil der technische Ansatz macht total Sinn, egal ob dir jemand anders die Ressourcen gibt oder ob du die eigene Hardware im Keller hast.
Also das hängt natürlich immer ein bisschen mit deinem Drohungsszenario, deinem Potenzial zusammen. Also erstmal wie wahrscheinlich ist das überhaupt, dass dir jemand ans Fell will, bzw. was würde dich das im Zweifelsfall kosten? Also wie sensitiv sind deine Daten? Oder wie sensitiv ist deine Betriebszuverlässigkeit? Oder wie hoch ist der Spionage-Faktor? Und da gibt es natürlich durchaus Branchen. Das kann man jetzt nicht mit allgemeinen Nutzer beschreiben, sondern wir reden ja hier von Unternehmen und Organisationen, die in irgendeiner Form Daten vorhalten, prozessieren oder Dienste anbieten. Und natürlich ist das schon ein Faktor, wenn du selber die Hardware unter Kontrolle hast. Da kannst du zum Beispiel sicherstellen, dass alle deine Prozessoren auf deinen Mainboards auch das neueste Microcode-Update haben, was gegen Meltdown etc. gehärtet ist.
Es ginge, sagen wir es mal so. Ich habe nur die praktische Lebenserfahrung, dass ich bei verschiedenen Agenturen gearbeitet habe und da dann irgendwie jemand auf die Idee kam, zum Beispiel so eine Windows-Cloud lokal zu betreiben. Oder so ein Server da in dem, ja, es ist total super, dass wir hier einen lokalen Server haben und das alles lokal speichern. Und dann werden aber zum Beispiel, wurden dort Macs rausgegeben an die Mitarbeiter und weil die von der IT gemanagt wurden, durften die nicht verschlüsselt sein, weil sonst hatte die IT angeblich keinen Zugriff. Also haben wir keine lokale Festplattenverschlüsselung gehabt auf diesen Rechnern, wo dann die ganzen Unternehmensdaten drauf waren. Und um sozusagen, die Mitarbeiter sind natürlich ständig zugefahren oder sonst wo draußen gewesen und dann war es aber eine unfähige IT. Natürlich ist es eine unfähige IT, darum rede ich ja. Das sind die 80 Prozent, von denen ich spreche, worauf ich hinaus will, ist, also und was haben sie gemacht als Lösung, damit sie sozusagen mit ihrer IT-Richtlinie, wir haben in die Arbeitsverträge reingeschrieben, du darfst auf deinem betragbaren Computer, was unser einziger Computer war, den wir hatten, keine Unternehmensdaten speichern. Und dann habe ich die, als einziger habe ich mir diese Security-Anweisungen dadurch gelesen, die die uns gegeben haben. Hab dann angerufen und gesagt, wie stellt ihr euch denn vor? Naja, wir können ja jeden Abend die Daten, die sie am Tag bearbeitet haben, wieder zurück auf den lokalen Server spielen. Und ich so, ey, warum gebt ihr mir einen mobilen Rechner, um mir dann zu verbieten, diesen zu transportieren, damit ich ihn dann benutzen kann? Das war sozusagen, oder es werden halt diese gesamten irrationalen Entscheidungen gemacht, wie zum Beispiel irgendwie, ihr dürft keinen Chrome verwenden, weil der kommt von Google und Google ist böse. Und was war die Antwort der Mitarbeiter, die natürlich Chrome brauchten, ist, sie nehmen von zu Hause einen Speicherstick und machen einen mobilen Chrome drauf, sozusagen umgehen die gesamte Security, die sich die IT... Also sozusagen dieses, Linux sagt dann ja immer irgendwie, man muss halt das als Gesamtheit denken und deswegen denke ich, dass ganz oft für ganz viele Unternehmen in dem Praktischen eine gut verschlüsselte Cloud mit zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung als Absicherung besser ist als eine lokalbetriebene Sicherheit oder die eigenen Server, die eben dann nicht richtig gemanagt werden. Und das ist halt immer so dieses, ja, sehr abstrakte Sicherheit und nicht so dieses Konkrete in dem Alltag der Menschen. Das ist total recht.
Aber ich finde halt auch so, man hat manchmal bei einigen Unternehmungen so den Eindruck, sie wollen alles geschenkt haben und sie wissen auch alles immer, so was IT, Security und Infrastruktur betreiben angeht. Und das, naja, muss man sagen, vielleicht einfach mal ganz gutes Geld in die Hand zu nehmen, einen Menschen einzustellen, der davon Ahnung hat, oder sich beraten zu lassen und nicht einfach jede Grütze sich dahin zu stellen. Das ist halt echt ein Problem.
Das Problem ist sogar noch größer, dass die meisten noch nicht mal wissen, dass sie ein Problem haben. Auch ein schönes Beispiel der gleichen Agentur, wo ich war, bzw. war ein größeres deutsches Unternehmen, da war das halt so, dass die IT, am Einrichtungstag, der erste Tag, kriege ich also meinen Arbeitsrechner, und dann rufe ich die IT an, ja, irgendwie Einrichtung, mein Outlook wird dann konfiguriert auf dem Mac, aber ich, naja.
Ich leide mit dir.
Danke. Und dann sag ich so ruhig an, wir schalten uns jetzt auf deinen Mac. Und ich so okay, und dann, so, wir sind jetzt auf deinem Mac, und ich so, wo ist denn das Fenster mit, bitte geben sie dem Admin Zugang. Und die so, nee, nee, das haben wir nicht. Wir kamen einfach hier, und ich so, ihr habt jederzeit Zugang zu meinem Mac, ihr kommt euch jederzeit, ohne dass ich gefragt werde, und ich so, weiß der Vorstand das? Dass die ihr jederzeit, also der Vorstand, die Boards und so weiter, die auch Macs haben, dass ihr jederzeit Zugang habt. Ich sag, ihr seid ja ein unkündbares Volk in der IT-Abteilung, weil ihr sozusagen die geheime Macht habt und euch auf jeden Mitarbeiter in dieser Firma schalten könnt. Zu jedem Zeitpunkt abends, 23.30 Uhr. Das fand ich, also...
Aber das war vor 20 Jahren auch schon so. Beim Chef war alles total geheim, aber der Admin hatte alle Passwörter.
Ja, ich glaub ja, dass die Admin sowieso die geheime Macht haben in Matrix. So, nächstes Thema.
Hier ist ein Blatt noch interessant. Im Chat kam gerade hier noch der Hinweis, dass jemand hier bei einer großen Bank arbeitet. Da geht Cloud gar nicht. Wir haben zwei Datencenter und viele Server. Es geht nicht anders, dass es auch von der BaFin so vorgesehen ist.
Bei der sogenannten modernen Fintech, die ganzen neuen Unternehmen, die da so Payments und Bitcoin und die ganzen Scheiß machen, die sind auch alle bei Amazon Cloud. Nicht nur in Europa, sondern auch in den USA und so.
Aber genau an Bitcoin siehst du auch, was passiert, wenn man es nicht gut macht. Also da sind ja so viele gescheitert schon dran.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es an den Cloud lag.
An seinem eigenen sonstigen Importanz.
Ja, genau. Weil es natürlich schickes Ziel sind, weil frische Firmen gerade angefangen, aber da liegt viel Geld rum. Natürlich sind da die Hacker am Start. Die sind bei den Banken sicher auch am Start, aber die Banken kaufen sich das ja, die zahlen ja und dann ist ja wieder Ruhe und die publishen das ja nicht.
Ein zweiter Link, der hier noch kam, hab ich auch mal gelesen, dass Dropbox vor ein paar Jahren angefangen hat, von AWS weg zu marschieren, seine eigene Cloud aufzubauen. Ich glaube, das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass diese Dienste, Amazon, AWS, ist natürlich super, wenn du mal eben was starten willst oder irgendein Produkt hast, was, was weiß ich, irgendwas macht, aber das keine Megadimension hat. Ab dem Moment, wo mehr oder weniger klar ist, was du machen willst bzw. auch die Art und Weise, wie du es machst, entscheidend ist für die Weiterentwicklung des Produkts und deine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, dann, wie zum Beispiel jetzt bei Dropbox, macht es halt Sinn, weil sie können natürlich auch ihre Datencenter genau daraufhin auslegen für den Bedarf, den sie haben, was auch immer dieser Bedarf im Einzelnen sein muss.
Das ist auch eine Kostenfrage, oder?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Kostenfrage. Erstmal musst du natürlich das ausbauen, du brauchst die Kompetenz etc., die Standorte, Security und so weiter. Klar, aber dann zahlst du natürlich jetzt auch nicht so viel Geld für den ganzen Plan.
Wenn du genau weißt, was du brauchst und hast das Know-how, dann kannst du es wahrscheinlich günstiger machen, als wenn Amazon an dir verdient. Das ist logisch.
Auch schon so eine einzelne Kiste schnell mal aufgesetzt, das machst du nicht, da musst du dir deinen Rechner kaufen, hier und da, also alles, was du unter ein Dutzend mal benutzt, da lohnt das wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Netflix ist ja auch weggegangen von, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob sie bei Amazon war, aber die hatten irgendeinen Standard CDN benutzt, wo sie ihre ganzen Movies von verteilen und die haben sich das auch durchgerechnet und haben sich dann auch, die nutzen ja FreeBSD, haben sich dann auch so einen Reck gebaut, ich weiß nicht, wie die das genau nennen, so einen Content-Cache-Cluster oder keine Ahnung, die haben auch so einen Namen dafür, ihr Kasten und machen das auch selber mit eigener Software. Ich glaube, die nutzen sogar Engine X, so eine Spezialversion.
Dazu kommt natürlich auch, dass gerade so Firmen, die halt sehr viel auf große Performance machen, dass du dann natürlich auch den gesamten Stack optimieren willst. Und wenn da irgendeine Maschine in irgendeinem Data Center, in irgendeiner Cloud läuft, dann kannst du halt zum Thema Performance auch nichts sagen und dann willst du die eigene Hardware haben.
Ich hab auch schon von größeren deutschen Unternehmen gehört, die so klug waren, vor kurzem mal so ihre Datencenter komplett Amazon zu verkaufen, so nach dem Motto betreibt das mal für uns, wir haben davon keine Ahnung. So jetzt mal irgendwie als Dienstleistung und jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen in den Schlund der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung blicken und überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig unter Kontrolle haben, ob sie überhaupt ihre ganzen Policies bezüglich Speicherung, Zugang usw. überhaupt noch richtig aufrechterhalten können.
Das wird noch ganz spannend.
Ich bin sowieso, ich freu mich auf die ganzen Abmahnungen, die da verschickt werden. Aber irgendwo stand hier auch, nicht stand heute gar nicht auf der Tabliste, diese ganze Datenschutzverordnung, aber ist auch ein mega juristisches Thema. Aber ich glaube, das wird sozusagen ein umgekehrtes Abmahnenspaß. Also jetzt können die Bürger mal die ganzen Firmen abmahnen, und zwar so richtig auch massenweise. Und das wird lustig.
Sollen wir mal das Cloud-Thema mal zu machen? Womit machen wir weiter?
Du bist der Moderator, oder?
Letty, du wolltest noch um was erklären.
Nee, ich wollte. Also Letty wollte dann weitermachen, ich wollte eröffnen. Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob es erklären passt, nicht ganz, aber ich erzähl trotzdem. Und zwar habe ich meiner Mom, die hat ja meinen alten Mac bekommen, und die kommt da natürlich immer an und hat so Fragen, wie sie ihre Bilder sortiert, usw. Alles ganz simple Sachen, aber ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich verstehe nichts, was sie mir da erzählt. Also weil sie das nur so erklärt, ohne dass sie am Rechner sitzt, weil sie hat den nicht dabei, ihr Laptop. Und ich kapier mal nichts. Und dann fiel mir irgendwann mal ein, dass ich mal das irgendwo gesehen hab, dass wenn du, du kannst ja hier so einen Schach-Großmeister, das jen hat sich vorhin erzählt, hier Karpov oder Kasparov oder jetzt von mir aus Magnus Carlson, den stellst du 20 Stellungen hin, berühmte Stellung oder auch nicht so berühmte Stellung, aber 20 Spiele, die im laufenden Spiel angehalten wurden. Und die laufen da fünf Minuten lang vorbei, merken sich das, dann deckst du das zu und dann bauen die das nach. Und das können die so aus dem Stehgreif irgendwie, ne? So, jetzt ist aber der Trick. Wenn du dir 20 Schachspiele hinstellst oder Schachbretter mit Positionen, die es nicht so gibt, die man gar nicht so spielen kann oder die keinen Sinn machen, dann scheitern die wahrscheinlich schon an dem ersten Brett, weil sie das sich einfach nicht merken können. Das heißt, die brauchen auch schon so eine gewisse Logik da auf dem Schachbrett, damit sie sich das einbringen. Dann wissen die alles klar, diese Öffnung war am ersten, diese Öffnung war am zweiten und dann auch so... Muster, die sie schon mal gelernt haben. Und die kennen ja alle Muster, aber Muster, die sie nicht gelernt haben, nämlich irgendwelche Positionen, die gar nicht gehen, oder die nie so einer spielen würde, die können sie sich halt auch schwer merken. Und so geht's mir mit meiner Mutter auch. Die erklärt halt Sachen, wie ich die überhaupt gar nicht machen würde.
Oder geht das auch schon nicht?
Sie sagt dann, ja, dann drück ich da so rechts. Ich mein, ja, wie rechts? Rechts im Fenster, rechts auf dem Desktop, rechts, rechts, rechts, wo? Rechts. Da, da auf das Bild. Ja, das Eigen oder das Bild. Also, äh... Na, das kleine Ding da. Also, das weißt du, das ist einfach nicht so, wie wir das sagen würden und wie wir uns ausdrücken würden und auch der Job, wie sie den macht teilweise, das würden wir auch schon nicht so machen.
Ohne Terminologie sozusagen.
Genau, und das fielen wir vor allem ein bei erklären, aber eigentlich hat das jetzt, wie ihr gemerkt, schon gar nicht so viel mit erklären zu tun, aber sie dürfen jetzt übernehmen.
Ich find das ganz lustig, weil meine Mama ist auch so ein Kandidat.
Ja, alle Mama ist wahrscheinlich.
Ist halt... Nee, meine nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Die erklärt jeder, wie der Rechner funktioniert.
Nee, aber die ist ganz gut alleine unterwegs.
Meine Mama ist auch alleine unterwegs. Die kommt ja klar, die macht da Sachen, die ich ihr nicht beigebracht hab. Die findet sie von alleine raus. Aber wenn sie mir davon erzählen will, weil sie jetzt wieder mal irgendwo hängen bleibt, dann versteh ich sie halt nicht. Darum geht's mir. Also die fummelt sich schon alleine durch.
Das geht schon.
Sie verwendet nicht die selbe Terminologie, wie die denn ist.
Ja, naja, bei meinen Podcasts ist es so.
Nicht nur die Terminologie, es geht um das gesamte Verständnis.
Genau.
Das ist von sozusagen, was passiert da eigentlich. Zum Beispiel, ich merke das oft, ich mach ja auch Workshops, wo ich den Leuten Facebook erklären muss. Also jetzt nicht so auf eurem Niveau, sondern du klickst auf Erstellen neuen Beitrag. Und hier liest du Foto. Da fehlt halt so die Grundverständnisse von was ist ein Desktop, was eine Ordnerstruktur, was ist eine Datei. Diese Grundbegriffe fehlen. Die merken, die schreiben sich dann eben nicht auf, ziehe Datei aus Desktop hoch, sondern die schreiben sich auf, sozusagen aus dem oberen rechten Bereich des Bildes, wo in dem Fall die Tween Shots dann automatisch landen bei denen, ziehe ich fest steht, also die haben wie immer wieder unsere Vorstellungen.
Wieder das, was sie auf dem Bildschirm sehen, und nicht das, was wir dahinter beschreiben, was passiert, sodass Ordner aus Datei ist, was da unten irgendwo passiert. Und die beschreiben ja, aus dem Fenster, außerhalb des Fensters gezogen, so ungefähr.
Ja, Terminologie. Sie haben halt dieses Grundprinzip User Interface überhaupt nicht begriffen. Oder nicht vermittelt bekommen.
Ich wollte meiner Mutter ja Alias erklären, weil sie, wenn sie Fotovorführung macht, dann macht sie von allen Fotos, die sie zeigen will, macht sie eine Kopie in den Ordner rein, damit sie diesen Ordner dann zeigen kann. Ist ja damit APFS jetzt eigentlich auch nicht mehr so schlimm. Deswegen dachte ich mir, hätte ich eigentlich das Konzept von Aliasen ja gar nicht erklären müssen. Weil eigentlich hat sich's ja eh erledigt mit APFS, weil da ist es ja egal. Aber ich hab's auch nicht geschafft. Sie hat's nicht so schnell, sie hat's irgendwie nicht verstanden mit den Aliasen, weil das ist ja wieder so man im Echten halt auch nicht abbilden kann. Weil im Echten kannst du halt nicht mal so eine Kopie von irgendwas machen. Im echten Leben, weil man tickt ja mal symbolisch, man vergleicht ja mit dem, zieht eine Analogie mit irgendwas im echten Leben, wenn's denn geht, weil das ist sehr praktisch, weil das jeder kennt. Alias kann man da beim echten Leben keinen Vergleich ziehen und deswegen, ja, kam das nicht so rüber.
Alias kann man im echten Leben keinen Vergleich ziehen?
Na, wenn du eine gute Idee hast, also das, ich suche ja immer, wenn man was, also wenn du da was hast.
Es ist ja ein sehr elektronisches Konzept.
Es ist ja sehr virtuell so ein Alias, also es sind ja künstliche Kopien, sind ja eh schon. Dass wir da APFELD drücken und eine Kopie haben, geht ja im echten Leben auch schon nicht so easy.
Ein Hausbild.
Fernseher.
Replikator.
Du hast aber zwei Dateien am Ende, zwei Elemente beim Replikator. Da entstehen ja nicht zwei Dateien, sondern es ist eine Datei, die nur an verschiedenen Orten liegt oder eine Repräsentation aneinander.
Ja, ich meine, der Jan Böhmermann sitzt ja auch nicht in jedem Wohnzimmer, sondern er wird ja sozusagen nur auf dem Fernseher als Schatten repliziert.
Sitzplatzreservierung wird gerade vorgeschlagen, finde ich interessant im Chat.
Na jedenfalls war er das mit dem Alias.
Das war er nicht.
Deswegen wird sie das wahrscheinlich demnächst weiter machen, wie sie es macht und deswegen gibt es APFS und das Problem ist gefixt und dann wissen wir jetzt auch, warum das gut ist, weil ich habe mir schon mal gefragt, wozu brauche ich dann dieses APFS-Feature, weil wann mache ich denn mal eine Kopie von einer Datei? Ich mach das nicht, weil es mir halt auch keinen Sinn macht, weil dafür gibt es ja Alias. Meine Mom macht das aber schon, das ist sozusagen APFS, ist für meine Mom gemacht.
Amen.
Letzter, du wolltest was zum Erklären.
Das war wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum Apple das entwickelt hat, weil es so viele Mütter gibt, die bei einem anrufen. Ich finde, was ihr halt auch schon sagte, manchmal fehlt halt so diese gemeinsame Grundlage, über ein Thema zu reden und dann Metaphern zu finden. Also ich finde, Metaphern, was hast du ja auch gerade gesagt, aus dem Leben sozusagen versuchen zu finden, um etwas Technisches zu erklären. Und ich habe jetzt auch gerade wieder eine Vorlesung. Das ist keine Vorlesung, Vorlesung in dem Sinne, sondern eher so ein Zusammenkommen. Wenn man Programmieren lernen will, mache ich zusammen mit einer anderen Kollegin. Und ich habe heute versucht, Grundkonzepte des Programmierens, einfach mal so ganz banal, Variablen, Datenstrukturen, Schleifen, if else so Conditions und Functions.
Da gibt es Spiele, für die einem das beibringen.
Genau, aber ich wollte...
Human Resource Machine, sag ich noch.
Oh Gott, ja, da habe ich auch kurz dran gedacht. Aber manchmal weiß man halt auch nicht, was den Leuten wirklich weiterhilft und was sie überfordert.
Ja, das ist halt auch bei jedem ein bisschen anders. Weil es kommt ja mal drauf an, wie weit die Leute schon sind, was sie so kennen, wo man dann drauf aufbauen kann, ich glaube.
Genau, und ich habe schon mal gehört, dass es Programmiersprachen gibt, aber noch keine im echten an mir vorbei laufen sehen, so nach dem Motto. Und ich habe schon mal irgendetwas zumindest benutzt gehabt. Also wirklich so die Range von, ich will vielleicht nicht mal direkt programmieren lernen, sondern eher Grundkonzepte verstehen, damit ich dann, wenn ich mit einem Entwickler arbeite, mit ihm reden kann. Also ich arbeite ja hauptsächlich in der Uni mit den Designern zusammen und einige wollen programmieren wirklich lernen und andere wollen vielleicht einfach nur eine Grundlage haben, um eine gemeinsame Kommunikation überhaupt aufbauen zu können. Was ja ziemlich wichtig ist, wenn man an einem Projekt zusammenarbeitet. Und ich habe halt versucht so Grundkonzepte beim beim Coden zu erklären. Also wirklich das, was einem selber halt so komplett banal mittlerweile vorkommt. Ja, FS, total logisch. Entweder das stimmt oder das stimmt nicht. Und dann sitzen halt irgendwie Leute und gucken dann so, ja wie, was heißt das jetzt und was mache ich da und das ist echt wieder...
Ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich nicht möglich ist, Dinge zu erklären. Also ich glaube, dass sozusagen ist...
Du zerstörst meine Welt.
Na, ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich ist, aus meinem Kopf etwas zu nehmen, einen Wissensstand und den in deinen Kopf hinein zu pflanzen mit Hilfe der Sprache. Dafür ist die Sprache viel zu unterkomplex.
Aber mit Metaphern kann man es versuchen.
Auch nicht. Was einzig hilft ist, du musstest in deinem Kopf neu erfahren. Das, was ich dir vielleicht zeige, musst du dann nochmal nachspielen oder nachmachen. Beim Fußball, so lernen wir Fußball ist, indem wir es spielen.
Learning by doing, aber man braucht ja schon ein bisschen Regeln erklärt, dann brauchen wir Tipps, was geht dann überhaupt und was geht nicht.
Begleitende Spielen würde ich das eher nennen.
Aber es ist doch auch erklären, also man hilft dem anderen dabei, das zu lernen.
Der Unterschied, den ich machen will, ist, die gesamte Schule, wie wir sie kennen, sozusagen Akademie und aber auch Grundschule, Hauptschule, Gymnasium und so weiter, da ist das Konzept, jemand steht vorne und berichtet und danach ist das beim Schüler angekommen. Das ist sozusagen die Annahme der Schule und ich glaube, dass da ein Missverständnis vorliegt, dass das nicht praktisch eigentlich gar nicht so funktioniert, sondern der Schüler lernt das erst, wenn er zu Hause vor der Hausaufgabe sitzt und dann sagt Shit, das geht ja gar nicht. So und dann fängt er an...
Hallo, ich habe nie Hausaufgaben gemacht.
Es gibt Ausnahmen. Aber erst, wenn du es selber machst und das ist vielleicht auch für die Universitäten, deswegen glaube ich nicht mehr an das Konzept von Universitäten, eines der Hauptprobleme, dass sie sozusagen gerade in der Vermittlung von IT, sozusagen Lernerfahrungen, die du selber machen musst, versuchen über eine Vorlesung zu vermitteln. Und besser wäre sozusagen, du in deiner Vorlesung jetzt, Laddie, müsste es sozusagen die Leute sagen, programmiert das jetzt mal und ich gebe euch hier ein Set an Werkzeugen zur Hand und versucht es mal und dann können die Leute sich melden und eine Frage stellen. Also darum sind sie dann eher gezwungen, diesen Lernerfahrungen, die du schon gemacht hast, für sich selber nachzuvollziehen. Also sozusagen als Grundannahme. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das, es ist halt länger und es ist komplizierter. Ich habe nur in meinen Workshops, wenn ich irgendetwas erzählen will über Social Media, obwohl das noch tausendmal banaler ist als das, was du unterrichtest, gemerkt, dass ich den Leuten das super erklären kann. Aber es wird einfach nicht verstanden, bis du es machst. Das ist der Moment in dem Workshop, wo ich sage, jetzt klappen wir eure Laptops auf. Ich habe dann so eine Online-Software, mit der ich wohl mit die Bilder gestalten. Und wenn sie plötzlich, wie schreibst du das? Welches Bildmotiv willst du aus? Das ist der Moment, wo sie anfragen, nach welchen Konzepten gehe ich eigentlich vor? Und wo sie sich dann Gedanken machen. Und dann können sie auch das, was ich Ihnen vorher erzählt habe, teilweise verwenden. Das ist ja nicht ganz so, dass es alles unnütz ist. Aber da erst beginnt der Lernprozess. Und das kommt oft zu kurz. Leider in Universitäten und überall auch sonst in unserem Bildungswesen.
Ja gut, aber das würde ja bedeuten, dass man nur Dinge verstehen kann, die man auch selber zur Anwendung bringen kann. Ich meine, so kann ich dir zum Beispiel Gravitationswellen, könnte ich dir auf diese Art und Weise halt nicht näherbringen. Trotzdem würde ich mir einbilden, wenn ich genug Zeit von dir zugestanden bekomme, dass ich dir an einem Abend zumindest meinen Kenntnisstand darüber umfangreich ins Hirn pressen könnte, sodass auch was hängen bleibt.
Meine These wäre, dass sozusagen in dem Moment, in dem ich versuche dann jemand Drittem zu erklären, was du mir beigebracht hast, dann erst verfestigt sich das Wissen bei mir.
Das ist ohnehin so.
Aber das ist der Lernprozess, von dem ich dann wirklich spreche. Solange ich passiv sitze und nur mir gesagt wird, versackt 80 bis 90 Prozent des Wissens. Und das ist sozusagen auf die Mauer, auf die du stößt, glaube ich, Lettli.
Ja, aber das würde es ja unter Umständen auch helfen, dass man die Leute sozusagen so versucht, so was zu bringen, dass sie in der Lage sind, also dass sozusagen der praktische Teil daran besteht, dass andere Leute dabei sind zu bringen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir brauchen ein anderes Lernkonzept.
Also genau, heute war das halt für mich so von vornherein gar nicht so auf eine spezielle Sprache fokussiert, weil ich einfach mal noch mal so eine Art Input von den Konzepten hergeben wollte, weil mir eben in der ersten Vorlesung, die ich gegeben habe, da kam irgendwie sowas die Frage, wie kann ich mir denn eine Iteration vorstellen? Also, dass sie mit diesen Begriffen noch nicht wussten, umzugehen. Und ich habe halt heute wirklich so versucht, so eine Grundlage zu schaffen, dass sie wissen, auch welche Begriffe sie zum Beispiel googeln müssen. Weil das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was du bei Neulingen so beim Coden häufig merkst. Sie wissen so irgendwie, wo sie hin wollen, aber die Begrifflichkeit fehlt gerade noch. Dass ich ihnen einfach so eine Art Leitfaden so ein bisschen mitgeben konnte. Und aber halt gleichzeitig dann auch nicht nur, wie ich sag mal, Pseudocode gezeigt habe, sondern nebenbei irgendwie so eine JavaScript-Reppel aufgehabt habe, um das irgendwie kurz zu zeigen, wie verhalten sich denn irgendwie, Iterationen, was heißt nach inkrementelles und dekrementelles iterieren und einfach so Conditions so ein bisschen gezeigt. Und da haben sie dann halt auch wirklich so, klar, da haben sie jetzt nicht mitgemacht, das ist vielleicht auch ein Fehler gewesen. Aber da haben sie schon mal so ein bisschen was gesehen und halt auch in der Tat Fragen gestellt. Also nicht nur so, gut, du kannst bei einer Gruppe von 20 Leuten auch wissen, dass nur fünf Fragen stellen. Und aber das ist ein guter Hinweis. Das werde ich wahrscheinlich einfach bei den nächsten zwei Themen komplexen machen, dass ich dir ein bisschen was vorgebe und die einfach rumspielen sollen.
Rumspielen, dialogisch und Dennis, das ist letztlich auch der Grund, warum du sozusagen diesen Diskursproblem in deiner Mutter hast, dass eben sie nicht sozusagen den Prozess nachfühlen kann.
Ich kann ja ihren Prozess nicht nachfühlen, das geht so rum.
Okay, ja, weil du in ihrer Welt sprichst und sie nicht in deiner.
Genau.
In dem Moment, in dem ihr gemeinsam vom PC sitzt, habt ihr das Problem nicht. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Weil ihr dann diese gemeinsame Erfahrungswelt habt.
Das ist schon klar. Es ging ja nur darum, wenn sie was erklären muss, ohne dass sie da im Rechner sitzen. Wenn sie mir das zeigt, dann verstehe ich das ja auch.
Die Sache ist so überschätzt, also von dem, was sie transportieren kann. Nee, wirklich. Aber es ist ja so, ich hab vor kurzem oder gestern, um genau zu sein, hab ich von...
Das sagst du in einem Podcast, Mann.
Okay, worauf ich hinaus will. Ich hab gestern ein tolles Video gesehen von einer alten Schuhfreunde von mir, die jetzt, Achtung, nicht gleich weggelaufen, für die CDU in einem lokalen Wahlkampf kandidiert. Und die haben ein ganz schreckliches Video gemacht. Dann haben sie ein Video gemacht, dann ist es mal so. Und in diesem Video haben sie, so wie typische, schlechte Wahlkampfvideos in Kommunalpolitik eben sind, haben sie so fünf Wörter eingeblendet. Digitalisierung annehmen, Wirtschafts-, die Region entwickeln. So Schlagwörter halt. Ja, genau. Und was aber sozusagen wirkt, ist dieses gesamte restliche Video schadet eine wahnsinnige, also jedes Video hat, also da sind Menschen, die sich ja zeigen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Und die Inszenierung spricht tausend Bände. Ja, also der eine Typ, und das waren so vier Leute in dem Video, der stand da wie so ein Aristokrat im 15. Jahrhundert mit so einer Körperhaltung, die sozusagen, wo er die Arme auf den Beinen abstützt. Und im Hintergrund lief so klassische Musik, aber mit so einem Titanic-Soundtrack, so für einen Kommunalwahlkampf, irgendwo im Lande. Und es ist so vollkommen abgehoben. Also so wirklich, nicht so, hey Leute, stellt euch da einfach, ihr seid doch, das sollen übrigens die jungen Leute in der CDU sein, also die, die unter 40 sind, also es waren jetzt die vier jungen. Und ich so, ey, ihr denkt doch mal darauf, wie das wirkt auf andere. Ja, wir sind doch jetzt in der YouTube- und Instagramzeit. Ihr könnt euch einfach nur hinstellen und sagen, hey, wir sind die und die, wir machen das und das, und dafür stehen wir ein. Total, like, mit einer ganz normalen Klamotten, oder setzt euch auf den Sofa, was auch immer. Aber, und wir hatten dann so Dronenflug, ja, so ein Dronenflug, ich mein, ist fancy, aber, und das kam dann so von oben so runter.
Ich würde mal sagen, das war wie bei dir vorhin, nämlich, die hatten Budget.
Jaja, die hatten ein Budget, aber was ich sagen will, ist, dieses Video hat sehr viel darüber ausgesagt, wer die sind, aber alles nicht durch Sprache, sondern sozusagen durch Bilder. Und wir unterschätzen immer sozusagen, was unsere Körper verraten, was unsere Gesichter verraten, und das ist auch so ein bisschen meine These, warum im Internet so viel Hass und gegenseitiger Argwohnen herrschen, warum wir auf Twitter uns ständig streiten. Weil sozusagen diese ganze Körpersprache, unsere Gestik weg ist. Ich benutze auch gerade meine Hände während ich spreche, obwohl das völlig absurd ist. Weil sozusagen wir die Menschen nicht sehen und wir seine Intention deshalb nicht erahnen können. Wir sehen nur den Text, den er schreibt. Und der Text ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz stark verkürzte Sache. Sprache ist ganz kraftverkürzt. Und wir Menschen nehmen ganz viele War aus Körperhaltung, aus Kleidung, aus allem Drumherum. Und das ist eigentlich schade, dass das Medium Internet sozusagen so begrenzt ist in seiner Repräsentation. Deswegen sind ja auch Emoticons und Smilies und diese ganzen Gips so wichtig, weil es plötzlich so einen Kontext gibt wieder.
Deswegen sind Podcasts so wichtig.
Und Podcasts sind toll, weil da hat man die Stimmlage. Nicht der Text ist hier entscheidend, sondern die Stimmlage ist das, was sozusagen als Tim vorhin seinen Rant abgegeben hat, war nicht der Text, den er gesagt hat, relevant, sondern die Stimmlage war die...
Nee, die Stimmlautstärke.
Die Lautstärke war das, was sozusagen am meisten die eigentliche Botschaft, die er hat transportiert hat. Und die Schnappatmung. Das ist halt so ein bisschen...
Das ist auch der Grund, wenn ich jetzt immer erkläre, warum ich immer noch, ich gucke auf Netflix, so eine spanische Serie, warum ich die tatsächlich... Genau, warum ich die tatsächlich in Spanisch gucke mit deutschen Untertiteln.
Ja, das ist doch total super.
Weil ich halt, was die Synchronsprecher, die sind schon gut, aber die sind halt lange nicht so gut wie der spanische Schauspieler. Da ist halt eben auch die Sprache, das Atmen, wie schnell, langsam, laut die sprechen, das kommt halt in der Übersetzung, also in der Synchronisation, kommt das einfach nicht rüber. Deswegen gucke ich das lieber in Spanisch und Englisch mit deutschen Untertiteln. Da ist viel mehr Emotion in der Sprache. Ich lerne noch den spanischen Flow, lerne ich auch gleich noch, also wie man halt sowas, also nicht, dass ich jetzt Spanisch lernen würde.
Wie man halt, dass man so spricht.
Aber ich glaube, man könnte jetzt besser Spanisch aus einem Buch lernen und wüsste schon, hatte schon so eine Ahnung, wie man es dann aussprechen würde. Und sagen nicht absolut, wie der Schwede, die sagen immer claro.
Vor allem bei Narcos ist mir das aufgefallen. Zurück zum Thema Etlern.
Kann ich nur empfehlen, die Serie, das finde ich gut.
Genau, weil zwei Leute auch gerade noch sagten, also einer Person meinte im Chat, gerade Kochrezepte sind super. Oh, das habe ich auch gedacht. Und habe dann mir gedacht, so ja, schreiben wir doch so als Abschluss ein Algorithmus, wie man Pancakes kocht. Ist ein bisschen länger geworden. Und ich habe ihn heute jetzt noch nicht gemacht, weil ich dachte so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, nicht, dass ich die Leute verschrecke mit so einem simplen Kochrezept in Form eines Algorithmus und dachte dann so, oh je, das machen wir bis zur nächsten Woche.
Rezepte sind ein schöner Einstieg in dem Zusammenhang.
Du kennst die Programmiersprache Chef, ne? Da formuliert man alle Programme wie ein Kochrezept.
Davon habe ich gehört.
Aha, das habe ich noch nicht gehört. Chef heißt die.
Was heißt das? Also wie formuliert man das dann? Muss man irgendwie eine... Eine Prise Bits.
Du deklarierst deine Variablen wie Zutaten. Zwei Eier, 500 Gramm Butter.
Ist das geil.
Und dann kannst du halt angeben, was tust du wo rein.
Lass eine Spalte 5 schmelzen.
Geil, ich schreib den nochmal um. Genau nach so was habe ich gesucht.
Das ist auch mehr so eine esoterische Programmiersprache. Wirklich, da hab ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen. Nicht so ernst gemeint.
Ja, ich find das jetzt nicht so schlimm, weil ich hab einfach nur, ich wollte den halt auch so ein bisschen zeigen, wie man...
Wie man eine Sprache, die nicht ernst gemeint ist und nicht funktioniert, als eine Sprache, die ernst gemeint ist und nicht funktioniert.
Also ich wollte den Leuten einfach nur ein bisschen zeigen, wie man so an Probleme herangeht oder wie man Probleme auf Teile runterbrechen kann. Und hab denen halt auch ein großartiges Video von Extra Credits gezeigt, wenn ich das noch auf die Schnelle finde, wo sie, also Extra Credits sind ja eigentlich mehr Richtung Game Design, Game Designer, die verschiedene Themen aufarbeiten und unter anderem haben sie zwei Folgen zu, wie man, also was man als Entwickler so macht und wie man als Entwickler denkt, die ich ganz cool fand. Die habe ich den, meinen Mädels heute quasi gezeigt.
Also ich, für mich ist ja erklären ein Hobby. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich kann den Zustand was nicht zu erklären. Also wenn ich versuche, etwas zu erklären und es gelingt mir nicht, das geht nie. Das trifft mich tief so. Und von daher bin ich da etwas optimistischer als du vielleicht so, dass man schon mit Sprache etwas erreichen kann. Die Frage ist halt nur, redet man überhaupt über das Richtige? Weil das Hauptproblem beim Erklären meiner Auffassung nach ist, dass die Leute halt viel zu sehr von der eigenen Gedankenwelt und der eigenen Gedankenstruktur ausgehen und sich dabei eben nicht an die vorherrschende Gedankenstruktur des Gegenübers anpassen. Ich sage nicht, dass das leicht ist oder dass das auf jeden Fall immer gelingen kann, aber das ist zumindest die Methode, mit der ich relativ viel Erfolg oder glaube zumindest viel Erfolg zu haben, indem ich halt immer zunächst einmal versuche zu verstehen, warum jemand eigentlich etwas nicht versteht.
Das ist ja das Wichtigste beim Erklären, oder? Man muss ja finden, auf welchem Level er sich schon befindet, dass man da dran anbauen kann.
Ich glaube, Tim, was du gut machst in dein Podcast, und so theoretisch könnte man auch sagen, warum du so erfolgreich bist, ist, dass du es schaffst, Bilder zu finden, die sozusagen etwas, also du hast Gäste, wie du gerade gesagt hast, die in ihrer Welt sind, und du versuchst sie zu zwingen, in Bildern zu sprechen, die sozusagen andere wiederum verstehen können, also so eine Art Transfer zu machen. Das, was ich eigentlich vorhin sagen wollte, ist nicht, dass ich nicht an Sprache oder Wörter glaube, sondern dass ich nicht daran glaube, dass sozusagen einfach nur die Vorlesen eines Wikipedia-Textes dazu führt, dass sozusagen eine beliebige Person sich das Wissen aneignen kann, sondern man muss sich von den abstrakten Begriffen ein bisschen entfernen und sozusagen das Runterbrechen auf den jeweiligen Wissens- und Realitätsstand, auf die Bildsprache, die diese Person besitzt schon. Wie gesagt, Dennis Mutter finde ich sozusagen ein wirklich super Beispiel dafür, weil sie eben ganz viele von diesen Begriffen und Vorstellungsformen von was ein PC ist, nicht kennt. Die andere Stärke, die du hast, ist du hast immer spannende Gäste, die sozusagen aus einem Wissenschaftsbereich kommen und die dann auch mit ihrer Leidenschaft oft in diesem Podcast erzählen. Keine Ahnung, ob das dieser Podcast war zum Thema Kaffeebohnen, wo diese eine Frau über diese Katzen, die den Kaffeebohnen auskacken oder so. Das hat sie mit so einer Freude in seiner Stimme erzählt, dass es auch eine Freude ist, dazu zu hören und ihre persönliche Lebensphilosophie bringt sie damit rein. Und das macht dann sozusagen diese sonst eventuell trockene Fakt, dass eine Katze die Kaffeebohne verdaut, bevor man sie konsumiert, sozusagen plötzlich witzig, spannend und erlebbar. Und dann kann man das auch aufnehmen.
Wobei das jetzt eine andere Richtung ist, weil man ja an der Stelle, verstehe ich mich ja mehr als Katalysator oder als Transformator. Das erklärt vielleicht auch, warum ich an dieser Sprache XSLT so viel Spaß habe, weil XSLT ist ja sozusagen von der einen Verständniswelt in die andere Verständniswelt transformieren. Das ist ja eine andere Art des Denkens über Programmieren, eine deklarative Programmiermethode, die eben sozusagen das Verständnis der beiden Ein- und Ausgangsstrukturen voraussetzt und darüber dann eben über Muster eine Verbindung zu schaffen. Und das spiegelt vielleicht eher noch das wieder, was man in so einer Interviewsituation hat, weil man ja da quasi für Leute denken muss, die man ja gar nicht sieht. Also das ist nochmal eine besondere Härte. Aber so im unmittelbaren Dialog, denke ich, muss man halt einfach Zeit investieren und was ich einfach oft festgestellt habe bei Leuten, die anderen versuchen vergeblich etwas zu erklären. Der Kernfehler, den sie machen, ist, sie hören einfach nicht zu. Ich glaube, damit kann man schon mal 80% aller Probleme schon mal lösen, wenn ihr irgendwie das Gefühl habt, euch verstehen die Leute nicht. Vielleicht hört ihr ihnen nicht genug zu und das könnte...
Nachfragen, wenn man mal was nicht versteht. Also das geht auch gar nicht, wenn man dann so, ja ja, nichts.
Das merkst du aber auch ganz schnell. Wenn du ein guter Erklärer bist, dann merkst du auch, ob der das jetzt überhaupt wissen will oder nicht. Weil wenn da kein Feedback kommt, dann geht das nur rein und auf dem anderen Ohr wieder raus. Also Erklären, das finde ich auch immer auch so ein bisschen interaktiv, immer so ein bisschen gegenchecken den anderen irgendwie mal auch.
Aber da kann man aber auch gegenwirken, weil manchmal ist das ja nur so eine Verzweiflung, so dieses, oh Gott, ich verstehe es eh nicht. Fünf Leute haben schon probiert, mir das zu verstehen. Ich bin ja zu doof dazu. Das ist nicht meine Welt. Was man nicht alles immer so hört. Und auch da kann man, glaube ich, was dagegen tun, indem man, gut, das ist jetzt eine sehr psychologische Geschichte, hat erstmal was mit Zuhören auch wieder zu tun. Aber man muss dann vielleicht auch erstmal rausfinden, okay, was sind denn Dinge, die dir gelingen? Was sind Bereiche, in denen du dich wohlfühlst und in denen du deine Erfolge hast? Und aus diesen Bereichen, und das kann irgendwas sein, was weiß ich, versuche Computer zu erklären, aber das ist mit einer Person zu tun, die eigentlich nur aus Sport irgendwie was ziehen kann. Dann versuche ich meine Metaphern möglichst aus diesem positiv besetzten Feld, die dieser Person quasi naheliegt und wo sozusagen allein die Erwähnung von, und wenn du dann die Hürde übersprungen hast, wenn du irgendwie deinen Marathon abgeschlossen hast, weißt du, so was. Aber die Anstrengung irgendwie, und dann diese bei Kilometer 5, wenn die Maschine noch nicht so richtig warm ist, also ist das nur ein Beispiel, in irgendwas eintauchen, wo schon positive Konnotationen, Erfahrungen und Erfolgserlebnisse sind. Und da anzudecken, um dann irgendwie daraus vielleicht auch seine Metaphern zu ziehen, um erstmal so kleine Schritte bereitzumachen.
Ja, man kann alles erklären. Wenn jemand das zu schwer ist, dann braucht man vielleicht ein bisschen länger zum Erklären, aber eigentlich müsste das immer gehen. Das Zuhören ist auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig, dass man weiß, wo der andere ist, was er nicht versteht, und dann kann man da nochmal genau nachhalten.
Aber genau das, was Tim auch gerade sagte, mit dem vielleicht auch sich nicht trauen oder sozusagen, ja nee, ich programmier eh nicht, habe ich jetzt halt auch irgendwie einmal gesagt bekommen, ich kann dir jetzt nur so Bedingthilfe geben im Sinne von, ich kann dir Dinge erklären, ich kann dir Hilfestellungen im Sinne von, welche Webseiten gibt es, die dir deine Fragen vielleicht auch erklären können, beziehungsweise wo du auch programmieren vielleicht auf einer besseren Art und Weise lernst, als in einem Kurs, aber ich kann sie auch nur anbieten jemandem und wenn ich dann so dieses höre, ja ich programmiere ja gar nicht, dann denke ich mir, du musst es halt auch schon selber machen, wie auch schon jemand im Chat sagte, es ist halt so ein Teil, oder du auch gerade sagtest, man kann nicht nur zuhören, man muss selber ausprobieren und rumspielen und auch mal ordentlich frustriert sein, wenn man etwas Neues lernt.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Genau, bis dann wirklich mal so der Sweet Spot oder der Süßpunkt, wie Roddy vorhin sagte, kommt, an dem die Sachen halt auch funktionieren und man endlich merkt so, geil, ich habs geschnallt. Und das ist halt auch irgendwie schwierig, weil ich beziehe das gerade halt total häufig auf mich als Lehrkörper, wie man so schön sagt. Wenn jemand eben so gefühlt aus der Vorlesung dann geht und sagt, ja ne, hier lerne ich jetzt eh nichts mehr oder denke ich mir halt so, ja, hab ich jetzt irgendwas falsch gemacht oder kann die Person vielleicht einfach in so einer Umgebung auch nur nicht lernen.
Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass ich zum Beispiel in Mathe in der Schule schon immer so gut war. Nicht weil ich so gut war, sondern weil ich das Glück hatte, dass ich sowohl in der Grundschule als auch in der Oberschule einen guten Mathe-Lehrer hatte.
Oh, das ist sehr viel wert. Ich hatte einen furchtbar schlechten.
Meiner war sehr lustig.
Oh Gott, jetzt kommt die Mathe-Lehrer-Story-Side.
Meiner war auch noch Sportlehrer.
Er hatte einfach einen herausragenden Humor.
Mein Englischlehrer übrigens auch. Mein Mathe-Lehrer hat, ich war super schlecht in Mathe, passt jetzt zu meinem Gesamtbild. Und er hat mir irgendwann aus Frust in der gesamten Klasse sozusagen den Heft auf den Tisch gesnallt und irgendwie Sebastian, du wirst das nie lernen! Dieses ganze Internet-Scheiße, das du machst, das hat keine Zukunft! Und ich hätte ihn so gerne heute angerufen und gesagt, vor drei Jahren schon, ich lehne, ich lebe davon sogar, von dieser Internet-Scheiße.
Wie alt bist du, dass dein Mathelehrer vom Internet erzählen konnte?
Was? Wie alt ich bin?
Dass dein Mathelehrer von Internet erzählen kann.
Na, ich bin ja 35. Also ich bin 2001 noch zur Schule gegangen, also zum Gymnasium. Und da war das ja der große Hype. Und irgendwie, ich hatte damals Lahnpartys organisiert, und deswegen war ich so ein bisschen da in der Schule, halt auch irgendwie so eine Personality, also man kannte mich sozusagen. Also es war mit...
Der Internet-Guy.
Ja, ja, es war halt so dieser Internet-Typ, dieser verrückte. Ich hab, weißt du, meine Lieblingsstory aus der Schulzeit ist, dass ich meine Abitur-Abschlussarbeit, das sind so sechs Stunden, wo man dann nur so sitzt, da hab ich den Rektor gefragt, ob ich den nicht am Laptop schreiben könnte, was damals sozusagen so vollkommen Order of the Order war. Es gab halt, also es gab weder Computer noch Laptops an dieser Schule.
Heutzutage sind ja sogar Taschenrechner erlaubt, ne?
Ja, und ich hab, ich hatte eine Deutsch-Leistungsarbeit und meine Handschrift war so schlecht, dass ich gesagt hab, ich würde lieber am Rechner schreiben, musste dann die automatische Word-Korrektur ausschalten. Und um dann natürlich das Endergebnis, das musste ja, kann ich nicht nach Hause nehmen und dann der Lehrerin per E-Mail schicken oder so, gesehen davon, dass ich keine E-Mail hatte. Also hab ich einen Laserdrucker mit in die Schule gebracht, was damals sozusagen, also, dann hatte ich dann so einen Mutebeutel noch mit dabei. Und als ich dann, also die anderen Spitzschüler wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt nichts, als ich angefangen hab, meinen Laptop aufzuklappen und meinen Laserdrucker neben mir aufzubauen, da waren Augen sozusagen so auf mich gerettet. So, what the fuck, this man from the future ist.
Welches Jahr?
2001, 2002, 2002? Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wann ich Abitur gemacht hab, aber so um die Zeit, ja. Also es war halt eigentlich albern, da gab's schon alles, aber es war halt noch an der Schule nicht angekommen. Es ist ja leider, ich frag immer meine Nichte und die sagt so, ich sag's nicht, ja was habt ihr denn so eines? Na wieso? Zettel und Stiften? Es ist immer noch keine Laptops angekommen in der Schule.
In Costa Rica gab's übrigens oder in Nicaragua ganz große Werbung für One Laptop per Child. Vielleicht sollte man das dann auch noch hier einführen.
Ich hatte einen Grundschullehrer, der hatte Matheunterricht, der hatte echt einen extremen Weitblick. Man muss sozusagen, das waren Siebziger, da hat er uns erstens mal, da gab's halt so Rechnen auf anderen Zahlenbasen, wurde da irgendwie gelehrt. Die ganzen Parallelklassen hatten irgendwie auf Fünfer-Basis, auf Dreier-Basis, auf Siebner-Basis, sonst was gemacht. Wir hatten nur Binär. Der hat also mit uns nur Binär gemacht. Nur Zweier-Basis, geht doch.
Himm wäre auf ihn sehr stolz gewesen.
Und dann hat er vor allen Dingen auch sehr viel Mengenlehre gemacht und hat die Mengenlehre halt auch so gemacht, dass du hinterher auch Bullshit-Operatoren verstehst. Also das war halt, und das in der dritten Klasse. Das war halt irgendwie auch total genial. Und der Typ, der war aber schon, keine Ahnung, der hat glaube ich einen Weltkrieg noch mitgemacht, irgendwie super alt, aber der hat diesen extremen Weitblick gehabt. Das hat echt lang gedauert, bis ich das gemerkt habe.
Und was nie so ein gutes Verhältnis ist, wenn man seinen Sportlehrer auch als Mathelehrer hat und man vorzugsweise gerne nicht zum Sportunterricht geht und wenn man da ist, nur seine Eins mal eben mitnimmt, um dann wieder abzuhauen. Das hat sich immer so ein bisschen ausgewirkt.
Also stellen wir jetzt fest, ich bin der einzige schlechte Mathe-Schüler im Tisch hier, oder?
Nein, nein, bin ich auch gewesen und mein, ich bin in Mathe nie wirklich gut gewesen. In Sport, nicht in Mathe. Aber deswegen hat er mich halt auch gehasst und hat das auch so ein bisschen dann auch in einem Matheunterricht mitgenommen. Das war irgendwie nicht so eine gute Kombi. Und selbst noch in der Uni, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mit Formeln nicht so gut. Ich hab dann irgendwann mal zu meinem Mathe-Prof gemeint, ich so, ja, also wenn das hier alles nicht in Formeln wäre, sondern Pseudo-Code, fände ich das total klasse. Und er hat so die Augen gerollt, weil ich bei ihm auch formale Sprachen, Automaten hatte und das fand ich halt leicht. Und dann bin ich halt so, das geht nicht, du fällst mir halt durch Mathe durch und gehst durch Automaten, dann kommst du irgendwie einfach so mit dem Fingerschnipp, versteht er nicht. Und es war ziemlich lustig. Aber Mathe war auch, wie gesagt, durch die Formeln immer so ein bisschen, ist nicht meine Notation.
Ich kann dich übrigens beruhigen, also Mathe-Abi habe ich ein bisschen Probleme gehabt.
Das beruhigt mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Das ging nicht ganz so einfach.
Ich habe hier Minderwertigkeitskomplexe größten Ausmaßes an diesem Tisch, aber das ist okay, muss ich durch.
Ich habe nur reales Schöne, das bleibt ganz locker.
Ja, aber ich habe auch...
Ich meine, nichtsdestotrotz stellst du alle in den Schatten hier, aber... Ja, Formelle Schuldbildung glaube ich eh nicht so richtig dran. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen Mitarbeiter einstelle und mir dann ihre Zeugnisse zuschicken, dann denke ich immer so was willst du, geh weg. Also ich will nicht deine Zeugnisse haben, was hast du denn außerhalb der Schule gemacht? Also das ist halt... Aber ich weiß dann nicht, ob ich das...
Hast du Projekte gemacht, hast du selber mal was gemacht?
Irgendwas, irgendwas.
Telefon-Interview, spätestens eine halbe Stunde, ist alles klar.
Ich hatte auch irgendwie immer den Eindruck, ich meine, ich habe Abitur, aber das ist auch eher, glaube ich, ich glaube ein Jahr später, und ich hätte auch kein Abitur.
Weil du schon zu alt warst und schon zu viel Scheiß gemacht hast.
Weil ich auch nicht so gut war, und mein Leben geriet aus den Fugen, irgendwie so langsam, aber nicht schnell genug aus den Fugen, damit noch das Abitur verhindert werden konnte, sagen wir es mal so. Also ich habe schon mal ein Jahr vorher schon versucht, wollte ich irgendwie von der Schule weg, keine Ahnung, ich wusste gar nicht, was ich wollte, aber ich wollte nur irgendwie Rebellion. Und dann habe ich dann trotzdem einfach dieses Abitur gemacht, auch nicht besonders gut, irgendwie 2,5 oder so im Schnitt. Und dann hatte ich dann auch irgendwie schnauzevoll. Dann bin ich trotzdem noch mal kurz auf einer Universität gelandet, weil mich meine Freunde bequatscht haben, weil sie irgendwie meinten, ich müsste jetzt mit ihnen mitgehen. So, aber dann habe ich mir das halt angeschaut, das Elend, und dachte mir nur so, ey, sorry, aber nee.
Ja, also ich hätte glaube ich auch weder Schulabschluss noch Uniabschluss ohne meine Mutter, die mich halt sozusagen irgendwie da gebeizt hat moralisch. Der feine Herr. Nee, ja, ich meine, Mutter haben einen großen Einfluss. Aber ich fand es halt, also während der Schulzeit habe ich so viel untern gemacht, dass ich halt, ja, die Schule echt nur so nebenbei gemacht habe. Also es war so das Ding, wo man am Vormittag abgehangen war, und dann ging es los. Ich war damals schon Chefredakteur eines Onlineportals mit sehr vielen Lesern und ich habe sozusagen so nebenbei, während des Unterrichts schon so ein bisschen noch mal gecheckt, was die Kommentare machen und so.
Ja, habe ich auch gemacht, das war bei 96.
Stimmt, du hast doch diese, wie ist hier noch, Macintosh-Postelle?
Mac.seite.
Ich habe mich auch eine Weile getragen, irgendwie sowas zu starten, habe ich dann aber trotzdem nicht gemacht, obwohl ich schon einen Namen hatte.
Es hat Spaß gemacht. Dann kam ja hier Mac, wie heißt es denn hier, Mac Gadget oder so, diese deutschen Dinger, gibt es die immer noch, ja. Die kamen dann so auf und haben da auch mehr Manpower reingesteckt und haben mich dann überflügelt, aber ich war die Erste. Also 96. Da gab es sowieso nichts.
Spiegel online, ne?
Ich hab meins auch nur von Mac Groomers geklaut damals und hab das ins Deutsch übersetzt. Plus, so wie ich jetzt hier bei der Sendung meinen Stuff einbringe, hab ich da dann auch, was ich sowieso so rausfinde, da dann noch so ein bisschen mit reingeklebt, aber das lief.
Pirat von Beginn an.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab also Schule auch irgendwie so als überflüssig empfunden und halt auch fast gar nicht mich fürs Abi beworben, weil ich auch nur Realschule am Anfang gemacht hab.
Mir fehlt einfach die Motivation, mich groß irgendwie anzustrengen. Die Achievements, da gab es keine Achievements.
Genau, aber das hat sich halt im Studium komplett gewandelt, weil da hab ich halt Informatik studiert und Informatik ist geil. Und da hab ich halt so wirklich das erste Mal gemerkt, also ja, da ist halt genau das, was ich will. Und da kann ich mich reinnerden. Und da stört es keinen, wenn ich das Wochenende, die Sonne an mir vorbeiziehen sehe und programmiere.
Und am zocken bist.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, das auch.
Wie bist du? Du arbeitest jetzt in deiner Uni weiterhin. Also dir gefällt grundsätzlich das Uni-Leben?
Das ist gut, aber nicht auf Dauer. Also mir fehlt auch so ein bisschen ein größeres Team mit Informatikern, mit Informatik-Hintergrund.
Also mit Profis und nicht mit Studenten, meinst du?
Nee, nee, nee, ich meine, ich habe in meinem Team sehr viele Designer und also so Interfaces sehr viel, was total großartig ist, um als Entwickler mal die Design-Perspektive richtig kennenzulernen und die Zusammenarbeit wertzuschätzen. Aber es fehlt mir dann so an einigen Stellen der Austausch mit anderen, die halt auch mehr, ich sag mal, Hardcore-Coder sind einfach, mit denen ich mich mal unterhalten kann.
Was macht dir denn mehr Spaß, Design oder Coden?
Ich mache gar kein Design, das ist ja der Punkt. Also Design mache ich gar nicht. Ich mache ein bisschen Frontend, CSS, wenn es sein muss. Und bin immer ziemlich froh, wenn ich es nicht machen muss. Und bin jetzt auch eher sogar, dass ich eben so Backend und Server mich gerade sehr viel mehr flasht, weil ich es einfach irgendwie spannend finde. Und was ich eben auch gerade meinte mit so verteiltes Rechnen, finde ich jetzt auch nicht unspannend. Und gerade zu einer Visualisierung sehe ich halt so das Potenzial, dass du eben die Möglichkeit hast, auch sowas zu machen, wo du nicht nur übertrieben gesagt irgendeine schöne Grafik am Ende rauskommt, die irgendwie ein bisschen interaktiv ist, sondern du dich um so ganz viel Giraffel hinten dran kümmern kannst, was die Leute aber nicht sehen. Was aber vielleicht für eine Visualisierung, die mit sehr vielen Daten arbeitet, aber total wichtig ist. Deswegen, also ich bin auf gar keinen Fall Designer. Das wäre ja eine Beleidigung für jeden Designer, wenn ich mich das nennen würde. Nein, nein. Deswegen.
Komisch, ich bin hier totaler Außenseiter. Mich hat die Schule nicht weiter gestört. Also nicht groß interessiert, aber das wird einfach fertig.
Ich war halt faul.
Ja, faul war ich auch, aber es ging irgendwie trotzdem. Ich glaube, ich habe drei Wochen vor dem Abi das erste Mal richtig gelernt.
Ja gut, ich meine, das stört mich nicht. Mich stört sozusagen mehr das Konzept Schule. Also wie letztens, ich kann es immer so mit Beispielen bringen, kam halt so ein Typ an, der meinte, er ist TÜV-zertifizierter Social Media Manager. Da musste ich echt ins Lachen ausbrechen.
TÜV-zertifizierter?
Das war so sein Ding. Was heißt das? Ja, ich hatte einen dreiwöchigen Kurs. Der war ehemaliger Soldat. Wenn du ein Soldat bist, wirst du überführt ins Zivilleben, wirst du bereit gemacht, die Waffe so vorsichtig aus der Hand genommen. Dann werden dir diese Kurse geschickt. Dann gibt es zum Beispiel einen TÜV-zertifizierten Social Media Manager. Dann meinte ich, ja, okay. Dann melde dich mal in drei Jahren, wenn du irgendwas gemacht hast damit. Das ist halt dieses ganze deutsche Denken. Es ist immer geprimed durch, wir brauchen einen Zertifikat, wir brauchen TÜV, wir brauchen Abiturnote, wir brauchen Uni-Abschluss.
Die Scheingläubigkeit.
Ja, es ist halt eine Pseudo-Vergleichbarkeit, die man möchte. Man möchte gerne Dinge in Boxen packen und sozusagen Labels drauf tun. Und Menschen sind aber individuell. Ich meine, das ist jetzt alles so Standard-Floor-Skin. Das wissen ja alle, aber ich finde es besonders nervig, gerade wenn man in Bezug auf die neue Welt schaut, wo es eben nicht mehr darum geht, 7 Millionen Industriearbeiter am Fließband auszubilden, die alle das Gleiche machen oder die alle irgendwie das gleiche TÜV-Zertifikat für den Otto-Motor bekommen. Sondern es geht jetzt darum, individuell denken zu können, selbstständig handeln, zu deren Lösungen selbst auch zu finden und nicht einfach nur Standard-Dinge umzusetzen. Wir gehen eben weg von dieser Gesellschaft, in der sozusagen Dinge standardisiert sind. Und sozusagen die IT ermöglicht individuelle Lösungen. Und da müssen wir hin. Und das gilt für alle Bereiche von Journalismus, Musik machen, zeichnen, egal wo. Du musst deine individuelle Kreativität stärken und nicht sagen, ich habe Standardprogramm XYZ durchlaufen. Weil das haben auch drei Millionen andere. Und im Zweifelsfall kann das auch ein Computerprogramm das Standardprogramm. Deine individuellen Stärken sind das, was zählt.
Ja und vor allen Dingen, ob die Leute das verstanden haben. Also ich habe ja auch diverse Leute eingestellt. Und das ist halt für mich, ich versuche die Fragen immer so zu formulieren, dass Leute halt erklären müssen. Nicht was macht man in dem Moment, sondern warum macht man das, was man tut? Und das ist halt meistens, merkt man halt dann sehr stark, haben die Leute wirklich verstanden, was sie da tun? Haben sie verstanden, warum sie das tun? Und wenn sie verstanden haben, was sie tun, dann wissen sie auch, dass sie in einem etwas anderen Moment auch was anderes tun müssen und nicht einfach nur die Standardlösung draufkleben.
Ja, das ist auch wieder mit dem Erklären, wenn man so dieses Einstellungsgespräch oder dieses Casting, die auch immer ein bisschen interaktiv macht, dann merkt man auch, was man da gegenüber zu sitzen hat. Wenn man denen so simpel irgendeinen Test gibt und die irgendwas ausfüllen, dann hast du ja auch wieder nichts gelernt, oder? Deswegen will man schon interaktiv, oder?
Ja, wir machen halt immer ein Telefoninterview. Also klar, man guckt erstmal die Unterlagen durch, da fallen natürlich, sagen wir mal, zwei Drittel raus. Und dann machst du ein Telefoninterview, da fallen dann halt vielleicht auch nochmal 50 Prozent raus. Und die Leute, die dann durchs Telefoninterview durch sind, den schickst du halt. Also entweder wir laden die ein und dürfen das vor Ort machen, oder schickst du es ihnen hin, halt so eine Coding-Challenge. Baue das!
Aber ihr seid jetzt nicht so, dass ihr sagt, schickt uns mal bitte dein Abiturzeugnis.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, mal ein Abiturzeugnis von einem Bewerber gesehen zu haben. Also normalerweise guckt man nur den Lebenslauf an. Gut, dass diese ganzen Zeugnisse...
Den guckt man auch schon nicht wirklich an, oder?
Ja, ein bisschen schon. Die ganzen Zeugnisse, das macht alles HR. Also die gucken das alles an. Wenn da irgendwas faul ist, dann schmeißen sie mehr oder weniger eh schon raus. Aber nee, am Ende des Tages brauchst du auch keinen Abitur für das, was wir machen. Du musst es halt können. Wie gesagt, wir machen eine Coding-Challenge und dann schreibt der Mann oder die Frau halt irgendwas und dann guckst du dir den Code an und sagst, warum hast du das so gemacht? Und wenn die dann ihren Code erklären müssen, dann merkst du sehr stark, ob sie sich was dabei gedacht haben oder ob der einfach so passiert ist. Ja, weil das macht man so. Das ist halt keine Antwort.
Ich musste ja auch meine erste richtige Bewerbung jetzt wirklich in diesem öffentlichen Dienstkonstrukt schreiben. Aber es ist halt so der Moment gewesen, wo ich dachte, okay, strange, weil vorher war das eher so, du komm halt mal vorbei und wir reden. Und da ist das wirklich so äußerst formal mit, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Abi-Zeugnis hinschicken musste, aber so Master-Zeugnis, Bachelor-Zeugnis auf jeden Fall erst mal. Ansonsten wirst du da ja gar nicht in die Auswahl genommen, wenn du halt auch noch in diese Ehegeschichten, also du bist ja öffentlicher Dienst, dann wirst du nach Tarif bezahlt.
Das ist auch der einzige Grund, warum man noch diese Uni-Abschlüsse braucht, nämlich in diesem öffentlichen Dienst, wo halt in Großunternehmen, die eben auch irgendwie scheinbar unfähig sind, etwas neue Prozesse eben etablieren, die dann eben auf die Bille.
Da hab ich auch ne Geschichte. Ich hab mich mal bei Siemens beworben auf irgendeinen Job und hab denen alle Unterlagen hingeschickt, aber halt, wenn du 10 Jahre studiert hast, dann, ich hab halt kein Abiturzeugnis mitgeschickt. Und dann meinten die so, ja, wir brauchen aber noch das Abiturzeugnis. Und ich so, naja, okay, dann schickst du es halt noch hin. Und dann haben die halt gesehen, dass in dem Abiturzeugnis stand halt für Mathe ne 3 drin.
Das sind echt Trottel. Also das muss man echt mal sagen, wer auf sowas achtet, in einem Abiturzeugnis.
Aber dann dachte ich mir, naja, gut. Dann will man da auch nicht arbeiten.
Ich glaube schon seit 20 Jahren, oder vor 22 Jahren, habe ich mich, glaube ich, zum letzten Mal mit Zeugnis irgendwie beworben. Da war ich ja auch noch ein bisschen jünger, da musste man wahrscheinlich so machen. Aber seitdem immer nur noch irgendwie Leute, die ich eh schon kenne, die dann ankommen und sagen, hier Dennis, du programmierst doch da gerade schon auf dem iPhone da, also 2008, ne? Willst du nicht mal hier bei uns irgendwie fürs iPhone programmieren? Und schwupp, hast du einen Job? Also es ging...
Ich meine, die Programmierer-Welt ist sowieso nochmal... Ich meine, ihr seid so umkämpft, ja? Also jetzt sag ich ihr, aber diese Menschen, die programmieren können, das ist sowieso eine andere Welt. Aber ich sag mal, es gilt ja eben auch für immer mehr Berufe, dass das eben nicht mehr um die Standards ankommt. Und ich find's halt schade, dass das Bildungssystem da eben immer noch auf AB-Tests, also irgendwie ausführlich an Kreuztests und lernt halt Dinge auswendig. Also das gesamte Konzept von wir geben Schulbücher raus, und dann gibt es einen Kanon, und dann gibt es am Ende des Jahres Prüfungen. Und es gibt irgendwie, weißt du, sozusagen Standards Wissen Kanons, die vermittelt werden und in Hürne reingeprügelt werden. Und es gibt null individuelle Lernförderung, die wirklich darauf basiert, dass jemand erst mal angeschaut wird. Was kann der eigentlich? Jetzt ohne die DDR irgendwie preisen zu wollen, aber das haben die schon damals ein bisschen besser gemacht. Also da gab es wirklich sozusagen eine Anschauung von Schülern. Was kann dieser Schüler und wo können wir den irgendwo mal hinbringen in der Gesellschaft? Und dann hat das nicht zwingend bedeutet, dass der eben immer alles machen musste, sondern dann hat er eine spezielle Förderung bekommen, hat mehr Sportunterricht bekommen, oder hat mehr Musikunterricht bekommen und so weiter. Und das basiert eben auf einer individuellen Bewertung der Schüler. Das sind so Dinge, die halt irgendwie verloren gegangen sind und deswegen eben unser Bildungssystem ist ja immer noch sehr preußisch sozusagen inspiriert. Und die Preußen wollten eben ein großes, stehendes Herharten und wollten dafür sozusagen ein Standardwissen vermittelt bekommen. Dafür wurde das Schulsystem entwickelt.
Aber hier haben sie ja auch das Berufsinformationszentrum. Da hast du ja schon auch gesagt, was du kannst, was dir Spaß macht, wie deine Noten sind. Und dann haben die dir schon auch dementsprechend Berufsvorstellungen vorgestellt.
Aber das Berufsinformationszentrum hat ja nichts mit deiner schulischen Busbildung zu tun. Und die sagen ja nicht, Lehrer, lassen sie dich mal ein bisschen in den Boden. Ja, in der Schule musste das gefördert werden. Und zwar in der Grundschule bereits. Da muss entdeckt werden, das ist ein musikalisches Kind, das ist ein sportliches Kind, das ist ein technisches Kind, was sich für Mathe und Logik interessiert. Das ist ein Forscher. Und dann musst du deine Kurse wählen können. Und dann muss auch ein Kind, was sozusagen talentiert ist in einem bestimmten Bereich, auf eine höhere Schule gehen dürfen, auch wenn es vielleicht in bestimmten anderen Bereichen schlecht ist. Ich hatte zum Beispiel das Glück, ich bin Legastheniker. Meine Deutschkenntnisse waren katastrophal. Ich hatte eine Rechtschreibung. Ich hatte sozusagen durchgehende Sex, mein gesamtes Schulleben. Hätte es nicht damals sozusagen auch in Westdeutschland dann ein System gegeben, dass Legasthenik anerkannt wird als Krankheit, hätte ich überhaupt keine Chance gehabt an Gymnasium. Und mein gesamtes Leben hätte einen anderen Weg genommen, nur weil es standardisiert muss ich Deutsch können, also rechtschreibmäßig technisch, für einen Aspekt des Deutschen sozusagen. Und ich finde es halt schade, dass viele Kinder, die bestimmte Sachen nicht können, aber großartige Talente haben in anderen Bereichen und auch neugierige Kinder sind dann eben so Lebenschancen versagt bekommen, weil man sie versucht in Packungen zu stecken. Wie gesagt, ich höre mir so, das ist alles so bekannt, trotzdem regt es mich immer noch auf. Und ja, weil kam ja von erklären, sind jetzt in sehr großem Bogen gelaufen zur Schulbildung. Aber ja, es ist halt...
Eigentlich sind wir immer noch beim selben Thema.
Und das sind wichtige Aspekte. Ich hatte ja auch gerade, kann ich ja mal kurz planken, vor kurzem mich mit Harald Lesch unterhalten dürfen, Vorschlaggeist. Das ist legendär. Weiß ich nicht, aber war ganz okay. Also hast du das gehört schon?
Nein, tatsächlich nicht. Ich habe nur deine Werbung schon dafür gehört. Wo hast du das geplagt?
Ich bin manchmal ganz überrascht, dass immer Leute erzählen, was du diesen Podcast machst, auch schon seit fünf Jahren. Wusste ich ja noch gar nicht. Du kritisierst auch immer meine Social Media-Aufstellung nicht so gut?
Tims Social Media-Aufstellung ist eine Katastrophe, ist praktisch nicht existent. Die ist ja Verweigerungshaltung in der öffentlichen...
Jetzt kommen wir auf ein neues Thema.
Tim verweigert sich.
Was? Deine Social Media...
Analysieren wir mal. Ich wollte jetzt den Desch nur erzählen wegen dieser Bildungsaspekte, aber du hast eigentlich auch wunderbar gemacht.
Also, ihr habt einen zielgruppenspezifischen Angebot und ihr seid in einer sehr, sehr kleinen Bubble, die ich sehr liebe und deswegen höre ich es gerne und das ist total klug. Aber leider ist sozusagen ein ganz großes Potenzial, was ihr habt, nutzt ihr nicht. Also jetzt spreche ich von Plural, aber ihr gehört ja alle mit dazu, weil ihr sozusagen gewisse Verweigerungshaltung habt, was die Kanäle angeht. Und sozusagen, ich nehme ja nur das Beispiel Twitter, dass sozusagen Twitter eine Fixierung auf Twitter gibt und dass es eine Verweigerungshaltung gegenüber anderen Kanälen gibt, egal ob Instagram, Facebook, Vero oder sonst was. Das ist halt eigentlich ein großes vertaner Chance. Und natürlich YouTube auch. Ich weiß, du hast das alles. Wir haben ja auch zu zweit schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen. Aber ich persönlich finde halt den Content, den ihr produziert, extrem wertvoll. Und ich finde es unglaublich schade, dass ihr euch sozusagen so begrenzt in den Kanälen. Und es hat eine sehr starke ideologische Begründung, mit der ihr da rangeht, sozusagen so freie Kanäle. Und wir wollen uns nicht sozusagen von Facebook erklären lassen, wie wir unsere Content verbreiten. Und welche Reichweite wir haben.
Aber ist das wirklich ideologisch?
Ich glaube, das ist bei Tim und auch anderen in der Szene, von der wir sprechen, ist das schon eine ideologische Haltung. Und das Traurige daran ist, dass sozusagen der Content, der hier verbreitet und produziert wird, wahnsinnig wertvoll ist und wahnsinnig tolle Inhalte. Aber auch zum Beispiel Netz, Netz, wer ist das? Logbuch, Netzpolitik. Wenn ich das sehe und ich mir denke, warum haben die nicht eine Million Zuhörer? Und dann geht's auf YouTube und da ist Bibi's Beauty Channel. Okay, ist nicht vergleichbar und wird auch nie die Reichweite haben, aber dort... Tim ist eigentlich ein YouTube-Star. Könnte einer sein. Aber ihr habt einen genialen Content und vermauert euch ein in einer sozusagen Welt. Und das finde ich manchmal traurig. Nichtsdestotrotz, ich meine, ich finde es ja, aber es ist halt so schade, weil ihr euch...
Guck mal, du wirst doch nicht Rockstar, wenn du in einer Hitparade auftrittst.
Jetzt können wir das... Ich greife das mal auf. Ich habe ja auch zu jedem Kanal...
Die rote Karte mit dem Monolog.
So meine Ansichten, das kann man jetzt als ideologisch bezeichnen, hat aber auch andere Gründe. Mag hier und da etwas Ideologie mit drin sein, aber das ist auf gar keinen Fall nur. So was jetzt mal wie Instagram nimmt, Fotos. Ich schieße keine Fotos, ich mache keine Fotos, ich schaue mir keine Fotos an.
Das war ja wahrscheinlich nur so ein Beispiel, was jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz passt.
Ich sehe ja, natürlich ist es ja nicht so, dass ich nicht wahrnehme, dass viele Leute das benutzen und dass wir irgendwie ihre Dinge machen. Ich mach mir auch immer mal einen Account und schau da mal rein. So und nichts hat mich da berührt.
Ich hab's nicht verstanden, Instagram.
Also mich berührt auf Instagram.
Aber über Instagram kann man doch nur abmeckern. Posten Leute auf Twitter ein Instagram-Bild, dann klick ich da, dann will ich natürlich mal wieder ranzoomen, weil man will ja Details erkennen und dann kann ich bei Instagram nicht reinzoomen, weil das bei denen dann irgendwie nicht geht.
Ja, das ist aber eine technische Kritik.
Ja, aber warum machen die das? Die sollen einfach dieses scheiß Bild posten.
Also jeder Kanal, den ihr nutzt und der nicht euch gehört, jetzt sind wir wieder bei den Cloud-Geschichten, hat sozusagen seine Begrenzung. Und damit muss man leben, man muss die lernen und dann anpassen. Und man kann natürlich auf Instagram keine Podcast posten, um es mal so ganz banal zu sagen. Aber ihr könntet den Content, den ihr hier aufbereitet, sozusagen schon nochmal anders visuell aufbereiten. Und jetzt meintet ihr, die besten Zitate der Woche... Und die besten Zitate der Woche und auf Instagram posten.
Bist du eigentlich schockiert, wenn ich dir sage, dass einer meiner Podcasts auf Instagram tatsächlich beworben wird auf diese Art und Weise?
Ja, aber ich bin schockiert.
Mit diesen Live-Geschichten?
Ich tue das nicht selber.
Hast du jemand?
Forschergeist.
Wird sozusagen von denen gemacht?
Es gibt ja immer diese Videos, die landen auf Twitter, die landen auf Instagram. So. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das gut ist. Das wird gemacht. Ich kann keinerlei Reaktionen... Also, mir hat noch nie einer gesagt, weil auf Instagram, was passiert deswegen, Podcasts ist eine Information, die bei mir noch nie angekommen ist. Auch nur ein einziges Mal.
Tim braucht auch immer sehr viel Feedback, wenn da nicht die Zahlen kommen, dass da so und so viele Prozenture über Instagram reinkommen. Findest du das nicht gut?
Nein, das ist eine Gefühlsache, aber das kann zumindest mal einer erwähnen. Durch irgendetwas könnte es ja immer immanent werden.
Tim, wir können das insofern abkürzen, wenn du den Kanal nicht betreibst, ist er auch nicht authentisch, würde er auch nicht funktionieren. Entweder du gehst wirklich damit rein und das ist dein Kanal, der muss dann auch von dir betrieben werden, du musst da hinten stehen, du musst auch da einen Diskurs führen. Nur dann kann das funktionieren und ansonsten ist das halt so ein MeToo oder ein Müssen-wir-halt-machen oder so.
Aber ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, was ich da senden sollte, weil...
Also du musst deine Inhalte individuell auf die jeweiligen Kanäle anpassen und es ist sozusagen schon ein bisschen aufwendiger. Guck mal!
Das ist aber meiner Meinung nach schon der falsche Ansatz. Ein Kanal muss für meine Inhalte geeignet sein. Ich muss nicht meine Inhalte auf den Kanal anpassen, der Kanal muss zu meinem Inhalt passen.
Ja gut, dann bist du halt auf einen festgenagelt, nämlich Podcasting. Was ja auch okay ist, weil jetzt...
Ich mach ja nun mal Podcasting.
Jaja, nein! Du bist eine Personality. Du machst kein Podcasting, du bist eine Personality und du verkaufst über deine Personality, über deinen Charakter verkaufst du Erklärinhalte.
Aber ist das das, was er will, dass er über seinen Charaktersachen verkauft oder über den Inhalt?
Ja, das denkt er ja, das über den Inhalt. Das stimmt aber gar nicht.
Das denkt er überhaupt nicht, das ist mir vollkommen bewusst. Ich meine, ich benutze ja auch Twitter. Auf Twitter kann ich auch keinen Podcast veröffentlichen. Aber Twitter ist ein extrem gut geeigneter Kanal, der in seiner Art und Weise wie er Öffentlichkeit erzeugt, wie er Leser-Konsumenten- Verhältnisse abbildet, also das Follower-Modell, das war einfach von Anfang an überzeugt und Twitter hat ja die letzten zehn Jahre auch geliefert. Also für mich, sozusagen in meiner Nutzung, hat es mir was gebracht.
Twitter ist ein absoluter Eliten-Kanal, der sozusagen überhaupt keine Massenwirkung hat, außer die Tatsache, dass die Journalisten sozusagen ihn als Multiplikator nutzen.
Aber da bekomme ich doch genau die Leute, die ich haben will.
Das ist eine ehrliche Einschätzung, da würde ich mitgehen.
Und auf Facebook bekommt man dann welche Leute, nicht mehr die Elite, sondern den Mutensatz.
Da eben die 80% von denen, die du am Anfang gesprochen habt, die nicht das unterstützen, was Tim will. Jede befindet euch sozusagen eher im 20% oder eher im 0,2% pro Mille-Bereich. Dessen, was sozusagen an Bevölkerung da ist. Und die Masse der Menschen sind eben auf diesen Massenkanälen. Und Twitter im Besonderen ist halt ein Kanal, der absolut Elitenkommunikation ist. Also es gab mal eine Phase, wo ein paar Gamer auch auf Twitter unterwegs sind. Die Menschen sind auch noch immer da. Und so ein paar Promis. Aber gerade in Deutschland haben die Promis eigentlich auf Twitter nie so stark gefunden wie zum Beispiel in Amerika. Aber auch in Amerika ist das vorbei. Die Promis sind alle weg. Der einzige, der da ist, ist der Präsident. Ich meine, in Amerika ist sozusagen der US-Präsident noch da, Trump. Und ansonsten ist da auch nicht mehr viel los. Also Twitter ist sozusagen durch. In gewisser Weise auf einem... Absterbenden Ass.
Wo findet denn die Art... Nein, nein, absterbender Ass. Das würde ja bedeuten, dass die Diskussionen, die vorher auf Twitter geführt werden, jetzt woanders geführt werden.
In Amerika war es eben ein Massenphänomen, Twitter. Für eine Zeit lang. Das ist das, und das findet nicht mehr statt, das ist auf Facebook. Das ist komplett weg von Twitter. Natürlich findet auf Twitter immer noch eine Kommunikationsstadt, auch genauso wie in Deutschland eben so eine Art Elitendiskurs, Journalisten, Politiker, interessierte Menschen, die sich mit Politik beschäftigen, sowas.
Du hast die Geisteskranken vergessen.
Tante Erma sozusagen. Peter, der Netflix schaut, der ist halt auf Facebook und Instagram. Eine Zeit lang war er auf Snapchat, aber Snapchat ist auch gerade wieder so ein bisschen am Absinken und wurde von Instagram. Ihr habt eine Auswahl getroffen in euren Kanälen. Ich finde es schade, weil ich glaube, dass eure Inhalte eigentlich voll genial sind.
Ich mag das Elite-Wort ja nicht so, aber sind unsere Inhalte da nicht auch sehr elitemäßig? Würden Facebook andere Leute sind, würden die das überhaupt hören wollen?
Da ist ein Punkt. Zeitweise heute zum Beispiel, wo wir 20 Minuten irgendwie über Vor- und Nachteile von bestimmten Cloud-Installationen und bestimmten Prozessoren haben, das kann keiner aufnehmen, der sozusagen nicht in diesen... Aber es gibt, ich spreche, wenn ich von euch spreche, meinte ich auch Tim mit einer Metaebene. Er hat ja viele Podcast-Angebote. Davon sind viele auch über die, sag ich mal, CCC-Kernzielgruppe hinaus spannend. Und ich finde eben, da sind halt noch Unterschätze. Aber ich finde auch, dass selbst dieser Podcast hier sozusagen gerade junge Leute viel mehr ansprechen könnte. Und dass da einfach sozusagen Potenziale noch nicht ausgeschöpft sind.
Na was heißt denn ansprechen könnte? Du meinst, ich werbe nur nicht ausreichend dafür? Oder ich veröffentliche nicht an den richtigen Stellen?
Genau, du veröffentlichst nicht an den richtigen Stellen.
Was sind deiner Meinung nach die richtigen Stellen?
Die Massenkanäle. Facebook, Instagram, YouTube.
Auf Facebook kann man...
Tim ist sprachlos.
Du hast doch auf Facebook überhaupt nicht die Reichweite.
Ich glaube, die hast du schon. Aber die Frage ist, ob man das will.
Also ohne, dass du das bezahlst. Doch, auch ohne bezahlen. Eine Frage des Königs. Jeder Social Media-Kanal hat seine Regeln. Man muss diese Regeln befolgen und dann wird man vom Algorithmus belohnt. Es gibt vor allem Menschen, die langweilige Inhalte oder schlechte Inhalte oder nicht gut auf den Kanal angepasste Inhalte produzieren, die dann sich darüber beschweren, dass sie keine Reichweite bekommen. Oder die auch einfach nicht zu erzielen haben. Also ganz viele Leute, die sich am meisten über mangelnde Reichweite beschwert, sind halt irgendwelche Leute, irgendwelche Firmen, die irgendwas verkaufen wollen und die sich darüber aufregen, dass sie sozusagen nicht mehr kostenlos für ihre Matratzenladen eine Million Leute bei jedem Post erreichen. Und da muss man sich halt sagen, ja, aber du bist halt auch ein Matratzenverkäufer. Das ist halt auch nicht spannend.
Von alleine kommen die Leute auch nicht. Also ich mein, das muss ich ja rumsprechen, oder?
Na, du musst einen Mehrwert schaffen für die Nutzer. Das ist im Kern sozusagen, also das ist ja wie bei jedem Kanal, ne? Und was nur bei Facebook anders ist als bei Twitter, ist, dass ich nicht manuell wähle. Bei Twitter muss ich entscheiden, wer ist für mich interessant. Facebooks Idee ist sozusagen, wir nehmen das den Leuten ab und wir, der Algorithmus, entscheidet für die Menschen, was zu sehen ist. Und der Mensch gibt sozusagen Feedback an den Algorithmus durch Likes, Shares und Kommentare. Und wenn du es schaffst, interessante Inhalte zu kreieren, das gilt sowohl für Unternehmen als auch politische Organisationen, aber eben auch Creators, wie wir sie nennen, also Menschen wie Tim, dann, und die haben es eigentlich am einfachsten, weil wenn du journalistisch tätig bist, hast du ja per se interessante Inhalte, weil du Meinungen hast. Und du musst nicht immer jedes Mal versuchen, einen Post zu machen, der irgendwie versucht, noch eine Matratze zu verkaufen. Also eigentlich habt ihr das sozusagen ganz, ganz leicht. Und wie gesagt, ist alles nicht schlimm, das kann man alles machen. Ich finde es halt nur schade, weil ich die Produkte, die Tim macht, total super finde. Und ich finde, er unterstellt sich noch, einfach weil er aus einer Tradition kommt, die sozusagen eher 90er Jahre geprägt ist, aus dem klassischen 1.0-Internet. Und so ein bisschen so eine Verweigerungshaltung hat gegenüber den Plattformen.
Aber dafür läuft es ziemlich gut, für diese Verweigerungshaltung, findest du nicht?
Wenn es nicht so gut liefe, würde es ihnen ja gar nicht mehr gehen. Ich sage ja nur, dass es noch Potenziale gibt.
Guck mal, wenn, ich weiß jetzt nicht, die Zahlen von dieser Sendung, wie viele Leute die erreichen. Aber wenn du das jetzt mal stellst gegen einen, noch nicht mal die Top-YouTuber, dann ist das halt zu vernachlässigen. Weil die erreichen mit einer Sendung das, was ProSieben im Abend in Deutschland sucht, den Superstar erreicht. Erreicht so ein typischer 13-jähriger YouTuber mit seinem Blaber-Format, wo er echt Dummschiss entdehnt.
Definiere erreicht.
Erreicht, es sind richtig durchgeschauerte YouTube-Folgen. Die werden halt von zwei Millionen Leuten angeguckt. Und ich finde das halt, na gut, das hat halt natürlich auch Gründe, weil Jugendliche irgendwie...
Aber guck mal, Dummschiss, oder wie du das genannt hast, das kann man auch zwei Millionen mal unter die Leute schieben, weil da sind genug, die sich das antun. Ich glaube, das, was wir erzählen, dann vielleicht können doch nicht so viele mithalten.
Ja, also ich werde nie zwei Millionen haben, das ist klar. Aber es gibt eben mindestens, ich würde mal sagen, so vierfach, fünffach, zehnfach, vielleicht sogar hundertfach die Reichweite könntet ihr haben, wenn ihr euch einen gewissen Kanälen öffnen würdet. Und wie gesagt, es muss alles nicht sein, aber es ist einfach schön. Aber das wäre sozusagen mein Feedback, sozusagen. Das ist erstmal das erste, was mir auffällt, wenn ich auf das Angebot schaue, was die Metaebene bietet, dann sage ich, aha, interessant, da wird ein Potenzial, was da ist, nicht ausgeschafft.
Naja, es hat ja auch immer ein bisschen was mit den AGBs und den sonstigen Gepflogenheiten auf solchen Systemen zu tun. Und wie viel Freiheiten man da hat. Und mir sind also zum Beispiel schon mal Systeme, die von sich aus meinen Content entfernen können.
Geht mal gar nicht.
Da bin ich schon, nenn es ideologisch so, aber da hab ich einfach ein Problem mit. Das ist einfach, selber der Host da zu sein, ist schon mal eine Menge wert. Ganz abgesehen davon, was für merkwürdige Regeln da teilweise gelten mit Anstößigkeiten hier und inhaltlicher Bewertung und Copyright-Filter. Urheberrecht. Und dann spielst du mal irgendein Scheiß-Clip ein und dann wirst du halt gleich weggefleckt und hast vielleicht auch noch was drauf. Das ist auch alles ein Risiko. Das muss man in diese ganze Rechnung mit reinnehmen. Habe ich irgendwie auch relativ wenig Bock drauf.
Ich sag mal Folgendes, du hast mit allem Recht, man kann diese Kanäle nur bespielen, wenn man sozusagen die Regeln dieser Kanäle befolgt. Das ist halt eine Eingrenzung und das grenzt einen auch ein, als jemand, der creative ist. Und natürlich ist das auch ein genialer Vorteil, den ihr habt, dadurch, dass ihr diese Freiheit habt. Ich wollte mal eine Sache sagen, eine Sache, die jetzt eventuell zu euch zugunsten kommt, ist, dass Google jetzt hier angekündigt hat, das hatte ich ja auch in die Themenliste geschrieben, das können wir kurz vorziehen, dass sie jetzt Google Podcasts in die Web-Suchmaschine mit eintun. Das läuft's. Also zumindestens stand das da, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, aber wenn das jetzt wirklich so ist, dass in Zukunft da oben neben dem allgemeinen Google und Google News und Google Bilder dann auch Google Podcasts kommt, und Google hat auch angekündigt, dass sie die durchsuchen wollen, also audio-mäßig.
Weil du ihnen erlaubst, dass sie eine Kopie ausliefern von deiner Datei, von ihren eigenen Servern.
Das ist die Voraussetzung?
Wenn sich das nicht geändert hat, das haben sie ja im Prinzip letztes Jahr schon angekündigt, und haben da sozusagen einmal komplett die iTunes Exzensions kopiert. Wir machen jetzt mal dasselbe wie iTunes, nur dass wir irgendwie mit dem Kram selber...
Kannst du mal auf den Link klicken, den ich da in die Themenliste reingeschmissen habe?
Naja, ich kenne das Ding.
Achso, ok, hast du schon geklappt.
Da ist bloß jetzt relativ unklar, inwiefern das jetzt was Neues ist, bezüglich dem, was sie technisch schon vor einiger Zeit veröffentlicht haben. Das heißt, du wirst da halt nur angezeigt, wenn du in dem Google Play-Verzeichnis bist und in dem Google Play verzeichnest, bist du halt nur, wenn du dich da listen lässt. Listen heißt, hier sind unsere Rules, unsere Bedingungen. Unter anderem, wir liefern dann die Datei aus. Das heißt, Statistiken werden bei uns erzeugt. Wo ist denn das Problem? Wir machen dir hier auch schöne bunte Bilder. Das heißt, ich muss dann irgendwie wieder einen weiteren Kanal anklicken und schauen, was ist. Und ich habe sozusagen die Auslieferung. Die machen Re-encoding von meinen Inhalten. Da weiß ich nicht, was von meinen Metadaten übrig bleibt, etc., alles total problematisch.
Wie gesagt, ich verstehe deinen Punkt, aber ich bin ein großer Fan dieser Dienstleister, die sozusagen für dich Dinge tun. Aber klar ist auch, es ist ein gegenseitiges Geschäft. So ein Nehmen und Geben.
Die müssen nicht unbedingt meinen Kram hosten. Die können auch gerne mich einfach so finden und den Link anzeigen. Da muss ich auch überhaupt nichts für tun, weil ich bin komplett lesbar im Netz und die wissen alles, was sie wissen müssen. Das sind immer so quasi Angebote, die so einen Klumpfuß noch mit dran haben. Das finde ich irgendwie so problematisch.
Es ist halt das Einkassieren der Inhalte im Wesentlichen.
Genau.
Sie wollen die Inhalte unter Kontrolle kriegen.
Sie wollen, und es ist ganz interessant, dieses Rennen gerade um Podcasts. Weil alle wollen jetzt hier irgendwie das neue YouTube der Podcast sein. Dann kommt irgendwie auch alle zwei Wochen irgendein Startup angekrochen und meine Mailbox läuft die ganze Zeit über, weil sie meine ganzen E-Mail-Adressen, die in den Feeds drin stehen, durchspammen. Und so, ja, und du weißt, we've got the brain, you've got the looks, let's make lots of money und du musst nur hier und klick da und pipa po und dann hier diese ganzen hirntoten Radiostreaming-Portale, wie TuneIn und so weiter, die erstmal überall Feeds einsammeln, dich da irgendwie listen und so weiter. Und dann klick da hinterher und dann so, wie ist denn das hier da drin gelandet? Und so ist das einfach nur ein Podcast-Verzeichnis, was ja okay wäre, so ja. Und dann so, nee, dann lese ich mal so die AGP durch. Ja, und wenn du hier gewillt gelistet bist, dann akzeptierst du, dass wir da Werbung einblenden und pipa po und überhaupt Rechte-Übertragung und der ganze Glimpel. Schreibe ich denen irgendwie so, Leute habt ihr einen Arsch offen irgendwie? Wie kommt mein Content da rein? So, ja und bla bla bla, danke, dass sie sich an uns gewinnt haben. Das ist dann innerhalb von zwei Tagen auch gelöscht. Da musste ich jetzt bei Tune-In irgendwie den einen Feed jetzt glaube ich drei- oder viermal in den letzten sechs Monaten monieren, bis er dann jetzt auch endlich mal weg war. Ich hab's natürlich gleich geschreit von Tesla-Fahrern, weil die natürlich in ihrem bekloppten Gerät nur diese Tune-In-Frontend haben und Podcasts hören, die jetzt denken so, das kann ich aber keine Freak Show mehr hören. Sag ich halt nur so, kauft ihr ein anderes Auto? Mir doch egal!
Mein Punkt ist, dass du hast Recht, dass egal welchen Dienstleister du da zusammenarbeitest, und das gilt ja auch für Twitter, jeder kommt mit seinen Beschränkungen, mit seinen AGBs und Regeln und allem und eben auch Vereinnahmung von dir. Aber du darfst nicht unterschätzen, dass eben diese Plattform auch mit x Milliarden Nutzern oft kommt. Also vielleicht die kleinen Podcast-Dienstleiter jetzt noch nicht, aber Facebook ist halt sozusagen 50% des Internets momentan.
Und komischerweise gibt es einen riesigen Plattform-Anbieter, der seit 10 Jahren Podcasts unterstützt und überhaupt Null-Vereinnahmungen macht. Na ja, jetzt fangen wir auch langsam an. Ja, ich muss jetzt iTunes Podcasts verzeichnen, das war schon immer ein fair Deal. Wir listen den Feed, alle Metadaten, die da drinstehen, kommen aus deinem Feed. Kein Fünkel mehr. Hier ist eine offene Erweiterung für ein offenes Format, wo du den ganzen Kram reinschreiben kannst, der bei uns auftaucht. Das ist dann zum Standard geworden. Wir ownen nicht deinen Content, wir hosten den nicht, wir reinkohlen, wir fassen den überhaupt nie an, wir liefern den nur aus. Ja, dann halt das Übliche, kein Porn, pipa po.
Wie heißt der andere Podcast-Anbieter, der jetzt gerade sich mit unserem Jan Böhmermann diese eine Show eingestellt hat?
Das ist kein Podcast-Anbieter, das ist ein Musik-Streaming-Anbieter.
Ja klar, der aber auch Podcast. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist Spotify, also es ist für mich sichtbar, dass Spotify momentan etwas leistet, was iTunes in den letzten zehn Jahren nicht geschafft hat, nämlich Podcasts für die Masse wieder mal einfach und bedienbar zu machen, gerade weil sie es begrenzen und weil sie gewisse Vorgaben machen. Die Freiheit des Internets, sozusagen, dieses 90er-Jahre-Internet, wir haben alle unsere eigenen Survey, wir hatten mit der Cloud schon gesprochen und so weiter, das hat natürlich diese ganzen Vorteile von, die will ich überhaupt nicht abstreiten, das ist mit allem recht, aber es ist eben auch immer so, dass sozusagen Freiheit immer auch Komplexität bedeutet. Facebook ist ja nicht deshalb erfolgreich, weil sie sozusagen die komplexeste Plattform im Internet anbieten und da irgendwie das HTML besser funktioniert, sondern weil es eben sozusagen reduziert und weil der Nutzer eben nur klicke ein Foto an und das zu posten und es ist eben nicht, ich muss das Foto erst auf meinen Server hochladen, da muss ich mich mit einem HTML-Tag in meinen WordPress-Blog einbinden und dann muss ich irgendwie verschiedene, dann weiß ich aber noch nicht, wie ich den rechts und links ausrichten kann, das Bild, sondern das macht alles Facebook für mich.
Ja gut, aber Spotify macht ja Podcast-Hören nicht einfacher.
Doch.
Und Audible auch nicht.
Da hast du überhaupt keine podcast-spezifischen Funktionen drin, das ist irgendwie auf Musik gehen ausgerichtet.
Tim, du sprichst wieder von dir 20% und nicht 80%, mach's mal. Das ist ja zum Beispiel Audiobooks.
Nee, ich rede von der Zukunft, mein Freund. Ja, ich rede davon, wie es zu sein hat. Das, was heute ist, ist doch ja nicht, ich meine, ich lebe doch heute das, was ich vor zehn Jahren wollte. So, und ich bin aber auch nur deshalb hingekommen, weil ich das vor zehn Jahren schon wollte. Und ich will jetzt das Leben, wo ich in zehn Jahren sein will, und dann kann ich mich doch nicht von solchen Honks aufhalten lassen, die sich einfach nur an irgendeiner bekloppten Ist-Multimedia-Massenrealität orientieren und die mir am Ende nicht helfen werden. Die werden mich einfach, die wollen mich einfach nur in ihre scheiß Plattform einsperren und mir ihre Regeln aufdrücken.
Ja, aber solange du nicht anerkennst, dass die Plattform eben auch die Plattform per Einsperrung selbst einen Mehrwert hat. Kannst du natürlich, kann ich rede dich gegen eine Wand, aber es ist eben so, dass es für den Nutzer einfacher ist. Der Nutzer muss das nicht verstehen, ich muss nichts verstehen vom Internet, um Facebook als App zu benutzen. Das ist der Vorteil. Ich muss nicht verstehen, wie Fotos fotografieren, um bei Instagram Filter anzuwerben. Ich muss nicht Photoshop kennen. Was muss man bei Postkarten wissen?
Wenn mich Leute fragen, wie man Postkarten hört, sag ich, du tippst auf Podcasts auf deinem Telefon und dann gibst du PritLove ein, Return, und dann drückst du nur noch aufs Plus, fertig. Das ist alles. Wo ist denn die Komplexität?
Oder du tippst bei Google Freak Show ein und dann kommt da eine Webseite und dann... Und dann drückst du auf Play.
Ja, meine Erfahrung mit Nutzern ist, dass sie das nicht können und dass sie es nicht schaffen, ein Podcast, also eine Podcast-URL oder in einem Suchverzeichnis, einen Podcast rauszusuchen, sondern dass tatsächlich diese speziellen User-Interfaces Mehrwerte bringen und für die Masse der Nutzer... Also anders wäre ja nicht zu erklären, warum Facebook 80% des gesamten veröffentlichten Inhalts aufgesogen hat und warum sind denn Leute heute nicht mehr Blogger, sondern Instagramer, warum sind sozusagen die Leute...
Wie kommt man da bitte vom Bloggen nach Instagram?
Nein, ich meine, diese Reduzierung von Komplexität ist das, was Plattformen erfolgreich macht. Und es ist eben sozusagen, du hast als jemand, der Content in diese Plattform einstellt, natürlich weniger Freiheiten, aber du hast eben mehr Audience, weil es für die Audience einfacher gemacht wird, diesen Inhalt zu folgen, zu abonnieren, weil sie einer Standardisierung untergelaufen sind, bevor sie veröffentlicht wurden. Und die Freiheit des Internets hat sozusagen den Nachteil, dass es komplexer ist. Und es ist unglaublich leicht, davon zu sprechen, zu sagen, aber es ist doch nicht schwer, einen Podcast zu abonnieren. Das ist natürlich, aus unserer Perspektive wird es sich schwer vorstellen, warum das schwer ist. Aber wenn ich jetzt Dennis Mutter mir vorstellen würde oder meine Mutter, dann weiß ich, wie schwer das ist. Und diese Apps oder sonstige Plattformen helfen dort. Und schon die Tatsache, dass sie aufbereiten oder irgendwie den Podcast der Woche pushen und so weiter. Und man kann trotzdem natürlich sagen, die Plattformen könnten offener sein und sie könnten sich an Web-Standards halten und sie könnten und so weiter. Aber natürlich müssen die auch überleben und sie müssen ihren Geld verdienen und sie müssen sich gegen Übernahmen schützen und sie müssen halt kommerzielle Realitäten ermessen. Das kann man halt ignorieren, das kann man betlagen, das kann man sich gegen sperren und dann hat man eben den Effekt, dass man eben in seiner kleinen Basis ist und die Masse eben nicht erreicht. Und das wird dir wie gesagt schade, weil dir Content eigentlich gut ist und du hast auch ein Geschäftsmodell, was dir nicht erfordert, dass du zum Beispiel Werbung einblendest oder dass du irgendwie davon auf, wie zum Beispiel die Zeitungsverlage, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie ihre eigenen Werbeserver betreiben und so weiter. Und die deswegen ein großes Problem mit Facebook haben. Weil du bist ja finanziert durch deine Spenden und du musst ja eigentlich nur Reichweite haben und je mehr Reichweite du hast, desto mehr Fans kannst du generieren. Und diese gesamten YouTuber haben ja sozusagen auch im Prinzip jetzt dieses Modell übernommen, indem sie sozusagen über Spendenplattformen durch ihre Fans sich refinanzieren. Teilweise natürlich auch Werbung machen, aber dieses ganze Refinanzierungsmodell durch die Fans wird zunehmend dominanter und die YouTuber steigen zunehmend um, von diesen Werbedeals weg, hin zu meine Zuschauer finanzieren mich.
Das ist lustig, im Prinzip übernehmen sie das Podcasting-Modell.
Ja, total. Mit Zukunft schon vor 10 Jahren. 10.000-facher Reichweite von dir. Nichtsdestotrotz, ich finde das alles total legitim und kann auch andere Meinungen haben, aber ich wollte mal erklären, wie ich das hier...
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Quatsch machen würde, dann weiß ich auch, dass ich mehr Leute ansprechen würde.
Nee, es hat nichts mit Quatsch zu tun. Es geht um die Plattform, nicht um den Inhalt.
Ja, wieso? Ich meine, die ambitionierten YouTuber mit guten, ordentlichen Inhalten, die haben jetzt auch nicht die Reichweite.
Guck dir zum Beispiel mal, wie heißt das hier, den Kanal In a nutshell an. Das sind Münchner, die machen halt so kleine At-Leer-Videos und die haben irgendwie vier, fünf Millionen Abonnenten weltweit. Und jedes von deren Videos wird 20, 30 Millionen mal geschaut. Das ist der totale Erfolg. Und es gibt ganz viele tolle, auch seriöse Angebote, At-Leer-Angebote auf Facebook, auf YouTube, und nicht nur Quatsch-Content. Natürlich sind das keine fünf-stündigen Laber-Podcasts, aber es gibt auch sehr viele, sehr viele, sehr viele, aber auch der kann auf YouTube gut funktionieren. Selbst das würde ich sogar sagen.
Aber wie soll der auf YouTube funktionieren, wenn du auf YouTube noch nicht mal herunterladen kannst?
Du willst gar nicht runterladen. Du erstellst auf YouTube Playlisten, und junge Menschen haben das als Radio im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich finde, es kommt halt immer sehr auf den Content drauf an. Was ich über YouTube zum Beispiel mehr anschaue oder auch nur manchmal nebenbei höre, will ich gar nicht runterladen. Also Podcast ist halt definitiv was anderes. Und ich finde halt auch, so ein Podcast kann nicht unbedingt auf YouTube funktionieren. Ja, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Ich nutze YouTube halt echt gerade nur für ein bisschen Recherche, weil ich gerade Women in Computing so ein bisschen recherchiere und da gucke, ob es kurze, spannende Filmsequenzen einfach zu verschiedenen Frauen gibt, die einfach eine Menge geilen Scheiß gemacht haben in der Geschichte und um Sport zu machen. Ich mache halt jeden Tag Yoga und ich habe einen Yoga-Channel, den ich...
Ja, das ist ja auch alles Ordnung. Ich konsumiere ja auch Content auf YouTube.
Aber deswegen verstehe ich halt komplett, dass Tim da überhaupt nicht hin will, weil das komplett so...
Du hast ja auch ein Schlüsselwort gesagt, die lassen das im Hintergrund als Radio laufen. So viel zu diesen Abrufzahlen, die für mich einfach wattepur sind. Millionen Leute schauen sich das Video an. Fuck me! Wer denn? In Deutschland mit 80 Millionen Leuten, mit all diesen ganzen YouTubern, zähl mal all diese ganzen Zahlen mal zusammen. Das ist einfach Background-Noise. So viele Menschen gibt es überhaupt gar nicht. Und die haben auch nicht so viel Zeit. Nein, es läuft auf Computern ab.
Nein, es sind schon... Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es die... Aber unter anderem, wodurch ich mich auch gewundert habe, was passiert ist, wie können Kinder und Jugendliche so viel Zeit haben mit diesen Streams und Gaming? Und eines der Dinge ist eben, dass sie eben quasi so... Die haben meistens so einen Rechner, an dem sie ihre Hausaufgaben machen. Und im Hintergrund haben sie entweder ein iPad oder ein iPhone, wo sozusagen ihre YouTube-Playlist, meistens eine automatisierte, alle meine Abos, hintereinander und die laufen so wie ein Radio, so wie wir früher Radio gehört haben.
Das ist so wie Leute beim Abendessen in Fernseher laufen lassen. Da willst du mir noch nicht erzählen, dass sie noch irgendwas von mitkriegen.
Nein, ich meine, darüber kann man diskutieren. Das Radio begründet so Reichweite. Aber nicht alles wird davon gehört. Aber ich finde es auch nicht schlechter, als in ein Radio im Hintergrund zu laufen.
Ja gut, aber dadurch relativieren sich natürlich diese Zahlen auch enorm. Ich kann davon ausgehen, dass, ich würde ja auch niemals sagen, alle von mir gezählten Downloads, wobei die Zählmethode ja auch nochmal diskussionsfähig ist, sind jetzt eins zu eins in Menschen, die das komplett gehört haben, zu übersetzen. Ist es nicht. Was der Faktor ist, keine Ahnung. Ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal, weil für mich ja was ganz anderes zählt. Für mich zählt ja, wie viel Engagement und wie viel Wohlwollen kann ich erzeugen, die sozusagen zurückkommen. Wie gut kommt das an und dieses Feedback ist für mich einfach entscheidend, dass ich halt einfach Sachen mache, die für die Leute, die es erreicht, genau passen. Weil die Bindung zwischen Podcast-Hörern und Podcastern, kann es mir nicht erzählen, dass irgendein YouTuber da rankommt.
Und zwar massiv weiter. Nicht nur, dass sie da rankommen, sondern dass sie über Steigweiten, über Weiten, was du leistest, weil diese Plattformen inzwischen sogar optimiert darauf sind, diese Bindung nämlich herzustellen. Also es gibt ja jetzt diese ganzen neuen Features von YouTube Live. Also Live Streams auf YouTube ist ja nichts Neues.
Also ob du dasselbe Bindung meinst, bin ich gerade.
Und dort wird, während die Leute zocken, also eines der ganz großen Dinge ist ja dieses Gaming. Man denkt jetzt immer bei Gaming vor allen Dingen daran, dass es um das Spiel geht. Es geht aber nicht um das Spielen, sondern es geht um die Charakter und die Typen, so wie es bei euch jetzt auch in diesem Setting. Ihr seid ja sympathische Typen mit all euren Charakteren und man liebt euch in Anführungszeichen, weil ihr bestimmte Typen darstellt oder seid. Und man hasst oder liebt euch so. Und genauso hasst oder liebt man YouTuber. Und die zocken dann miteinander, teilweise auch Crossover über verschiedene Channels zusammen und unterhalten sich dabei. Und die unterhalten sich über exakt die gleichen Themen, wie ihr das hier tut. Nur, dass sie dabei zocken. Manchmal zocken sie noch nicht mal mehr. Manchmal kotzen sie nur noch und lassen irgendein Videospiel dabei ablaufen. Und unterhalten sich über, keine Ahnung, die Schule, Liebe, Politik, alles. Das ist total faszinierend. Und ich finde auch, dass das total sehr schätzt wird, was da an Kommunikationen abläuft. Das ist faszinierend. Und dann gibt es eben diese, da ist ja bei YouTube und auch bei Twitch, was übrigens fast noch inzwischen der wichtigere Kanal ist, wenn man über Livestreams spricht. Twitch ist gerade der größte Konkurrent für YouTube und meiner Meinung nach, wenn YouTube nicht aufpasst, wird Twitch sogar YouTube ablösen. Da ist sozusagen das Live-Feature und die ganzen Chats und die ganzen Dinge, die man dort in den Chats interagieren kann, sind extrem ausgebaut. Wenn wir hier unseren Slack-Kanal angucken, das ist sozusagen ein trauriges Abbild von dem, was auf YouTube... Und da sind nicht irgendwie 5 oder 10 Leute drin, sondern es sind hunderte Leute, die sich gleichzeitig unterhalten und das übrigens immer noch so, dass es was bringt für die Leute, die sich da unterhalten. Das ist super faszinierend. Ich behaupte noch nicht, dass... Ich bin sozusagen schon ein bisschen zu alt quasi, um das alles zu verstehen, aber ich habe zumindest gelernt, als sozusagen jemand, der sich mit dieser Kommunikation von diesen neuen Medien beschäftigt, dass ich da Respekt vorhabe und nicht diese manchmal sozusagen so eine Ablehnung des... Aber früher war alles besser sozusagen. Ich versuche erst mal zu verstehen, wie die das machen und wie die ihre Kommunikation machen. Und ich erkenne da überraschend oft, dass da sehr hochwertige Diskurse auch stattfinden können. Und das ist... Das würde ich gar nicht mal unterschätzen. Ihr könnt sofort einen Twitch-Kanal aufmachen mit der Freak Show. Der würde super laufen.
Ja, aber was sollten wir denn da streamen?
Nein, Dennis und ich fangen einfach an zu twitchen, wenn wir immer W-Talken.
Also, ähm...
Was jetzt, du meinst hier eine Kamera ins Studio?
Nein, das braucht kein Bild, das Bild ist egal. Das Gespräch, was wir hier haben...
Ja, aber wieso ist denn das auf Video?
Twitch, das Video ist fast egal bei diesen Livestreams. Es geht unbedingt um das Gespräch. Du glaubst doch nicht, dass die Kinder und Jugendlichen die ganze Zeit dazugucken, wenn die Leute zocken, die hören zu. Während sie ihre Hausaufgaben machen, während sie in der Küche kochen, während sie bügeln, während sie was weiß ich, was die Kinder und Jugendlichen heutzutage machen. Während sie sich Pornografie nebenbei angucken.
Aber unsere Sendung ist, glaube ich, eh nicht so für Jugendliche.
Pornografie, die man sich nicht anguckt?
Das ist nicht mehr meine Welt.
Nein, also das ist... Also da wird ganz viel gequatscht. Im Prinzip das gleiche, was ihr macht. Ihr habt einen super Content eigentlich für YouTube live, für Twitch live. Ihr nutzt es nicht aus. Das ist ein bisschen schade. Das ist eigentlich alles, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, ich meine, dass dieser Slack-Chat jetzt hier kein populäres Einfallstor ist, ist mir schon klar.
Das ist vor allem super komplex. Du gehst einfach auf YouTube auf den Kanal und sofort ist der Chat offen und ich kann sofort mitquatschen.
Ich kann da nicht mitquatschen, weil da müsste ich erstmal einen YouTube-Account anlegen. Deswegen hab ich nicht, deswegen geht das schon mal.
Also Kinder und Jugendliche haben alle unter 40 YouTube-Kanäle und haben einen Google-Account und können da mitmachen.
Ich hab auch einen YouTube-Kanal. Ich hab glaube ich sogar schon drei Videos veröffentlicht.
Nein, also...
Einen Kanal hab ich nicht, aber man hat ja einen Google-Account.
Ja eben, damit ist das fertig. Ich will jetzt nicht dich vom Gegenteil überzeugen.
Warum denn nicht?
Nein, weil...
Jetzt hab ich so Feigheit vor dem Feind hier.
Es gibt keine Wahrheit, es gibt einfach nur, es gibt das Potenzial.
Ich lass mich ja auch gerne überzeugen, wenn mal jemand Argumente bringt, die auch belastbar sind. Ja, das find ich ja auch gut. Deswegen hab ich dich ja auch eingeladen, verdammter Axt.
Hier sagen ja viele im Chat, dass wir so YouTube-Vorurteile hätten. Ich seh das ja nicht so, weil ich hab jetzt zwar keinen YouTube-Account, weil ich hab einfach keinen Bock auf Account, aber ich guck natürlich auch YouTube-Videos ohne Ende. Wenn wir von Videos reden, dann ist es ja meistens ein Video auf YouTube. Wir gucken ja YouTube-Videos, aber ich seh jetzt auch nicht, was unsere Sendung, ich sag jetzt mal unsere, war eigentlich dein Ding hier, aber was diese Sendung hier bei YouTube verloren hätte oder bei irgendeinem anderen Ding. Du hast diese Webseite, das funktioniert. Man kann da klicken, das ist nicht schwer. Und klar, könnte man bestimmt bei Facebook, YouTube oder sonst wo noch mehr Leute erreichen irgendwie. Aber ich glaube, wenn man ein gutes Format hat mit gutem Inhalt und wir haben ja schon ne Menge Leute, die zuhören, dann wenn das gut ist, verteilt sich das von alleine. Vielleicht dauert es ein bisschen länger, aber wir haben dann auch Qualitätshörer, die es auch wirklich hören wollen und nicht nur, weil sie bei YouTube mit den Seitenvorschlägen von uns genervt werden. Also einfach nur vorgeschlagen werden, sondern weil es halt ein realer Vorschlag war.
Den ich ja auch vorher schon machen wollte, ist sozusagen, dass mit den Versuchen, sich hinein zu besitzen, andere Lebenswelten. Das Ding ist doch, zum Beispiel, eines der Erfolgsmodelle wie Microsoft Office, wie der relevant wurde, ist, weil sie ein Deal gemacht haben mit Samsung, dass Microsoft Office vorinstalliert ist auf Samsung-Handys. Man könnte ja sagen, wenn die Leute Microsoft Office nutzen wollen, dann werden sie das doch wohl in den App-Store finden. Ist aber nicht so.
Dass man das ein bisschen entforcen kann, ist schon klar.
Die Apps, die vorinstalliert sind, werden genutzt. Das ist erstmal die Lebensrealität von diesen 80-90% von denen, von denen ich immer spreche. Wenn ihr die erreichen wollt, müsst ihr auf die Apps gehen, auf die Kanäle, auf die Plattform, die vorinstalliert sind. Da gehört YouTube dazu, Facebook dazu, etc. Android ist kein...
Android ist ja auch scheiße Dreck.
Das ist der Moment, wo ich gehen muss, oder?
Ist doch alles total ungesortiert. Aber ich meine, wie lange kündigt Google jetzt an, dass sie irgendwie Podcasts supporten wollen? Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, das zweite Jahr hintereinander. Ich warte noch drauf. Sollen sie einfach mal eine Podcast-App draufwerfen? Fertig ist die Nase. Sie hatten ja schon mal eine. Die war schlecht und dann haben sie sie wieder weggenommen. Das ist überhaupt das Problem mit diesem Laden, dass sie irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwas ankündigen und dann ein Jahr später machen sie was anderes.
Ja, da bin ich... Ich will nicht Google verteidigen.
Ja, aber den WeChat-Messenger... Du hast doch so richtig den Messenger. Letztes Jahr war das alo. Ich komme überhaupt nicht mehr mit, wie viele Produkte ich schon angekündigt habe.
Warum bin ich in dieser Rolle, Google verteidigen zu sollen?
Das will ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, ihr sollt die Kanäle bedienen, die erfolgreich sind und dazu gehört auch YouTube, dazu gehört Twitch, dazu gehört so, wenn man, also zumindest die Optionen gibt es.
Ja, die erfolgreich sind und die vorinstalliert sind. Kann man natürlich machen, dass man sagt, ok, Android-Telefone haben jetzt keine ordentliche Podcast-App vorinstalliert, deswegen muss ich jetzt das Podcast-Business einstellen, ist nicht so ganz mein Ansatz. So, und deswegen irgendwie gleich auf YouTube zu marschieren, heißt natürlich auch extra Arbeit, extra Kanal, neue Jurisdiktion, mit der du dich rumschlagen musst, mit Regeln, mit Stress, Kommentarkultur, musst du bedienen. Mir ist ja auch klar, dass wenn ich auf so einem Kanal rumhänge, dass ich nicht nur einfach rausposten muss. Deswegen war das mit dem Instagram nur so ein Seitenhieb, weil ich bin natürlich nicht Instagram, weil ich lese nicht Instagram, ich atme nicht Instagram, ich verstehe Instagram nicht, ich komme auch mit Fotos generell nicht klar, ich habe da nichts zu suchen. Das ist für mich einfach nur ehrlich. Twitter passt bei mir wie Arsch auf einmal, deswegen bin ich da von Anfang an dabei und bin da auch immer noch, auch wenn ich diesen Laden hasse. Und Facebook, sorry, Komplexität, ich sehe das irgendwie, sie haben irgendwie Mail und diese ganzen anderen Internetkatastrophen ordentlich gekapselt, aber leider das Ding ist in sich eine Komplexität, wo ich jedes Mal wieder davor stehe, wie ein Pferd vom Schontor und irgendwie keine Ahnung habe, was Sache ist, nicht weil ich blöd bin, sondern weil ich wahrscheinlich doch blöd bin.
Nein, also sagen wir erst mal so, wenn du das angehen willst, das Thema, dann musst du natürlich ein bisschen out of the box denken und mal ein bisschen auf deinen kleinen Dimensionen, deines Single-Daseins als Unternehmer sozusagen. Ein YouTuber, der in gewisser Weise in diese Größen vorstößt, der versteht sich als Unternehmer und hat natürlich auch Mitarbeiter. Das heißt sozusagen, das geht los mit, der stellt sich einen Cutter ein, dann fängt er irgendwann an, einen Community-Manager zu haben und so weiter. Dann entwickelt es sich und es gibt YouTuber, die haben 10, 20 Mitarbeiter und haben halt natürlich, die haben dann eben diese berühmberechtigten Werbeeinnahmen, die du dir auch aus ideologischen Gründen, was ich sehr sympathisch finde, verweigerst und so weiter. Aber man kann das als Unternehmen begreifen. Content-Produktion ist eigentlich immer schon, deswegen gibt es ja Zeitungen, deswegen bezahlt man sie, ist eigentlich immer eine unternehmerische Tätigkeit. Du kommst ja eher aus, historisch gesehen, als sozusagen, ich mach das halt nebenbei als Hobby. Und die YouTuber haben dann aber dadurch, dass sie relativ schnell mit Geld zugeschüttet wurden, verstanden, dass sie sozusagen, oh, das gibt mir ja Geld. Und dann hat sozusagen das Einstellen von Menschen, die dann deinem helfen, die eben sozusagen entweder zum Beispiel Community-Management machen oder die Sendung, dieses ganze Verteilen und die verschiedenen Kanäle, ist wirklich Arbeit. Ich meine, das ist mein Beruf. Das ist genau das, was ich für meine Kunden mache. Jetzt zwar im politischen Bereich, aber dieses verdammte Einstellen, alle möglichen Kanälen, alle Kanäle...
Aber vielleicht ist es ja genau das, was man nicht will, dass es sich am Ende anfühlt wie Arbeit. Wenn du 20 angestellt hast, ich denke mal, das, was du machst, ist ja schon dein Job. Du hast ja gesagt, du hast das zu deinem Beruf gemacht oder irgendwie so, ne? Aber wahrscheinlich fühlt es sich nicht so richtig wie Arbeit an, oder?
Also wenn es anfängt, sich wie Arbeit anzufühlt, dann bist du ganz schnell weg.
Nein, nein, nein, aber das ist ja die Sache. Komm mal, deswegen versuche ich auch mehrfach zu betonen, dass alles, so wie er das macht, genau so richtig ist und ich ihm überhaupt nichts auflabern will. Nur eben, er hat mich gefragt, was wäre denn, was gibt es denn für Chancen, was wären da für Möglichkeiten? Und ich sage...
Möglichkeiten, das ist schon klar.
Er hat halt genialen Content eigentlich, ne? Danach lächzen sich die Leute, deswegen schicken sie mir diese ganzen E-Mails. Weil der Content eigentlich voll genial ist und weil die sich freuen würden, seinen Content zu vermarkten. Also ich würde Tim sofort einen Deal bieten für x 1000 Euro und sagen, ich vermarkte deinen Content und ich kriege dafür die Gewinne. Und sofort gebe ich ihm, meine Ahnung, x, y 1000 Euro und Tim gibt mir den Content. Und ich verteile das auf die Kanäle, kassiere die Gelder und ich verdiene mehr als Tim am Ende. Ich mache einen Mehrwert. Weil ich sozusagen dann diese... So, und das ist das, was die Plattform...
Aber kannst du dann nicht auch Zweitvermarkter werden?
Nicht, wenn Tim mir nicht die Rechte einräumt. Das ist ja das, weswegen er es ablehnt, auf gewisse Plattformen zu gehen.
Aber du brauchst doch keine Exklusivrechte.
Nein, er ist ja ein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Produkt. Er darf ja nichts anfangen, außer er gibt mir die Rechte.
Ja, aber du brauchst sie ja nicht exklusiv. Das heißt, Tim könnte das ja so weitermachen, wie er das gerade macht.
Er soll, oh Gott, das will er. Er soll doch seinen Podcast nicht einstellen. Ich sag nur, genau. Aber noch mehr Gewinn macht er natürlich, wenn er das selbst alles vermarktet und wenn er einfach nur Leute einstellt.
Probier das doch mal ein Jahr.
Jetzt, liebe Hörer, würdet ihr gerne, würde ich gerne euch das Gesicht zeigen von Tim. Das sieht so aus, als wäre gerade seine Mutter vom Auto überfahren worden.
Ich fand das, ehrlich gesagt, fand ich Tims Gesicht vorhin bei der gesamten Diskussion über das Bildungswesen noch schlimmer. Der hat dann noch verzweifelter geguckt, muss man mal dazu sagen.
Aber er ist schon recht, also so. Ich würde mindestens sagen, so.
Was ihr jetzt alle reininterpretiert, ist mal gut, dass es hier keinen Videostream gibt. Also, es ist nicht so, dass ich mir nicht auch die ganze Zeit Gedanken darüber mache. Also ich bin jetzt nicht auf so einer Position von, das haben wir ja noch nie gemacht, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Und wir müssen ja ewig die 90er-Jahre feiern, weil früher war ja alles besser. Das ist eh nicht mein Film. So, andererseits erwarte ich natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr, als dass ich mich gleich auf jedes Pferd schwinge, was mal eben vorbei galoppiert kommt, weil das halt auch potenziell so auch Nachteile haben kann. Die sehe ich halt auch. Da gibt es Dinge, die ich etwas anders gewichte als vielleicht andere Leute, was auch damit zu tun hat, dass bei mir Quantität alleine halt keinen Wert darstellt. Ja, also ich habe sehr viel mehr davon in einem qualitativen Verhältnis zu der Hörerschaft zu stehen als in einem quantitativen Verhältnis. Für mich wird das nicht alles besser dadurch, dass mich mehr Leute hören, sondern das muss auch ein gutes Hören sein. Und ich finde auch, dass diese nicht sehr niedrigschwellige Geschichte zum Podcast zu kommen hat auch was für sich, weil Leute, die auf diesem Weg einsteigen, in der Regel aber auch länger hängen bleiben. Also oder überhaupt auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise hängen bleiben. Das könnte ich jetzt noch weiter ausführen. Ich glaube, jeder, der in dieser Situation ist, wird in etwa wissen, was ich meine. Ich habe da schon so viele Stories in dieser Richtung gehört und das ist irgendwie ein gutes Verhältnis. Während wenn man so auf so marktschreierischen Plattformen ist, wie YouTube Nummer 1 ist, wo du so reingedängelt wirst und dann landest du auf irgendwelchen Regumenten, eine Homepage, Leute klicken drauf, hören sich das 20 Minuten an, dann kriegst du dann wieder gleich so einen Kommentar um die Ohren gespissen, so überhaupt kein, der ganze Kontext, die Geschichte, alles ist irgendwie nicht klar. Das sind alles schon mal so Aspekte, die mich ein bisschen...
Und vor allem, wenn erst mal das Werbevideo vorne am Anfang kommen würde, ich glaube, dann hätten wir auch schon eine Menge höher verloren, weil ich glaube, die finden das gut, dass bei uns das nicht...
Keine Matratzen, keine Webseiten.
Wie gesagt, alles legitim und man kann sich für einen der zwei Wege entscheiden. Du hast eine Entscheidung gemacht und ich finde die total gut und ich persönlich als Hörer profitiere ja auch davon, dass es eben so ist und nicht anders. Aber eben wenn man gerade... Ich meine, ob jetzt die Freak Show eine große Reichweite hat oder nicht, ist dahingestellt. Bei anderen Formaten von Tim finde ich es manchmal schade, weil ich mir denke irgendwie verdammt nochmal, diesen Podcast muss eigentlich jeder Mensch in Deutschland hören, sonst können wir unsere Netzpolitik mal verändern. Oder Forschergeist ist auch ein toller, ne?
Ich habe genau das Gefühl, dass es halt nur als Podcast funktioniert. Also du kannst halt nicht unterwegs in der U-Bahn YouTube machen. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es mit Spotify ist, das habe ich nicht. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass du halt auch in einer Berliner U-Bahn, wo du nur Edge heißt, halt auch keinen Spotify machen kannst. Aber mit einem Podcatcher, mit einem Normalen, der dir den Kram runterlädt, der lokal auf deinem Device liegt, den du anhören kannst, wann du willst. Weil er einfach da ist, ist das halt was ganz anderes, den du jederzeit unterbrechen kannst, dann kannst du was anderes hören.
Das ist der eine Vorteil tatsächlich, den sozusagen Podcast auf jeden Fall hat, als einen Kanal. Aber ich habe ja noch nicht mal nur von YouTube gesprochen oder von Twitch, sondern ich spreche davon, grundsätzlich alle Kanäle zu bespielen. Und ich würde auch Tim insgesamt mehr als Personality branden und sozusagen ihn insgesamt als Person nach vorne stellen, was er ja auch nicht so richtig tut und dann noch sehr verlegen tut sozusagen. Was würde denn das bedeuten? Na, das bedeutet, dass du dich stärker inszenierst, dass du sozusagen in Erscheinung trittst, auch auf anderen Kanälen noch verstärkt, dass du versuchst nicht nur mal auf eine Radioanfrage zu antworten, wenn irgendjemand mal wieder ein Interview haben will zum Thema Podcast, sondern dass du dich auch anbietest gegenüber den Medien, dass du vielleicht einen Medienberater hast, der dich platziert in bestimmten Sendungsformaten, dass du sozusagen Talks gibst, dass du versuchst dich insgesamt insgesamt zu promoten und sozusagen nach vorne zu bringen.
Und wer macht dann unsere Sendung?
Na er, weiterhin. Dann müsste er natürlich, das ist schon... Wir brauchen von Tim all das. Aber guck mal, Tim beschäftigt sich ja mit 60% oder 80% seiner Zeit, damit sein IT-Setup hier zu machen. Weißt du, für sowas hätte normalerweise alle Menschen, die irgendwie ökonomisch denken, würden sagen, ich stelle mir halt einen Typen ein, der mir mein Setup baut und meine Qualität, das Unique Sending Point, ist das Radio machen, das Sprechen, das Erklären, ja? Und er muss doch nicht sein eigenes Studio einrichten und so weiter und so weiter. Also warum macht er all das? Es ist alles Liebe, es ist alles Hobby und das finde ich...
Nein, das ist Forschung!
Auch Forschung und bietet dir auch Mehrwert, weil du da immer schön drüber berichtest. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es eben ökonomisch gesehen, nimmst du dir die Zeit, um sozusagen deine Hauptstärken davon zu haben.
Also ich wünschte, ich könnte da so viel Zeit reinstecken, dass das wirklich ein Problem wäre. Dem ist halt nicht so. Hier habe ich mehr Stabilität in diesem Setup, als es mir selber lieb ist.
Auf dem glaube ich auch, wenn man hier sich das machen lassen würde. Das wäre vielleicht erstmal ganz toll und vielleicht funktioniert es dann auch eine Weile, aber es würde auch nur davon sorgen, dass man sich von der eigentlichen Technik immer weiter entfernt. Vielleicht geht es der ersten ein, zwei Jahre gut, aber irgendwann ist man dann so raus, dass man sagt, ja keine Ahnung, mach das wieder geht. Und wahrscheinlich will man da gar nicht hinkommen. Du willst schon deinen Shit da irgendwie selber irgendwie haben und du bringst das ja auch vorwärts, oder ist ja dein Setup, also da passiert ja auch was. Und an deiner Software und Podcast, wie du das alles verbreitest, da passiert ja auch was. Das ist ja nicht fertig, sondern das ist ja andauernd in einer ewigen Weiterentwicklung, oder nicht? Also du musst ja schon sagen, Tim ist auch halt ein bisschen Control-Freak, oder?
Man kann sich ja amerikanische Podcaste anschauen, die eben anders denken, die sich inzwischen ein ganzes Podcast-Netzwerk aufgebaut haben mit 15 Co-Moderatoren, mit verschiedenen... Also in gewisser Weise ist die Metaebene das ja auch, nur du behältst die ganze After-Produktion und sozusagen die Medien-Weiterverwertung alles noch in deiner Hand. Und du bist jemand, der, so wie ich übrigens auch, sehr stark versucht, selber alles zu machen und hast eventuell Schwierigkeiten, Kontrolle abzugeben und dich auf andere zu verlassen. Das weiß ich nicht, ob das auch noch mit deinem Charakter zu tun hat, vielleicht hast du eine negative Kindheitserfahrung gemacht. Aber das weiß ich nicht.
Hätte ich eher negative Erwachsenenerfahrung. Und auch dieses Ganze sich irgendwie rumreichen lassen und so weiter in Medien. Ich hab schon vor so vielen Kameras gesteckt. Ich bin über Messen getingelt. Ich hab irgendwie Leuten gequatscht. Ich war irgendwie bei NTV und Pipapo und all diesen ganzen Kanälen. Und es ist so ein dummes Quatsche da draußen. Und es macht mich fertig. Also es ist auch so ein... Ich muss sagen, gehört auch so ein bisschen zur Lebensqualität, sowas nicht zu machen. Das ist so ein Stück weit, kann man das machen. Und da bist du ja dann sozusagen aus den Nullerjahren und so. Und noch sozusagen... Da schmerzt das noch nicht ganz so. Aber der Schmerz wird größer, das kann ich dir sagen. Also man erträgt irgendwann auch vieles nicht mehr. Und das ist dann sozusagen auch Teil der Lebensqualität, das nicht zu machen. Oder Dinge halt auch selber zu machen. Weil es natürlich für mich auch... Ich bin jetzt 50, bin jetzt nicht alt, bin jetzt nicht jung, bin irgendwie so dazwischen oder so. Keine Ahnung, was ich bin. Ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall nicht unbedingt so wie das, was normalerweise 50 so zugeschrieben wird. Und ich will zumindest so halbwegs, soweit es möglich ist, auch einerseits erstmal Top of the Game sein. Ich will irgendwie genau wissen, was ich tue. Warum ich es auch mache. Wenn ich so lange es noch argumentieren kann, finde ich es okay. Wenn ich an allem zweifle, dann kann ich es ja auch wieder ändern. Und das Lernen ist auch wichtig. Also ich hab nicht viel Spaß an einer Tätigkeit, in der ich nicht was lerne. Also wenn das Lernen aufhört, ist es für mich uninteressant. Dann mach ich was anderes oder gar nichts. Aber nur so was betreiben, um Geld zu erzeugen, ist für mich kein Wert. Das ist dieses reine Bemessen an, ich kann ja mehr Geld verdienen. Ja klar kann ich mehr Geld verdienen, aber was mach ich denn? Was mach ich dann in dieser Situation, in der ich in so einem Hamsterrad von oh Gott, jetzt beschäftige ich Leute, jetzt muss ich mein Business developpen, damit ich irgendwie mehr Aufträge habe, damit dann diese Leute usw. auch noch mit ernährt werden. Und man muss sich die ganze Zeit mit diesem Sozialsystem rumschlagen und du hast dann auf einmal Montag bis Freitag und machst, führst einfach dieses 9 to 5 Leben, was ich einfach, ok, ich akzeptiere, dass Leute damit klarkommen, aber es ist nicht für mich.
Ich kann dich vollkommen verstehen. Zum einen hab ich mal einen guten Kumpel gehabt, der auch ein sehr toller Politikberater ist, den hab ich auch mal gefragt, warum willst du denn nicht mal jemanden einschalten? Er hat mehr als 30 Mitarbeiter in seiner Beratungszimmer und meinte, plötzlich ändert sich deine Rolle. Du bist dann eben nicht mehr derjenige, der wirklich rausgeht und die Leute berät, sondern du bist plötzlich der Chef. Du musst dich plötzlich um die Sorgen machen, wenn der nicht der nächste große Auftrag reinkommt, musst du X, Y und Z entlassen und musst dessen Frau irgendwie und dessen Kinder musst du dir Sorgen machen. Du hast plötzlich ganz viele Sorgen, die du vorher nicht hattest. Das, was dir Spaß gemacht hat, ist eigentlich dann weg. Du hast plötzlich mehr so eine Art Management-Rolle und bist gar nicht mehr so der Creative Person. Deswegen ist das eine total legitime Position. Nur du, ich kann es nicht nochmal zu verteidigen, hast gefragt, was könnte man tun? Das wäre die Perspektive. Und da gibt es auch gute Gründe, das nicht zu tun.
Ich baue ja gerade diesen 8-Bit-Computer von diesem Ben Iter, der auch bei YouTube das so vorführt, 30 Videos. Und dann fragen auch Leute, warum machst du das eigentlich? Und dann sag ich immer, aus Spaß. Und dann fragen die mal, ja, aber irgendwie gar nicht, irgendwie was zu lernen oder für einen Job oder irgendwie so. Also warum brauchst du dann den Computer? Ich sag, nee, ich brauch den nicht, ich mach das aus Spaß. Und das verstehen viele nicht. Und ich kann das wiederum nicht verstehen. Also ich meine, was machen die dann in ihrer Freizeit? Sachen, die ihnen keinen Spaß machen oder was?
Das sind die anderen, Dennis. Und die gibt es halt auch.
Aber die machen doch auch... Also gibt's Leute, die machen Kreuzwort-Rätsel, das ist auch Rätsellösen. Ich löse halt Rätsel beim Computerbauen, weil da musst du auch Rätsel lösen, halt andere Rätsel. Aber am Ende ist alles Rätsellösen.
Ich bin mir nicht so richtig so sicher, ob das mit dem Kreuzwort-Rätsel wirklich mit Spaß zu tun hat.
Das ist Beschäftigungstherapie.
Ja, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es eine gewisse Genugtuung ist, dass man die entwickelt, wenn man so einen Kreuzwort-Rätsel gelöst hat. Also ich mein, das kann ja auch anspruchsvoll sein, da die Dinger rauszupfen.
Es bleibt aber immer das Gleiche.
Ja, wenn du erstmal alle Flüsse in Italien kennst.
Natürlich ist es immer das Gleiche. Wir hatten vorhin die Diskussion um Spiele und gewisse Spiele sind für mich nichts, weil ab einem bestimmten Punkt sind sie immer das Gleiche. Wahrscheinlich fände ich World of Warcraft nach mehreren Stunden langweilig.
Aber zum Beispiel bei dem Thema Kreuzwort-Rätsel, also man war ja früher auch kreativ in der Schule, wenn uns langweilig war, hat man sich halt gegenseitig irgendwelche Rätsel geschrieben. Also Kreuzwort-Rätsel waren in der Tat eher so a thing in der Schule, wenn es langweilig war.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt ja keinen Wettbewerb zwischen sozusagen einem Privatleben und einem ökonomischen Leben. Und man braucht beides.
Ja, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich genau der Punkt, dass das, was Tim hier macht, ist halt eben beides so ein bisschen und aus Tims Sicht wahrscheinlich doch noch mehr privat als halt Business. Du siehst das glaube ich ganz krass von Business-Seite und deine Tipps wären bestimmt auch alle total super, wenn er jetzt hier so voll hinter der Kohle hinterher wäre oder hinter... also am Ende geht es ja um Geld, also Verbreitung und mehr Hörer und so weiter. Außer wir hätten jetzt hier den pädagogischen Anspruch.
Ja, auf der einen Seite schon, auf der anderen Seite nicht nur. Also ich finde halt auch tatsächlich, wenn ich sendungsbewusst bin, will ich natürlich auch möglichst viele Menschen erreichen und mich dann sozusagen selbst zu kastrieren, indem ich nur auf sozusagen einen Kanal setze.
Aber auf Biegen und Brechen, meinst du nicht, die kommen von alleine?
Ja, also ich bin sogar der Ansicht, du hast recht, guter Content zieht die Lese an, egal auf welchen Kanal du ihn anbietest. Auf der anderen Seite ist das deshalb problematisch, weil sozusagen, wenn du jetzt argumentatisieren würdest, Twitch oder YouTube, würde ich sagen, dann ist es dir egal, weil dann sozusagen, da finden die Leute dich schon. Aber wenn du auf einem Kanal bist, der sozusagen von so einer kleinen Zielgruppe nur erreicht wird, dann ist es halt so ein bisschen, als würdest du dich absichtlich verstecken und den Zugang zu dir erschweren. Also das ist halt jetzt aber auch einfach nur, das kann man sozusagen aus dieser ideologischen, man kann das aus dieser privaten Sicht sehen. Also da würde ich einfach argumentieren, wenn ich sozusagen richtig meine Botschaft rauskriegen will, würde ich versuchen, auch auf allen Plattformen zu tun. Als Journalist will ich ja, dass ich überall gelesen werden kann und nicht nur auf einer Website, sondern eben auch irgendwie auf Facebook und ich möchte auch auf Twitter sein und ich möchte auch auf Instagram sein und ich möchte eben alle Plattformen bespielen mit meinem Content und muss mich eben anpassen. Aber wenn man natürlich sagt, ich mach das hier als Hobby und es ist mir gar nicht so wichtig, dass ich sozusagen alle erreiche und kommerzielle Ziele habe ich auch nicht, dann ist es auch total legitim. Ich wollte nur sagen, es gibt eben diese ökonomische Perspektive, ist genauso legitim wie eine private Perspektive und ich finde, die stehen sich gegeneinander oder so, sondern jeder hat seine totale Berechtigung und man muss nicht irgendwie das Ausschlachten bis zum Gettner und sowas, was ich kann. Ich finde es auch alles so schön, wie es ist, aber es wäre halt noch potenzial nach oben.
Man, jetzt ist ja schon so spät und wir haben immer noch nicht über Buchhaltung geredet.
Darf ich da kurz was einwerfen? Weil wir hatten die sechsstündige Abi-Prüfung ja gerade. Tim, es würde dich ja freuen in meiner, weiß ich wie viel stündigen, wahrscheinlich auch sechsstündigen Abi-Prüfung, hatte ich auch Buchhaltung.
Na du bist ja eh ein Buchhaltungsbrot, das haben wir doch schon gehört aus dem Autohaus und so.
Na scheiße, das weiß der immer noch.
Na ja, das war sogar schon mein Sendungstitel.
Das hat ein bisschen...
Ich kann übrigens noch mal mir damals durch den Kopf vergehen, was du gesagt hast, das ist sozusagen so dieses, wenn du Buchhalt hältst, also wenn du diese Zuordnung machst, dass das so was wie so eine Mantra-ähnliche Erfahrung ist, dass du da so sitzt und einfach so vor dich hin so Dinge abarbeitest und dass das so eine schöne, entspannte Wirkung, das kann ich total bestätigen, weil das so befriedigend ist, Dinge einfach so wie ein Puzzle lösen. Ja, ein Kreuzworträtsel wahrscheinlich. Das ist halt so dieses, ha ja, ich mache etwas fertig, ich so ein Kunstwerk malen oder so. Es ist so dieses, man ist in sich und man kann diese Beteiligung...
Ordnung in etwas bringen. Wo vorher Chaos war, macht man für sich eine Ordnung.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr entberuhigend.
Wir hatten das Thema auch schon mal, als du wieder über Interhemd und Versand von zum Beispiel Merchandise geredet hast. Ich glaub, ich fänd's auch einfach geil, mal so einen Tag lang irgendwelche Bestellungen zusammenzupacken und schön so eine Sache vom einen Stapel zum nächsten Stapel zu räumen. Ich glaub, da würd ich mal so einen Tag lang echt denken, geil.
Mein Schlafzimmer war schon mal für zwei, drei Jahre ein T-Shirt-Lager. Das hab ich jetzt auch schon durch irgendwie.
In der Hausnummer 23.
Hausnummer 23. Ja, aber können wir trotzdem noch mal kurz das Steuerthema ansprechen?
Welches? Der Steuer oder das Buchhaltungs?
Alles! Was hat du denn hier noch?
Na, ich könnte erzählen, wie ich Buchhalte mache. Also du und Tim, ihr hättet da auf jeden Fall eine sehr gute Grundlage. Tim, wollen wir einen Podcast aufmachen? Ich höre nicht nerven.
Ja, nimmst euch mal eine eigene Sendung.
Get a Podcast, you two!
Was ich erzählen will, was ich sehr befriedigend finde, ist, Software einzusetzen, um Buchhaltung zu machen. Ich bin Fan von Cloud-Software, du hast ja mehr den lokalen Ansatz. Und es macht mir einfach total Freude, weil das Schöne an dieser Cloud-Software-Lösung für Buchhaltung ist, dass alles in der Wolke bleibt. Und ich hab quasi eine Software, die heißt Get My Invoices, kann ich sehr empfehlen, die sammelt von allen verschiedenen, also von O2 sammelt sie meine Rechnung ein, direkt sozusagen aus dem O2-Portal.
Das heißt, du gibst denen deine Zugangs... Das ist ja wie... Das ist ja wie sofort überweisen.
Ja, das ist sofort überweisen.
Du bist raus.
Ich bin raus. Also ich habe allen Passwörter gegeben, so einmal get all, und dann also get my invoices, sammelt sozusagen auf allen Portalen im Internet meine...
Ich finde, das müsste, man müsste das verbieten.
Meine Rechnung ein? Soll ich noch zu Ende reden oder?
Jetzt lass ich noch mal erzählen, das ist interessant.
Für manchen. Und unter anderem auch meine Amazon-Rechnung und meine Facebook-Rechnung und so weiter. Was echt super spannend ist, weil ich irgendwie im Monat halt 50 Facebook-Rechnungen hab sozusagen.
Wie hat man denn Facebook-Rechnungen?
Weil ich halt das beruflich mache.
Weil du Werbung schaltest?
Weil ich Werbung schalte und die machen ganz schreckliche, die schicken dir Einzelrechnungen und das ist ätzend und du willst das automatisieren sozusagen.
Du meinst, Facebook hat auch seine Buchhaltung nicht im Griff?
Facebook hatte einiges nicht im Griff.
Amerikanische Unternehmen sind mit Rechnungsschreiben ganz furchtbar.
Und du willst das nicht manuell runterladen und dann wieder irgendwie ein... Also sammelt, get my invoice, ist alle meine Rechnung ein und schickt das dann zu Cevdes, das ist meine Online-Buchhaltung, wo sie sozusagen alle reingespült werden, meine Rechnung. Und dann wird es von der Cevdes, hat so eine automatische Erkennung und erkennt sozusagen, macht so eine Art Scan des Dokuments und erkennt, wer ist der Absender, also welcher Lieferant bei mir ist das, wie ist die Rechnungssumme, wie viel ist der Mehrwertsteueranteil. Und ich muss dann nur noch einmal drüber gucken und bestätigen sozusagen. Das reduziert die Arbeit, die ich hab sozusagen ganz massiv. Also das ist eine sehr schöne Lösung. Und da gibt es jetzt auch tausend andere Anbieter. Es muss nicht der sein, aber es hat eine unglaublich schönere innere Logik, sozusagen alles in der Wolke zu lassen, ohne dass man diesen Prozess hat. Ich muss erst die Rechnungen downloaden und dann muss ich sie wieder irgendwo hinladen. Achso, und das schöne Ende ist auch noch, dass dieses SEV-Desk für mich dann auch noch gleich die Umsatzsteuer-Voranmeldung macht. Das heißt, nachdem ich alle meine Einnahmen und Ausgaben dort erfasst habe, macht die Software dann auch gleich noch am Monatsende die Meldung ans Finanzamt direkt aus der Software. Das ist das, was du jetzt abführen musst. Und das ist so einmal die Gesamtlösung. Aber ja, es läuft alles in der Cloud und ich bin verdammt, falls irgendwann mal jemand da ist.
Aber ich meine, wenn du so viel Business-Zeugs machst, will man dann nicht jeden Steuerberater haben?
Hab ich so zusätzlich noch, musst du auch haben.
Aber du sammelst das schon mal vor, dass du das dann nur noch so rüberleicht kannst?
Genau, der Steuerberater liegt am Ende des Jahres. Na, okay, muss man nicht haben, wenn man...
Macht aber Sinn.
Macht Sinn, wenn du auch gewisse Rechtssicherheit haben willst.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Also im Sinne von, du willst nicht einen banalen Fehler dazu führen, dass du einen Strafprozess vom Finanzamt hast, sondern du möchtest, dass der Steuerberater die Fehler macht, für die du dann trotzdem haften musst. Richtig, das ist wahr, aber du hoffst natürlich...
Aber die Chance ist, dass er weniger Fehler macht.
Dass er weniger Fehler macht als du und Marc.
Und dass du noch vor Gericht wenigstens sagen kannst, dass es nicht dein eigener war, wenigstens für das eigene Gewissen.
Hilft nichts.
Ich weiß, aber...
Aber das fand ich einfach so eine Gesamtschönheitslösung für mich. Aber klar, wenn man...
Also, das ist natürlich ganz interessant. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt sozusagen, dadurch, dass ich jetzt mal so Buchhaltung so ein bisschen verinnerlicht habe und mittlerweile bin ich auch an so einem Punkt, wo ich irgendwie alle Features meines Programms kann und jetzt wird's schon wieder langweilig. Das ist total ätzend. Schlimmer noch, wenn man stößt... Ausgespielt. Man stößt sozusagen die ganze Zeit auf Limitierungen und Begrenzung und so. Und das ist eigentlich insofern auch ein ganz interessanter Run, als das hier mal wieder auf eine ganz neue Art und Weise auch so dieses Cloud versus Desktop-Apps ausgespielt wird. Man muss ja sagen, dass diese ganze Desktop-App-Programmierung doch verhältnismäßig schwierig zu sein scheint. Wenn man sich so die Qualität der User-Interfaces anschaut, da sind also teilweise Webseiten schon weiter durch Vereinfachung, durch klarere Modularisierungen, natürlich weil sie es halt auch einfacher umstellen können, etc. Du hast natürlich auch Nachteile. Es gibt bestimmte Dinge, die gehen nicht so gut. Das ist immer so tit for tat. Aber im Prinzip ist es ein offenes Rennen. Und gerade jetzt so bei Buchhaltung, wenn man jetzt mal grob das Feature-Set jetzt hier anschaut von ZEVTES, was du erwähnt hast, es mag, glaube ich, noch ein paar Programme geben, die zumindest unter Windows das ähnlich machen. Also zum Beispiel dieses Belege mit reinwerfen scheint noch ein echtes Problem zu sein. Also die klassischen Buchhaltungsprogramme, die können irgendwie ganz ordentlich buchen. Aber so dieses Konzept mit der Beleg ist dabei, was man ja eigentlich echt will, weil Wichtig und Bezug und so ist da überhaupt nicht mit drin. Und derzeit habe ich das zum Beispiel so auf meinem manuellen lokalen System alles separat und getrennt. Und klar, gehört natürlich jetzt so ein gewisses Vertrauen rein. Was ist, wenn die Bude sich morgen irgendwie ihren Datenbestand weggrubelt?
Naja, dann bin ich der, der das kleinste Problem hat. Die anderen Firmen sind größer und wichtiger.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht ganz unproblematisch, wenn das sozusagen dein einziger Storage ist oder da, wo sich alles sammelt, ne?
Ja, da gehe ich halt davon aus, dass die wissen, dass die ihre 20.000, 40.000 Kunden, die sie haben, dass die nicht nur, dass die Firma dann im Ruin ist, sondern dass sie sozusagen sich für den Rest ihres Lebens nirgendwo... Also die haben alles doppelt und dreifach abgesichert. Also das sichern sie auch zu. Sie sichern über das eben... Einer fragt dir gerade im Chat, warum muss alles in der Cloud sein? Einer der großen Vorteile bei der Buchhaltung ist ja, dass du eben das auch alles noch finanziell für die nächsten zehn Jahre archivieren musst, damit das Finanzamt immer darauf zugreifen kann. Und es ist halt eben...
Da kann man ja nicht davon ausgehen, dass dieses Unternehmen noch zehn Jahre lebt.
Doch. Also die sagen sogar, wenn sie pleite gehen, dass sie sozusagen trotzdem die sichere Vorhaltung dafür bezahlst. Genau für diesen Service. Das sichern sie.
Das sagen sie.
Ja gut.
Wenn die pleite sind, gibt es die nicht mehr.
Im Zweifelsfall, also die haben auch jetzt schon einen Download-All-You-Export. Also das ist ja das, worauf es ankommt.
Genau, das ist wichtig. Und das wiederum bei Buchhaltung muss man sagen, lässt sich verhältnismäßig gut formalisieren. Da gibt es irgendwie ein paar abgehangene Datenformate, die nicht alle unproblematisch sind, aber zumindest so kann man halt sagen, Chris ist irgendwie in Dativ rein und das müsste eigentlich alle gelesen bekommen.
Mein Misstrauen ist sozusagen mein eigener PC. Ich bin zwar schon ein erfahrener Nutzer und benutze schon ein Mac, was ja halbwegs sicheres System ist und so weiter. Aber ja, keine Ahnung, wie mache ich wirklich sichere, also mit einem Rechner kann man einfach keine sichere Verwahrung über zehn Jahre machen, das geht einfach nicht. Dann kann man externe Festplatten nutzen, dann muss man aber eigentlich auch mindestens zwei haben, dann muss man blablabla, das irgendwie vorreitig halten, dann muss das nicht alles in einer Wohnung liegen, denn wenn da jemand einbricht, dann ist ja auch alles weg.
Dann machst du halt ein Cloud-Backup.
Ja, gut, dann ist es aber dann die Frage, wo ist der Vorwurf gegenüber netCloud-Buchhaltungssystem? Wenn du eh dein Backup in netCloud machst, dann hast du ja genauso verloren wie ich, wenn jemand sich in meine Cloud einbricht. Das ist dann ja am Ende.
Nee, weil du ja lokal verschlüsselst, bevor du es hinschickst.
Es gibt jetzt ja die Firma nicht mehr da, die das Cloud macht.
Das Problem ist aber auch mit deinem Cloud-Anbieter für deinen Online-Storage. Also ich persönlich bin da halt so großer... Also mir macht es halt Spaß, weil ich mich eben nicht mehr lokal um meine Sicherheit kümmern, also nicht mehr so stark kümmern muss, weil ich nicht mehr so viel Angst hab. Und ich sozusagen das Gefühl habe, dass so ein Anbieter, der sich nur mit diesem ein Problem beschäftigt, das besser kann als ich, der irgendwie mit meinem Rechner noch Computer spiele, erotische Filme anschaue und sonstige Dinge mache.
Der Attacker kann ja auf den Anbieter, der 100.000 User hat, da kriegt er ja 100.000 Daten und nicht nur die von dir. Das heißt, die müssten ja, wenn man das mal umrechnet, 100.000 mal sicherer sein als du und das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber kann man denn in dieser Online-Buchhaltung auch so richtig buchen?
Das ist übrigens das Allerschönste. Du gibst eben nicht nur ein Buchungskonto 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, sondern du schreibst einfach Benzin und er weiß, was der richtige Konto ist.
Ja, aber kann ich auch einfach...
Du kannst auch einfach hart auf Konten buchen. Du kannst sogar eigene Konten anlegen. Ich will hart buchen. Die haben natürlich dann auch so schöne Features wie zum Beispiel bei der... Wie sagt man hier, so ein Geschäftsessen, das wir vorhin hatten mit den Pizzen. Bewirtung. Bewirtungsbelegen. Da weiß ich ja genau, SKR 03, richtig? Bei der Bewirtung zum Beispiel darfst du ja nur 30% ansetzen, wenn es mit Geschäftspartnern, 70% ansetzen, wenn es mit Geschäftspartnern ist, außer das ist dein eigener Mitarbeiter, dann hast du 100%, aber auch nur unter bestimmten Umständen. Und sowas wird zum Beispiel von dieser Software einfach automatisiert mit berücksichtigt, dass er dann sozusagen das macht. Und die updaten natürlich das System permanent und passen es auch ständig an an die aktuellen Gesetze. Das machen die Local-Software natürlich auch. Aber es ist in der Cloud, meinem Gefühl nach, deutlich sympathischer, die gesamte User-Interface und die Geschwindigkeit, also die machen halt monatliche Updates, monatliche Feature-Updates und die ganze Integration mit allen wirklichen Cloud-Diensten, das ist halt wunderschön gemacht. Und es gibt 1000 Plugins, da kannst du sagen, ok, ich will Reise-Abbuchungen machen, ne? Dann verlinken sie dich einfach zu einem Reisekosten-Abrechner. Auch in der Cloud.
Wie heißt der Laden?
Der jetzt, wo ich bin, heißt Ceftest. Es gibt aber so drei, vier verschiedene, die auch ganz gut sind. Also LexOffice zum Beispiel ist auch ein ganz oker Anbieter. Also einfach online Buchhaltung mal eingeben in die verschiedenen Suchmaschinen. Da tauchen dann die großen Anbieter auf. Also ich glaube, in Deutschland gibt es insgesamt so 30, 40 verschiedene für kleine und mittlere Unternehmen. Und diese Anbindung auch in diese ganze sonstige Buchhaltungswelt. Der eine hat zum Beispiel das Problem, er muss Fahrtkosten ständig abbrechen. Und da gibt es halt einen Spezialanbieter, der nur Fahrtkosten, sozusagen dafür ein Interface gebaut hat. Und den kannst du dann integrieren, kannst du einfach in dein System reinpumpen oder eben Reisekosten einbuchen. Oder du hast meinetwegen einen Online-Store und verkaufst ständig T-Shirts. Ja, dann gibt es einfach ein Interface für deinen Online-Store und deine ganzen Rechnungen, die du verschickst an deine Kunden werden automatisch in deinen Links reingepumpt usw. Und dieses ganze Zusammenbinden von Dienstleistungen in der Cloud ist natürlich viel einfacher, als wenn du das alles vorher lokal realisieren willst. Das ist immer sozusagen schwieriger. Und jetzt gerade, wo diese ganze Fintech-Geschichte abgeht, ist natürlich auch, da öffnet sich gerade erst, wir fangen gerade, also wir jetzt, also diese Welt fängt gerade an, ein Universum zu werden an Möglichkeiten von Intervernetzung, von Banken, Buchhaltung, Steuer erklären usw. Und auch z.B. meine komplette Lohnabrechnung für meine Mitarbeiter mach ich in der Cloud. Ist auch wunderschön gelöst, super einfach. Diese Cloud-Software macht für mich auch die Anmeldung an die Soziale. Also ich bin wirklich als Nutzer, ich bin eigentlich Einzelselbstständiger und total unerfahren. Ich hab noch nie eine Person beschäftigt, aber du meldest dich da an, gibst einfach nur ein, wer du bist, was du machst und wie Geld du deinem Mitarbeiter geben willst und den ganzen Rest, also die Anmeldung bei der Sozialkasse, die Anmeldung bei der Rentenkasse, die Knappschaftsanmeldung, die Meldung ans Arbeitsamt. Das macht alles diese Software für dich automatisiert und nimmt dir einen riesen Berg an Arbeit ab. Haben die auch im Angebot, klar, können die auch machen. Und das kostet 5,90 Euro pro Mitarbeiter. Was unschlagbar günstig ist. Pro Monat. Aber zum Beispiel mein Steuerberater, wo ich es früher darüber gemacht hatte, meine Mitarbeiterbuchhaltung, der hat halt immer 19 Euro genommen, was auch schon sehr günstig war. Also sozusagen als Pauschale pro Monat. Aber klar, jeder, der eine Software programmiert, um ein Problem zu lösen, ist natürlich immer günstiger, als wenn ich eine Person damit beschäftige, die das alles manuell macht. Es kann einmal eine Software, das muss ich euch nicht erklären. Deswegen, ich finde gerade diese Cloud-Buchhaltung, das bedrückt mich so richtig. Das macht mir so richtig Spaß, weil es wieder so ein, wie du gesagt hast, Tim, man hat endlich mal wieder ein schönes Problem, was man wieder lösen kann, wo man so eine harmonische Lösung finden kann. Ich sage nicht, dass das alles irgendwie ausgelöst ist dort schon, aber es ist unglaublich spannend, was da an Möglichkeiten ist.
Was hast du denn noch getestet, außer LexOffice und ZEVDesk?
Ich habe mir eigentlich alle Buchhaltungssysteme angeschaut, aber ganz viele Buchhaltungssysteme scheitern eben daran, für mich aus meiner Perspektive, dass die Buchhaltung schlecht ist. Also, dass der Buchhaltungsteil, es gibt ganz viele Anbieter, die machen nur den Rechnungsteil, also sowas wie Fastbill, Easybill heißt der andere noch.
Also um selber Rechnung zu machen.
Die machen halt nur den Rechnungsteil und die haben so eine ganz rudimentäre Buchhaltung, aber die ist nicht kompatibel mit einer echten Finanzbuchhaltung, die du dann auch halbwegs seriös dem Finanzamt schicken kannst. Also, da muss man sich auf die Dienstleister gehen, die auch sozusagen eine Umsatzsteuer-Voranmeldung mit anbieten, weil nur diese Dienstleister haben sich ausreichend damit beschäftigt, dass du auch eine halbwegs legitime Umsatzsteuer-Voranmeldung machst.
Und die machen letzten Endes hinter den Kulissen natürlich auch richtige doppelte Buchhaltungen mit Standard-Kontenrahmen, den kann man auch anpassen und so.
Ja, das haben nicht alle, aber manchen. Bei Saftdex zum Beispiel kann man es anpassen, bei LexOffice kann man es nicht anpassen, da ist das begrenzt. Ja, es ist einfach nur schön. Ich meine vor allem, gerade alle höre mal da draußen, die irgendwas machen. Es gibt ja ganz viele Leute, die selbstständig sind als eine Person. Die meisten haben ja dann einen Steuerberater da draußen und kümmern sich um nichts, schicken denen die Rechnung. Das ist das wirklich Schöne, dass du das erste Mal das Gefühl bekommst, diesen Teil deines Geschäftes, wenn du selbstständig bist. Das ist völlig egal, wie klein du bist. Selbst wenn du nur über Davanda ein paar Stricksocken im Monat verkaufst, plötzlich dieses Gefühl zu haben, das zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert, und wieder das Gefühl zu bekommen, ich weiß, was meine Einnahmen sind, ich weiß, was meine Ausgaben sind, und wie das funktioniert und warum ich auf bestimmte welche Steuersitze so... Und man bekommt auch plötzlich ein Gefühl dafür, dass man in gewisser Weise, weil man versteht, wie das Steuersystem funktioniert, dann auch seine unternehmerische Entscheidung mehr in den Griff kriegt und weiß, wo gewisse Vor- und Nachteile sind. Dann kann man dann mitdenken im Hinterkopf, wenn man bestimmte unternehmerische, zum Beispiel, wann kaufe ich mir was? Wann im Jahr macht das Sinn?
Aber die Software kann nicht so gut bescheißen, wie mein Steuerberater.
Na ja, das würde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen sogar, weil die Software ist schon so, dass du letztlich alles sagen kannst.
Du kannst alles eingeben.
Du kannst alles eingeben. Und wenn du falsche Sachen eingibst, bescheißt du trotzdem. Du kannst ja sagen, ob du sozusagen einen Laptop, den du für dich selbst gekauft hast, als Unternehmensausgabe oder eine Stilatausgabe, das ist dir überlassen. Und der Betrug ist eher in dem Bereich möglich. Und das ist leider ungenommen.
Dieses Bull, die Jungs hier, die Visotrupper, die haben auch noch so ein Webding.
Nicht so richtig, weil ich glaube, die sind mehr so im Nachhinein online gegangen. Die kommen eben eigentlich aus dieser lokalen Software. Und das sind tendenziell nicht so die Erfolgreicheren, weil die immer versuchen, ihre lokale Software dann im Online im Internet abzubilden. Und die Startups, die oder die Unternehmens-Startups, ist der falsche Begriff, die sind teilweise schon seit zehn Jahren am Markt, die von Anfang an das als reines Web-App gemacht haben? Ich glaube, die, die die Zeit haben, halte ich für etwas erfolgreicher, weil die mit einer ganz anderen Denke rangehen.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, es ist auch nur diese Einkommensteuer-Geschichte. Aber die machen auch schon so ein bisschen. Für Selbstständige haben sie auch, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie weit das geht. Ich muss sagen, diese Visotools selber finde ich ganz gut für Einkommensteuer. Also die funktionieren ordentlich. Ach so, Letty will mal wieder das Mikrofon anhaben.
Ich nutze dir auch die Viso für Freelancing. Das ist großartig, einfach mal nichts vergessen. Dass du da einfach gefragt wirst und Hinweise. Das finde ich ganz gut auf jeden Fall.
Machen denn irgendwelche von diesen Online-Tools auch Einkommensteuererklärungen?
Ja, aber davon würde ich tendenziell abraten. Es kommt auf die Komplexität an, wenn du 20 Rechnungen im Jahr schreibst oder 100 Belege hast als Eingang. Wenn du keine transeuropäischen Rechnungen stellst, die außerhalb Deutschlands sind, oder wenn du keine Spezialfälle hast, dann kannst du das auch mit den Online-Tools tatsächlich machen. Die bieten dann sogar von Cefdes aus gibt es sozusagen wiederum Schnittstellen zu anderen, die dann für dich die komplette Einkommensteuererklärung machen. Aber das geht wirklich nur, wenn man simplere Unternehmen und das wirklich mehr so im Nebenberuf macht. Und man macht dann irgendwie drei Rechnungen.
Und der Nehmere hat dort die Einkommensteuererklärung nichts zu tun.
Also ich meine, das ist ja nur... Als Selbstständiger erklärst du ja am Ende nur die Einkommensteuer.
Ja gut, aber das einzige, was von deiner normalen Buchhaltung da drin landet, ist dein zu versteuerndes Einkommen und das Wahrsten. Der Rest ist ja der ganze andere Klimp mit Krankheitsdiensten.
Ich zum Beispiel habe Vorträge, die ich im Ausland halte und dann muss ich halt die Reverse-Steuer, Mehrwertsteuergeschichte machen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja Teil der Umsatzsteuergeschichte.
Richtig, gut, richtig. Aber ich möchte nur sagen, dass es eben Aspekte gibt von der Einkommensteuererklärung, aber auch, ja die sind etwas komplexer. Aber auch zum Beispiel, dass man da natürlich Spenden hat, dass du Reisekosten mit abrechnen musst. Wenn du das alles kannst und wenn du alle in diesen allen Aspekten so sicher bist, kannst du das auf jeden Fall über die Online-Tools machen. Ich persönlich fühle mich da noch nicht so sicher, dass ich diese komplette Einkommensteuer selbst machen würde. Und bin da relativ happy, dass ich da noch eine Steuerberaterin habe und die hat mir auch schon gute Hinweise gegeben. Und ja, das lohnt schon nochmal da am Ende. Ja, das stimmt. Allerdings ist das ja nicht zufällig, sondern es hängt halt damit zusammen, dass wir das komplizierteste Steuersystem der Welt haben.
Und das Steuerberater, der geschützteste Beruf in Deutschland ist überhaupt.
Ja, und die Hälfte der gesamten Weltliteratur über Steuern ist in deutscher Schiene.
Ja, kein Wunder. Also da, und das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, ne? Wir haben so ein mega kompliziertes Steuersystem, was eigentlich, naja, das ist eigentlich nicht total kompliziert. Es ist nur übersät mit Ausnahmen und Sonderregelungen. Das ist das eigentliche Problem. So, weil an sich ist das Ganze ja verhältnismäßig einfach. Das ist so eine Erkenntnis, die man halt so gewinnt, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt. Also die Grundstruktur ist, das ist ein bisschen wie mit dem Programmieren im Übrigen. Ja, das ist sozusagen, im Prinzip ist das erst mal ganz einfach, danach wird's dann etwas diverser. Und ich sehe schon den Trend, dass jetzt insbesondere durch diese webbasierte Buchhaltungsgeschichte, wir die Sache langsam so sehr in den Griff kriegen und dass jetzt hier sozusagen auch so ein Empowerment stattfindet. Und das kann ich eigentlich nur begrüßen und vermutlich geht das auch nur übers Web. Und da macht es irgendwie auch Sinn, also auch dieses Belegevorhalten und so weiter. Das ist schon so ein bisschen edel. Ich kann mir das jetzt irgendwie leisten und ich finde meinen Workflow soweit auch erst mal ganz gut, etwas besser integrierter hätte das. Hätte ich es auch gern, aber ich will auch irgendwie, naja, weiß ja, Kontrollfreak, ich will halt irgendwie in Kontroll sein. Und so Cloud-Dienste sind halt immer so, ne, du kannst nicht überall ran. Natürlich lässt mir jetzt meine Buchhaltungsstoffe mich auch nicht überall ran, das finde ich auch schon schlimm genug. Aber es ist ja noch mal eine andere Geschichte, wenn du überhaupt gar keinen direkten Zugang hast. Also ich werde das auf jeden Fall mal beobachten, mich interessiert das total und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man damit auch noch eine ganze Menge schmerzende Seelen aus ihren Depressionen befreien kann. Weil wie viele Leute das irgendwie in die Gräben spülen, das ist einfach nicht okay.
Zum Beispiel einfach die reine Tatsache, dass ich online meine Rechnung schreibe, sie online direkt aus der Software versende und sozusagen automatisch die Software mich nach drei Wochen erinnert. Der Kunde hat jetzt noch nicht gezahlt, weil auch meine Bankkonten fließen in diese Online-Software. Also Dennis wird gleich wieder schreien. Aber bei mir ist sowieso das mit dem Datenschutz, das ist halt alles verlorene Liebesmühe bei mir, aber das fließt da halt rein. Und meine Online-Software weiß, dass eine Rechnung noch nicht bezahlt ist und verschickt automatisiert sozusagen die Ermahnung. Sozusagen, hey, sie haben seit drei Wochen noch nicht die und die Rechnung bezahlt. Letzte Mahnung und so weiter und informiert mich dann wiederum darüber sozusagen über noch ausstehende Buchhaltung. Informiert mich auch darüber, welche Belege noch fehlen. Ich krieg ja immer einen Krampf, diese ganzen Amazon-Rechnungen, die einem nicht geschickt werden. Und meine Buchhaltungssoftware zeigt mir einfach, hey, hier, das sind ein Geld entgegen.
Eine Buchung ohne Beleg.
Genau, Buchung ohne Beleg. Du brauchst dann noch eine Rechnung. Und dann mein Get-My-Invoice, das ist ja die andere Software, die ich nutze, schickt automatisiert dann alle Einkäufe, die ich mache, denen automatisch diese bescheuerte, schicken sie verdammt noch mal eine Rechnung. Ja, das kann das. Es ist so, ja endlich, jemand hat das Problem gelöst. Und ähm, ähm, und ruft auch automatisch diese in diesen E-Mail, in diesem schrecklichen Amazon-E-Mail-Postfach hinterlegten Rechnungen auch automatisch ab. Die man ja sonst so immer so, wo ich immer nicht weiß, wo muss ich klicken, um in den Scheiß Amazon-Posteingang reinzukommen. Und das, das ruft das alles ab und da, wo eine Rechnung noch fehlt, verschickt es automatisch die E-Mail. Also, es ist einfach so ein Traum, weil so viele Probleme einfach so schön gelöst werden können, über dieses Internet. Also, dieses Internet, das glaub ich, wird sich durchsetzen.
Ein prophetischer Ausklang. Oh man, jetzt haben wir noch irgendwie genug Themen auf unserer Liste für noch zwei, drei Sendungen, aber ich glaube, wir müssen langsam mal...
Die letzte Bahn fährt gleich.
Die letzte Bahn fährt gleich, genau. Hier wird schon das große T an die Wand gemalt.
Das war aber eine ziemliche, Tim out, ja. Das war eine ziemliche Luftwand hier.
Sebastian, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Das war so erhellend und bereichernd, wie ich es erwartet hatte. Und alle anderen sagen auch Tschüss. Wir setzen das fort, Sebastian.
Macht eure Steuern alle.
Genau, macht eure Steuern. In der Cloud oder nicht. Tschüss.